NNSL. GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON.
IT'S A GOOD MORNING OR
AFTERNOON.
IT'S RATHER ODD YEAH IS IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE WILL THAT.
BEGIN TODAY'S
HEARING OF ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION FINANCE.
TODAY OF COURSE WERE IN A FOCUS
ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
UPON OF THE BUDGET IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
PROPOSALS I DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YES WE WON'T TAKE ROLE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING A ROBUST
DISCUSSION TODAY WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OUR ILIO.
AND.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES CSU AND
YOU SEEN. TALKING ABOUT THAT
CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
OUR STATE BUDGET.
HIGHER EDUCATION AFFORDABILITY
FOR COLLEGE AND ACCESS AND.
AND FOCUS ON THOSE MUTUAL
IMPORTANT GOALS I CERTAINLY LAST
FOR YEARS WE'VE WE'VE UP.
HAD IF YOU ARE POSITIVE STEPS IN
MAKING HIGHER EDUCATION MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR. A
CALIFORNIANS INCREASING
FINANCIAL AID AND CUTE
INCREASING ACCESS FOR
UNDERGRADUATES AT THE UC SYSTEM
WITH TWO HUNDRED NEW
UNDERGRADUATE SLOTS.
LARGELY DUE TO OUR WORK.
WITH THE UC SYSTEM THE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE WORKING TO
IDENTIFY SAVINGS TO PAY FOR
THOSE NEW ENROLLMENTS LOTS.
ARE CSU SYSTEM I GREW BY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON OUR
GRADUATION. INITIATIVES
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WE
MADE OUR GREAT STRIDES AS WELL
INCREASE FINANCIAL AID. THE LAST
YEAR'S ARE THE CONVERSATION
WHICH LED TO THE FINAL BUT TODD
BILL IN OF THE YEAR FOCUSING ON
MAKING. A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FREE.
THE FIRST TIME FOR ALL.
FULL TIME I FIRST TIME
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS SO
THAT'S A GOODA STARTING OFF.
POINTS
AT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGETS.
.
CERTAINLY HAS SOME ISSUES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE DIGGING INTO
IN THE UPCOMING MONTHS.
JUST KIND THE BUZZ AROUND THE
BUDGET SO FAR IS ALL THE MONEY
WENT TO THE RAINY DAY. OR TWO
LAPTOP NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION SO
FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CERTAINLY WE
SAW A LOT OF. AT EFFORTS AND
INITIATIVES AND AND THOSE
FRONTS.
UC AND CSU AND MINIMAL
INCREASES WHICH ARE CONCERNING
WILL ADDRESS THOSE AS WELL AS
MINIMAL INCREASES IN OUR.
STUDENT AID.
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PIECE THERE
ARE A FEW HIGH PROFILE PROPOSALS
WILL START THE DISCUSSIONS
TODAY.
I KNOW THERE ARE.
MANY QUESTIONS AND FRANKLY MANY
MORE QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
RELATED TO SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSALS I WILL. ADD BEGIN
THAT.
DISCUSSION TODAY ABA WITH WITH
THAT WE WILL AND I BEGIN THESE
PROCEEDINGS ANY OPENING. AYE
COMMENTS FOR MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER VOEPEL.
A SEEING NINE WE WILL START BY
BRINGING UP THEIR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE LA OPEN TO GIVE
US AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROPOSALS
.
WE'LL START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE
.
PASSAGE OF PROP THIRTY IN
TWENTY.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TOTAL.
RE POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IT'S MADE UP OF
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION GENERAL FUND AND
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES AND
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN POINT TWO
BILLION. OF OTHER FUNDS AT THIS
TOTAL REFLECTS BOTH FUNDING I'D.
AT DIRECTLY TO THE PUBLIC
SEGMENTS AND FUNDING OF FOR
FINANCIAL AID THAT STUDENTS MAY
USE AT ELIGIBLE INSTITUTIONS.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE WITH AND
WITH THE INCREASES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDING FOR
THE UC WILL HAVE GROWN BY ONE
POINT TWO BILLION FOR THE CSU BY
ONE POINT SIX BILLION AND FOR
THE COMMUNICATIVE BY TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
CONTINUED INVESTMENT HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WILL WORK TOGETHER TO IMPLEMENT
NEW AND CREATIVE PRACTICES THAT
CONSIDER COST OF INSTRUCTION. TO
BETTER SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS
AND COMPLETION AND TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
WHAT THIS ALL DESCRIBE THE
GOVERNOR'S BY BUDGET PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND HOW THOSE
INVESTMENTS REALLY TIGHT BACK TO
THIS SCHOOL OF AND ACCESS WITH
SUCCESS?
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES NINE POINT TWO BILLION
IN FUNDING FOR COMMUNICATIVE AS
AN ADULT EDUCATION WHEN
ACCOUNTING FOR AVAILABLE PROP
MAYBE GENERAL FUNDS A LOCAL
REVENUES AND FEES.
I THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT AND
NUMEROUS CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
BEFORE I DESCRIBE IT THE
SPENDING PROPOSAL IS I WANT TO
BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
RECENT INITIATIVES AND
DEVELOPMENTS OF THE
COMMUNICATIVE DRESS. POTS TO
HELP FRAME IN THE INVESTMENTS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE STATE HAS MADE VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS IN RECENT YEARS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS THIS
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
AND SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES UP PLANNING AND
SERVICES TO MATRICULATE AT
STUDENTS. AND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE MILLION.
FOR EQUITY PLANS TO MITIGATE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
ACCESS AND ACHIEVEMENTS OF
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS
AS WELL AS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING TO
DEVELOP GUIDED PATHWAYS UP
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE INTEGRATED
INSTITUTION WIDE. APPROACHES
FOCUSED ON STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
A RECENT DEVELOPMENT AT THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND JULY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE BOARD OF
STRATEGIC PLAN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS TO IMPROVE COMMUNICATIVE
STUDENT SUCCESS. AND THE PLAN
CALLS FOR THE SYSTEM TO MEET
SPECIFIC GOALS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE COMPLETION TRANSFER
RATES TO DECREASE ACCESS UNITS
TAKEN BY STUDENTS. AND TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
STUDENTS WHO ARE EMPLOYED IN
THEIR FEEL LESS OF STUDYING AS
WAS TO ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS REALLY
FOCUS ON A BATH AND THEN THEME
AT THE SYSTEMS NEW STRATEGIC
PLAN AND BUILD UPON THE
INVESTMENTS INCIDENTS CASSETTES
OF THE PRIOR YEARS.
SO I WANNA START BY TALKING
ABOUT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR A NEW STUDENT CENTERED UP
FUNDING FORMULA FOR GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT.
SO THE EXISTING FUNDING.
FOR GENERAL PURPOSE
APPORTIONMENT SET UP FOR THE
COMMUNITY HALL EDGES IS BASED ON
A ROMANCE OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS.
THIS CAUSES DISTRICTS TO
PRIORITIZE AND ROAMING GROWTH
AND CREATE SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIPS
FOR DISTRICTS THAT ARE DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS. FURTHER THAT'S A
ROMAN BASED.
APPORTIONMENT FUNNY MODEL DOES
NOT A PROPERLY REFLECT THAT
GOALS OF THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
OR IN THE STATE'S PRIORITIES TO
BETTER SERVE STUDENTS TO
ELIMINATE. AYE UNTIL THE MADE
EQUITY GAPS GIVEN THAT IT'S ONLY
REWARDS ENROLLMENT WITHOUT ANY
OTHER CONSIDERATION FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS METRICS.
TO BETTER INCENTIVE AND REWARD
STUDENT SUCCESS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA AND THERE ARE THREE
COMPONENTS TO THAT FUNDING
FORMULA.
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE FUNDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
TO DISTRICTS THROUGH A BASE CRAP
AND THAT'S BASED ON A ROMANCE A
VERY SIMILAR TO THE EXISTING. I
HAVE FUNDING FORMULA AS A WAY TO
REALLY PROTECT AND ACCESS.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE FUNDS
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO DO TO
DISTRICTS THROUGH A SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT THAT WOULD BE BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THAT THE DISTRICT A ROLES.
AND THEN TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE FUNDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH A STUDENT SUCCESS GRANT
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
RECEIVE A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE
AND THE NUMBER STUDENTS WHO
COMPLETE. THEIR DEGREE
CERTIFICATE OR TRANSFER IN THREE
YEARS OR LESS.
ADDITIONALLY THE STUDENT SUCCESS
INCENTIVE GRAB WHAT INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR EACH
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
GRANTED BY THE COLLEGE AS A WAY
TO FURTHER AND SENT THAT
SEAMLESS TRANSFER.
THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO BALANCE
THE NEED TO MAINTAIN ACCESS
WHILE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO ENCOURAGE ACCESS FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS. AND
REWARDING COLLEGES PROGRESS ON
IMPROVING STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE ALSO THINK THAT THAT PROPOSED
FUNDING FORMULA WOULD AT GREATER
FISCAL STABILITY TO THE COLLEGES
BUDGET SINCE I MOVED AWAY FROM A
MODEL THAT'S JUST BASS ARE A
MOMENT. WE KNOW THAT WHEN
ECONOMIC TIMES ARE GOOD
COMMITTEE COLLEGE REMAINS FLAT
OR DECLINES. OUT WHICH IS WHAT
MANY COLLEGES ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING THIS PROPOSAL
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLLEGES TO GROW FISCALLY AT
THREE.
AT A BY IMPROVING ONS SPECIFIC
STUDENT SUCCESS METRICS.
TO SUPPORT THE DISTRICT
TRANSITION TO THE NEW AS A
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
PROPOSITION. GENERAL FUND TO
ENSURE THAT NO DISTRICT RECEIVES
AT LESS RELATIVE TO THE EXISTING
FUNDING FORMULA.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
TWO POINT FIVE ONE COSTS LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. TO APPORTIONMENT AND
SIXTY MILLION PROP NINETY EIGHT
UP GENERAL FUND FOR WILL PRESENT
GROWTH AND ACCESS IS SO THESE
FUNDS WILL BE BUILT INTO AT THE
BASE RESOURCES OF THE NEW
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA.
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO A
POPULATION OF WORKING ADULTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT ACCESSING
COMMITTEE COLLEGESTHE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME IN
TWENTY MILLION ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. TO DEVELOP OF AN ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN THE
PRIME WORKING AGE IS BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY FOUR WILL
ONLY HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR SOME COLLEGE BUT NO DEGREE.
AND WARREN LOW PAYING JOBS THE
FOCUS OF THE COLLEGE WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE SHORT TERM CERTIFICATES
AND STACKABLE CREDENTIALS WITH
LABOR MARKET VALUE. TO HELP THIS
POPULATION HAVE BETTER.
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES.
KEY FEATURES OF THE COLLEGE
WHICH I KNOW WILL DISCUSS IT
FURTHER DETAIL I'M INCLUDE IF
FLEXIBLE COURSE SCHEDULING AND
START TIMES NOT TIED TO THE
TYPICAL ACADEMIC CALENDAR AND.
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION I
RECOGNIZE THIS PRIOR LEARNING
AND SPECIALIZED SUPPORT SERVICES
INCLUDING ON ON DEMAND SUPPORT
SERVICES SIDE.
AT TIMES LATE AT NIGHT OR ON
THE WEEKENDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSALS PROPOSE A SEVERAL
INVESTMENTS TO MAINTAIN
AFFORDABILITY AND FOR THEIR
SUPPORT STUDENTS ABILITY TO
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY WAY.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES FORTY SIX
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE ARE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WHICH AUTHORIZES
DISTRICTS TO WAIVE. FEES FOR ALL
FIRST TIME FULL TIME STUDENTS OR
SPEND THE FUNDS FOR OTHER
PURPOSES TO ADVANCE SPECIFY
STUDENT SUCCESS SCHOOLS.
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES THIRTY
TWO POINT NINE MILLION TO
CONSOLIDATE THE FULL TIME
STUDENT SUCCESS GRANT AND THE
COMPLETION GRANT EITHER TO
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THAT
TARGET THE SAME SOCIO ECONOMIC.
A STUDENT COHORT BUT HOW
DIFFERENT I REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING DIFFERENT UNIT LOADS.
SO THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
CONSOLIDATE CONSOLIDATE THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS SHIP TRIP PER UNIT
GRANT AMOUNTS AND ALSO AUGMENT
THE UNDERLYING GRANTS TO PROVIDE
MORE COST OF ATTENDANCE
FINANCIAL AID FOR STUDENTS.
I'M GOING TO HELL I'D AS AT THE
PROPOSALS FOR THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS I SPECIFICALLY THE
BUDGET PROPOSES THIRTY POINT SIX
MILLION ONE TIME PROP
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
TO FUND SHORTFALLS IN RELATED
AND SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION
REIMBURSEMENTS IN PRIOR YEARS.
AS WELL AS SEVENTEEN POINT EIGHT
ON GOING TO REIMBURSE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR THE
ESTIMATED AND STRUCTURAL
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS AT IN YOU
RELATED AND SUPPLEMENTARY
STRUCTURING.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT IT AROUND OF
INNOVATION AWARDS. AT THIS
PROGRAM WILL HAVE IT WOULD HAVE
A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON FUNDING
INNOVATIONS THAT CLOSE EQUITY
COLLAPSE INCLUDING REGIONAL
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
I'M TO HELP ADVANCE THOSE
SCHOOLS AND THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
AND FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND INSTRUCTIONAL
APPOINTMENT. AND INCLUDES FIVE
NEW PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE BOND
FUNDED PROJECTS.
I'M THINKING AND WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW FOR THAT
UNIVERSITIES.
SURE ALL BEGIN WITH UNIVERSITIES
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MAY REVISION
BUCKET SUMMARY THE GOVERNORSHIP
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
THREE PERCENT. OF BASS INCREASE
FOR BOTH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS REPRESENTS AN
INCREASE OF NINETY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR EACH
OF THE STE UP THE CSU ON THE AND
THE YOU SEE. THE U. SKIRT THE
CSU REPORTS AND ROLLING ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS UNDER TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. THE TWENTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN BUDGET PROPOSES
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE CSU. INCLUDED IN THIS AMOUNT
IS THE NINE THE PREVIOUSLY NOTED
NINETY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION GENERALLY
EXPECTS THAT THESE FUNDS WOULD
BE USED BY THE CSU TO SUPPORT
ITS ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
AS YOU MAY RECALL THE CSU
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ADOPTED BY THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN. COMMITS THE UNIVERSITY
TRAINED VICIOUS GRADUATION GOALS
INCREASING THE FOR YOUR RATE O
AT LEAST FORTY PERCENT
INCREASING THE TO YOUR TRANSFER
RATE. TO LEAST FORTY FIVE
PERCENT AND CLOSING GAPS IN
OUTCOMES BETWEEN THE TARGET OF
STUDENTS AND THEIR PEERS.
THE TEN UC CAMPUSES AND ROLL TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH ANOTHER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THEIR EXTENSION
PROGRAMS.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET PROPOSES APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION IN
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDED IN THIS
AMOUNT IS THE PREVIOUSLY NOTED
NINETY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION FOR
THE UNIVERSITY.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
RECOGNITION OF REVISED
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX REVENUE
SUPPORTING GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
MONITOR PROGRESS TOWARD MEETING
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE UC. UP
REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SPECIFICALLY
THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CONDITION THE RELEASE OF FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
BASED UPON THE U. T. ACHIEVING
CERTAIN I COMMITMENTS.
DOES INCLUDE ACHIEVING
COMMITMENTS MADE THEN THE
AGREEMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR
RELATED TO ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING. AND TARGET MOMENT OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS.
ADOPTING RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
STATE AUDITOR. HA TO ADD TO THE
UC BOARD OF REGENTS ON THE U.
COPD.
ELIMINATING CERTAIN BENEFITS
FOR YOU SEE SENIOR MANAGERS AND
COMMITTING TO DISCLOSE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AS PART
OF THE ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS.
IN TERMS OF TUITION BOTH
SEGMENTS OF NOW CONSIDER TUITION
INCREASES FOR THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR.
THE BUDGET REITERATES THAT ANY
TUITION INCREASES MUST BE MADE
ONLY IN THE CONTEXT OF REDUCING
OVERALL. MUST BE MADE IN THE
CONTEXT OF REDUCING THE OVERALL
COST STRUCTURE YOU SEE AN
IMPROVING THEIR GRADUATION RATES
AT CSU.
TUITION INCREASES WITHOUT THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WOULD ONLY BURDEN
FAMILIES WHAT THE COST OF AN
INEFFICIENT SYSTEM.
ANY INCREASES WOULD ALSO HAVE
IMPACTS ON THE STATE BUDGET.
SPECIFICALLY THE INCREASE OF THE
GOVERNOR THE GOVERNING BOARDS
ARE CONSIDERING WOULD GROW CAL
GRANT COSTS FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
BY OVER TWENTY MILLION.
ANNUALLY AND FORCE CSU STUDENTS
BY OVER TWENTY MILLION ANNUALLY
COMMENCING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. BEYOND THE COSTS THAT
ARE REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
WITHOUT WILL CLOSE AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO HAVE TURNED.
THANK YOU HELLO.
AND JENNIFER CAN LEAD TO
ANALYST'S OFFICE I YOU SHOULD
HAVE A COPY OF OUR REPORT WE
HAVE RELEASED ANNOUNCES OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS LAST WEEK.
I'M GONNA SPEAK FROM IT JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW POINTS FROM IT.
I'M GONNA KEEP MY COMMENTS
HIGHER LEVEL RECOGNIZING YOU GO
THROUGH ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUES
AND COMING HEARINGS. IT'S GONNA
START WITH A FEW COMMENTS ON THE
HIGHER AND LANDSCAPE MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE
UNIVERSITY IS A COUPLE COMMENTS
ON THE COLLEGE AS.
SO STARTING WITH SOME COMMENTS
ON ELVES ABILITY TO GO TO UC AND
CSU.
SINCE THE MASTER PLAN IN
NINETEEN SIXTY WAS ADOPTED THE
STATE'S CONDUCTED ELEVEN OUNCE
ABILITY STUDIES.
ON THE STUDY IS.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE TO PAGE
SIX YOU CAN SEE THE RESULTS OF
ALL OF THOSE STUDIES FIRST
YOSHIO.
THE INTENT OF THE STUDY IS AGAIN
ONCE TO SYRIA UC AND CSU FOR
THEIR FRESHMAN ADMITS FOR DRYING
FROM WITHIN THE MASTER PLAN
POOLS. THE MASTER PLAN SET UP
PULLED BACK YOU SEE WOULD DROP
FROM THE TOP ONE EIGHT COLLEGES
COULD SEE IF SHE WOULD DROP FROM
THE TOP THIRD.
YOU CAN SEE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE ZERO SHE WAS TRYING FROM
ABOVE THAT LEVEL AND ONE OF THEM
AND TONS OF THE MASTER PLAN WAS
TO TRY TO. ENCOURAGE YOUR
STUDENTS TO GO DIRECTLY TO CSU
MORE TO GO TO THE U. AT THE
COLLEGES AND TRANSFER THERE
AFTER.
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT SOMETIMES A
COUPLE TIMES DURING THE EIGHTIES
YES USE PULL WAS TOO SMALL. AND
IT WAS LOOSENING ADMISSION
CRITERIA AND RESPONSE
WHERE YOU SEE IS TODAY UNDER THE
MOST RECENT STUDY AS A FORTY ONE
PERCENT SO ABOVE THE MASTER
PLAN.
GOALS.
UC WAS FOUND TO BE A FOURTEEN
PERCENT SO SOMEONE ABOVE THAT
TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT SIDE
UNDER A MASTER PLAN.
SO THE ISSUE AND THIS YEAR IS
WHETHER THE STATE MAY
UNIVERSITIES SHOULD ADJUST THEIR
ADMISSION CRITERIA TO GET BACK
TO THE MASTER PLAN ELIGIBILITY
POOLS OR CHANGE THE MASTER PLAN
ON STABILITY POOLS AND ALLOW
BOTH THE UNIVERSITY SEGMENT SO
REMAIN ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU WERE TO GO BACK TO.
THE MORE TRADITIONAL POOLS YOU
WOULD HAVE THE OBVIOUS BENEFIT
OF LOWER STATE COSTS LOWER
STUDENT COSTS
IF YOU EXPANDED THE POOL YOU
WOULD HAVE THE OBVIOUS BENEFIT
OF ALLOWING MORE STUDENTS TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE STATEMENTS.
THERE'S TWO OTHER CONSIDERATIONS
AMONGST MANY THAT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER.
THE FIRST IS THAT.
IS THINKING ABOUT TODAY IS
GRADUATION EXPECTATIONS SO
CALIFORNIA HAS THE COMMON CORE
STATE STANDARDS MOST STATES DO
CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTED IT IS USING
THEM. UNDER THE COMMON CORE
STATE STANDARDS EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE IS EXPECTED TO
BE PREPARED FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER. YOU'VE HEARD PROBABLY
ABOUT THE STATE'S SCHOOL
DASHBOARD WE USE IT TO EVALUATE
DISTRICT PERFORMANCE AS PART OF
THAT DASHBOARD WE HAVE THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR. IT MEASURES THE SHARE
OF THAT A DISTRICT STUDENTS THAT
ARE PREPARED FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER APPROACHING PREPARED
UNPREPARED.
SO I THINK THE QUESTION ITS LAST
WHETHER STUDENTS SHOULD BE
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER
AND MORE HOW DOES THE CALIFORNIA
ONE A DESIGN THAT'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND TO WHAT
EXTENT DOES IT WANT TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO DO THEIR LOWER
DIVISION COURSEWORK AFTER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. OR ENCOURAGE
THEM TO RURAL DIRECTLY AT YOU
SEE ARE CSU.
THE SECOND COMMENT SPAM FACTOR
YOU MIGHT WANT TO TAKE IN MIND I
KEEP IN MIND IS OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS THE STATE AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL EFFORTS IMPROVE THE
TRANSFER PATHWAY. IF YOU LOOK
COMPETE JUST FORTY FIVE AND
FORTY FOUR AND FORTY FIVE YOU
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT NOW BUT WE
GO AT LENGTH INTO THESE VARIOUS
EFFORTS THAT THE STATE COLLEGES.
HAVE MADE.
I'M OF THOSE EFFORTS AGAIN ARE
TRYING TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS TO TRANSFER INCREASING
THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING
ACCEPTED INCREASING THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING OUT OF CSU
WITHIN TWO YEARS OF ADDITIONAL
WORK IN GETTING A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. SO CONSIDERABLE EFFORTS
IN THOSE AREAS.
SO TURNING TO ENROLLMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE FOR PITCH
AIDS.
AND IT JUST SHOWS A GROWTH IN
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT GROWTH IS
SLOW IN IF YOU WERE TO LOOK FROM
TWO THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT. THE AVERAGE ANNUAL GROWTH
WAS TWO POINT EIGHT PERCENT.
IF YOU LOOK FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINE TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AT
SLOW IN ZERO POINT SIX.
AND.
IF YOU LOOK OUT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT NUMBER OF YEARS IT'S
PROJECTED TO SLOW EVEN FURTHER
TWO ZERO POINT THREE PERCENT.
SO THIS I HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LIKELIHOOD
YOU'D SEE REQUESTS FROM UC AND
CSU ASKING FOR NEW SPACE.
YOU SEE ANSWER TO CLEARLY HAS
AGING FACILITIES SO YOU'D EXPECT
THE IT WAS CONTINUE TO SEE
REQUESTS FOR RENEWAL AND
RENOVATIONS BUT IT WOULD BE LESS
LIKELY. THAT BASED UPON
DEMOGRAPHIC GROWTH YOU'D BE SEEN
I REQUEST FOR NEW CAPITAL.
TURNING TO AFFORDABILITY. IF YOU
LOOK AT FIGURE EIGHTS PAGE
THIRTEEN.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THE COLLEGE'S
FEW LEVELS ARE RATHER RELATIVE
TO SOMEWHERE INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN SEE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CSU RATES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STILL NOTABLY
LOWER THAN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. BUT COLLEGES THEIR
TUITION LEVELS LESS THAN HALF OF
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
CSU IS LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE BY SIXTEEN PERCENT THIS
THE GUINNESS FIGURE EIGHT ON
PAGE THIRTEEN.
YOU SEE IN CONTRAST WAS HIGHER
THAN THEIR AVERAGE OF SIMILAR
INSTITUTIONS TWENTY ONE PERCENT
HIGHER.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE NINE. PAGE
FOURTEEN JUST THE NEXT PAGE YOU
CAN SEE JUST HOW VOLATILE FEE
LEVELS HAVE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN SEE YEARS OF STEEP
INCREASE THOSE FOLLOWED BY FLAP
PERIODS. THE STEEP INCREASES ARE
DURING RECESSIONS ECONOMIC
SLOWDOWNS TIMES WHEN FAMILIES
ARE. LIKELY THEIR ECONOMIC
SITUATIONS ARE SOMEWHAT MORE
DIFFICULT YOU CONCEIVE FLAT
PERIODS DURING THE ECONOMIC
EXPANSIONS DURING PERIODS WHEN
FAMILY'S ECONOMIC SITUATIONS
TEND TO BE IMPROVING.
WE'VE RECOMMENDED FOR YEARS THAT
THE STATE HAVE A TUITION POLICY
THAT WOULD WORK VERY DIFFERENTLY
SO UNDER THE FEE POLICY THERE
WOULD BE GRADUAL MODEST
INCREASES DURING GOOD TIMES WHEN
FAMILIES WAGES ARE LIKELY TO BE
GOING UP SOMEWHAT.
AND THEN IF THE STATE HOW TO
RESERVE AND IF THERE WERE EVER A
TIME WHERE RATES WOULD BE FLAT
IT WOULD BE DURING RECESSIONS
WHEN FAMILIES WHICH IS LIKELY
WOULD NOT BE INCREASED IN ARE
INCREASING AS MUCH. THAT COULD
ONLY BE DONE AGAIN AT THE STATE
WERE SITTING ON A HALF RESERVE.
IF YOU HAVE.
.
LOOK IT JUST FIGURE ELEVEN HERE
ON THE FACING PAGE YOU CAN SEE
ALL OF THE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE HAS FOR
UNDERGRADUATES.
.
AND YOU CAN I AM I'M SORRY YOU
CAN SEE FROM HERE THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS NUMBER OF AID
PROGRAMS CONFERENCE IT PROGRAM
SO ARE AMONGST THE MOST GENEROUS
IN THE COUNTRY ARGUABLY THE MOST
GENEROUS.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE TWELVE ON
PAGE SIXTEEN YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE AID PROGRAMS ARE LARGELY
WORKING AS INTENDED.
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE JUST LOOKING
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AS AT THE LOWEST INCOME
FAMILY THOSE MAKING UNDER THIRTY
THOUSAND. YOU CAN SEE THAT NOT
PRICE FOR THIS FAMILY IS A
LITTLE BIT LESS THAN SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU CAN SEE AS
FAMILY'S INCOME LEVELS GO UP THE
NAP PRICE GOES UP.
TO TRY TO GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT
FOR THIS COMMUNICATES STUDENT
THEIR TUITION WOULD BE COVERED
SO THE SIX THOUSAND WOULD BE ON
MATT LIVING COSTS IF THE STUDENT
WERE TO WORK FIFTEEN HOURS A
WEEK DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR AND
FULL TIME DURING THE SUMMER AT
MINIMUM WAGE THAT MAKE. ABOUT
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS TO JUST
TO GIVE YOU A CONTEXT OF WHAT
THIS LOOKS LIKE. AT THE STUDENT
LEVEL.
SO MAKING JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY IS AND THEN
FINISHING WITH THAT COLLEGES.
EVERY YEAR THE TO KEEP TO KEEP
COST DRIVERS AMONG MANY ARE FOR
USE INSTANCE YOUR EMPLOYEE
COMPLICATE POLITELY.
SO THINKING ABOUT EMPLOYEE COM.
AND.
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE EIGHTEEN
ON PAGE TWENTY THREE.
I MEAN YOU CAN SEE JUST A
COMPARISON OF UC FULL PROFESSOR
AVERAGE SALARIES COMPARED TO
SOME SIMILAR INSTITUTIONS.
I'M AYE BOTH YOU CA AND CSU THE
MOST RECENT DATA SUGGESTING THAT
SALARIES ARE STILL COMPETITIVE.
THIS SHOWS THAT BEAR HIGHER THAN
THAT FOR PUBLIC COMPARISON
INSTITUTIONS VIRGINIA MICHIGAN
BUFFALO URBANA CHAMPAIGN. AS
WELL AS NOTABLY HIGHER THAN ALL
SIMILAR PUBLIC RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I'M FIRST YES YOU THE MOST
RECENT STUDY SHOWS THAT FACULTY
SALARIES ARE AT SLIGHTLY ABOVE
SIMILAR COMPARISON INSTITUTIONS.
THE DATA WE ALSO HAVE ON WHETHER
THE CAMPUSES ARE ABLE TO GET
THEIR FIRST CHOICE CANDIDATE
SHOW THAT IT STILL HIGH. THAT
TURNOVER RATES ARE STILL VERY
LOW.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
CS YOU HAVE FROM THE MID TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO MED TWENTY NINETEEN
AND YOU LOOK AT THEIR CONTRACTS
THE CUMULATIVE GENERAL SALARY
INCREASE THE SEVENTEEN POINT SIX
PERCENT TAX YES YOU. SO NOTABLY
ABOUT WHAT I'M SOME OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEE GROUPS ARE RECEIVING.
SO LOOKING AT CAPITAL OUTLAY.
.
IF YOU I'D TURN TO FIGURE TWENTY
EIGHT PAGE FORTY.
I'M I'M SORRY I'M IT FIGURE
TWENTY THREE ON PAGE TWENTY NINE
STARTED TO SUCH A STRICT.
.
SO ADAM IS SO I'M CAPITAL OUTLAY
HERE WE JUST HAVE WE HAVE STE
NOTABLE ISSUES WITH BOTH UC AND
CSU IS CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUEST
THEY WANNA JUST EMPHASIZE THREE.
I'M OUR FIRST IS HAVING TO DO
WITH THE JUSTIFICATION FOR NEW
SPACE NORMALLY WHEN THE SEGMENTS
WHAT'S THE MET AND REQUEST YOU
FOR NEW SPACE. THEY WERE TOLD
TELL YOU HOW MUCH OF EXISTING
SPACE IS BEING USED THEY WOULD
THINK ABOUT SUMMER AND TO THE
EXTENT THEY'RE USING SOME ARE.
AYE WE DIDN'T GET THAT KIND OF
QUALITY BACK UP THIS YEAR.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO JUSTIFY A
NEW FACILITIES WHEN YOU LOOK AT
UC SYSTEM WIDE THERE'S NOTABLE
EXISTING ON YOU'D SPACE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT MOST CSU CAMPUSES
PARTICULARLY ACCOUNTING FOR SOME
ARE. THERE'S NOTABLE EXISTING
CAPACITY.
OUR SECOND NOTABLE CONCERN IS
WITH CONSTRUCTION COSTS SO HERE
IF YOU LOOK AT FIGURE TWENTY
THREE ON PAGE TWENTY NINE. UC
HAS SUBMITTED REQUESTS FOR FOR
NEW ACADEMIC BUILDINGS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE AVERAGE
COST PER ASSIGNABLE SQUARE FOOT
IS VARYING FROM A LOW OF SEVEN
HUNDRED ROUGHLY AT SAN DIEGO TO
FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT AT SANTA CRUZ.
THE DIFFERENCE IS NOT BEEN
EXPLAINED BY THE TYPE OF SPACE
SO THIS IS PRIMARILY A CLASSROOM
SPACE FACULTY OFFICE SPACE.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS CSU HAD
CONSTRUCTION COSTS GUIDELINES
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY
STILL INTERNALLY HAVE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS GUIDELINES WE
DID AN EXTENSIVE REVIEW BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO OF THOSE.
GUIDELINES AND CONCLUDED THEY
WERE REASONABLE.
ALL WE DID THIS TIME IS TAKE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION COST
INDEX AN UPDATE THOSE IF YOU
WERE TO DO THAT THE GOING RATE
FOR A CLASSROOM WOULD BE FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT. IF YOU DID A FOR
OFFICE SPACE A BEFORE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT.
SO THESE RATES ARE NOTABLY
HIGHER.
JUST AS A REMINDER OF THE
GOVERNOR WHEN THEY TRIED THIS
NEW CAP OUTLAY SYSTEM OF
COLLAPSING CAPITOL IN SUPPORT
DID SO WITH THE HOPE THAT IT
WOULD MAKE THE TRADE OFF BETWEEN
CAPITAL AND SUPPORT MORE
OBVIOUS.
AND THAT IT WOULD CONSTRUCT
CONTROL CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
AND THAT'S CLEARLY NOT WHAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEN AT ANY OF THE
SEGMENT SINCE THE STATE STARTED
THE NEW SYSTEM.
AND WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
CHANGES AND SCOPE AND COST
AND.
.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT NOW FIGURE
TWENTY EIGHT PAGE FORTY.
THE STATE LAST YEAR PROVE
SEVERAL CSU PROJECTS AND SEE IF
SHE WASN'T ABLE TO PROCEED WITH
THE PROJECTS AND IN SOME
INSTANCES RESUBMITTED THE
PROJECTS FOR THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN SEE HERE ON FIGURE
TWENTY EIGHT JUST FOR AN EXAMPLE
NORTHRIDGE CAMPUS LAST YEAR
SUBMITTED A PROPOSAL FOR
RENOVATION BUILDING THAT WOULD
COST FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND THIS YEAR IS ASKING FOR A
NEW BUILDING THAT WOULD COST A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE SAN BERNADINE NOPE
CAMPUS LAST YEAR CAME IN ASKING
FOR A NEW BUILDING AT SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION AS ASKING THIS
YEAR FOR AND A RENOVATED
BUILDING AN ADDITION OF A
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN MILLION.
WHETHER IT BE JUSTIFICATION FOR
NEW SPACE CONSTRUCTION COSTS PER
SQUARE FOOT OR SCOPE AND COST
CHANGES THESE ARE NOT KINDS OF.
ISSUES WE WOULD HAVE SEEN AS
NOTABLY UNDER THE OLD SYSTEM SO
WE THINK THESE ARE ALL. A REALLY
SERIOUS SIGNALS OF A PROBLEM
WITH THE NEW SYSTEM.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE GOT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE STATEMENTS
REVISIT THEM RESUBMIT THEM TO
USE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE BETTER
JUSTIFICATION ON BEFORE YOU
PROCEED FORWARD.
IF YOU DON'T GET BETTER
JUSTIFICATION I'M WORSE
ADJUSTING THAT FIRST ISSUE FOR
EXAMPLE THESE PROJECTS THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO DO ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH AN INCREASE IN DEBT SERVICE
COSTS OF ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION.
IF YOU'RE NOT SATISFIED THE BUT
THE REQUEST YOU WOULD TAKE THAT
THIRTEEN MILLION A REPURPOSE
THAT FOR HIGHER. UP PRIORITIES
WITHIN YOUR BUDGET.
AB SO I GET AGAIN BECAUSE THE
COSTS HAVE BEEN SO HIGH AND
BECAUSE THE SCOPE AND COST
CHANGES HAPPEN SO NOTABLE WE
HAVE. A PARTICULARLY SERIOUS
CONCERNS THE SHARE.
SO FINALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COLLEGES YOU'VE HEARD LOTS ABOUT
THE ONLINE COLLEGE PROPOSAL LOTS
ABOUT THE APPORTIONMENT FUNDING
PROPOSAL I'LL JUST SHARE OFFICES
GENERAL FEEDBACK. ON BOTH SO
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA AYE WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO TRY OUT
DOING LAST IN A APPORTIONMENT
FUNDING BASED ON ENROLLMENT SOME
PORTION BASED ON PERFORMANCE.
THIRTY OTHER STATES HAVE SOME
MONEY LINKED TO PERFORMANCE
BASED FUNDING. THOSE STATES THAT
DO RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT IT
DOES CHANGE COLLEGE BEHAVIOR
THEY DO THINGS LIKE HIGHER MORE
TUTORS HIRE MORE ADVISERS FOCUS
MORE ON BASIC SKILLS INSTRUCTION
TRY TO STREAMLINE COURSE
ARTICULATION.
THERE IS LIMITED DATA TODAY THAT
SUGGESTS STUDENT OUTCOMES
IMPROVE NOTABLY BUT IT'S SO
COULD BE WORTH TRYING SAID GET
COLLEGES TO START DOING THOSE
THINGS IF YOU WERE TO DEEMED
THAT POSITIVE THINGS.
IF YOU DO PROCEED DOWN THE ROAD
OF PLACING SOME MONEY I'M MORE
OF IT BASED UPON PERFORMANCE WE
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO LINK IT
DIRECTLY AT LEAST A SMALL
PORTION OF IT OR SOME PORTION OF
IT. TO HOW LOW INCOME UNLESS
PREPARED STUDENTS PERFORM NOT
JUST ON ROLLING THEM BUT GETTING
THEM TO SUCCEED WITH DEGREES IN
A TIMELY FASHION.
FINALLY ON THE ONLINE COLLEGE
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT IT REALLY
BELIEVES ARE THE ROOT CAUSES OF
THE WORD THE ROOT ISSUE US.
I WHY ISN'T THAT ADULTS WORKING
ADULTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
OPTIONS THAT THEY WANT WITH AN
EXISTING COLLEGE SYSTEM TODAY.
I'M A WHY IS IT THAT THEY'RE NOT
AVAILING THEMSELVES OF OPTIONS
WHAT PARTICULAR OPTIONS WHAT
THEY LIKE.
WE THINK ONCE YOU HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEM
YOU'RE TRYING TO TARGET THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THOSE PROBLEMS YOU
COULD CONSIDER. OTHER SOLUTIONS
SOLUTIONS MAYBE EVEN WITHIN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM HAVING SAID THAT
IT COULD BE HARD TO CHANGE THE
INCENTIVES OF THE EXISTING
SYSTEM YOU MIGHT HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELVES WHY. WHY AREN'T
COLLEGES OFFERING COURSES AT
CONVENIENT TIMES OF DAY
CONVENIENT TIMES OF THE WEEK WHY
AREN'T THEY MORE FLEXIBLE IN
FORMAT?
?
AND THOSE KINDS OF QUESTIONS WHY
INDUSTRY ISN'T PARTNERING WITH
COLLEGES IN SUCH A WAY THAT
WORKING ADULTS HAVE ON THE JOB
TRAINING EXPERIENCES ON
EDUCATION AND TRAINING A MORE IS
MORE SEAMLESSLY INTEGRATED. SO
THIS IS JUST AN ENCOURAGEMENT TO
THINK ABOUT RELIGION ISSUES TO
SIFT THROUGH ALL THE POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES BEFORE YOU LAND ON
WHAT YOU THINK WOULD BE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE RESPONSE.
SO I HAVE AN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
YES THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION
WITH REGARD TO CS YOU MAY BE
GIVING YOU COULD INCLUDE YOU SEE
FACILITIES.
.
DID YOU EXAMINE HOW HOW HOW THE
FACILITIES.
HOW THE PROCURED AT AT AT A
SPECIFIC CSU IN OTHER WORDS ARE
ARE ALL THESE?
ARE ALL THE UNIVERSITY OF THE.
CAMPUSES IF YOU WILL.
OPERATING SEPARATELY.
DO THEY GO THROUGH IS THERE SOME
CENTRALIZED PROTOCOL.
WHERE THERE'S OVERSIGHT?
AND AND NOW I HAVE A SECOND
QUESTION THERE IN YOU MAY KNOW
THE ANSWER THIS YOU MAY NOT
MAYBE LOOK TO THIS.
ARE THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
ON CAMPUS SHARING SPACE.
SO HEY YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE THE.
MEN OF THIS DEPARTMENT AT THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE BUILDING
NOBODY ELSE CAN COME AND BUT YOU
KNOW IF YOU NEED TO SPACE YOUR
OTHER DEPARTMENT. SHE WILL
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO BUILD
SOME NEW SOME NEW US A NEW SPACE
TO CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT I DID
YOU INVESTIGATE ANY THAT. HAVE
REGARDING THE FIRST POINT WE HAS
AN OFFICE HAVE HAD A LONG
STANDING CONCERN THAT.
THE CENTRAL OFFICES WHETHER IT
BE SERIOUS YOU OR YOU SEE THEY
TEND TO TAKE THE A PROJECTS THAT
OUR SUBMITTED FROM THE SEGMENTS
AND.
BEING OVERLY SIMPLISTIC MAKING
SURE CAMPUSES GET STUFF EVERY SO
OFTEN WITHOUT DECIDING
STRATEGICALLY WHICH CAMPUS TO
GET THE NEXT PROGRAM BECAUSE
BASED ON A SYSTEM WIDE PLAN.
THAT'S WHERE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
IS AND THAT'S WHERE EXISTING
FACILITIES ARE BEING USED AT
CAPACITY. IT DOESN'T FUNDS THE
BEADS ON ONE THOUGHT SORT OF
STRATEGIC VISION OF WHAT THE
SYSTEM NEEDS WHERE IT NEEDS IT
WHEN IT NEEDS IT IT TENDS TO BE
OF SPECIFIC CAMPUS HOW THE
BUILDING THAT'S AGING AND WOULD
LIKE TO MODERNIZE AT SO IT'S
VERY CAMPUS SPECIFIC. IT DOESN'T
HAVE A SYSTEM WIDE MUCH LESS A
STATEWIDE FOCUSED.
NOT BEING SENT THAT PART OF THE
JOB YOU MIGHT SAY WELL THAT'S
OUR JOB OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES JOB BUT UNDER THE NEW
CAPABLY SYSTEM THESE PROJECT
PROPOSALS HAVEN'T BEEN REALLY.
GIVEN A REALLY THOROUGH I'LL
LOOK INTO.
THE STATE IN THE PAST HAS HAD
STANDARDS FOR DIFFERENT KINDS OF
SPACE FOR CLASSROOMS FOR
TEACHING LAB SCIENCE LABS.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN A SPECIFIC AS
REQUIRING.
DEPARTMENT LEVEL DATA SO AS A
STATE WE'VE NEVER HAD THAT NOW
IT TO THE EXTENT THAT IT HAPPENS
I SUSPECT IT MIGHT HAPPEN IF
THERE'S TO SCIENCE BUILDINGS
PRETTY CLOSE BY THEN MAYBE THE
LABS ARE WILLING TO. IN CERTAIN
TIMES THE EFFORT OF THE STATE
LEGISLATIVE GUIDELINES WHEN THEY
WERE REALLY USED ON IN FOREST
WAS THAT. THE STATE WOULD BE
STUDYING THESE AGGREGATE WE WANT
TEACHING LABS TO BE IS A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DAYS A WEEK A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF HOURS WITH DUST FILLED
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME YOU GO
FORTH UNIVERSE INTO TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN WILL GIVE YOU FLEXIBILITY
TO MANAGE IT AT. THE CAMPUS
LEVEL.
BUT MANY OF THE SORT OF
WATCHDOG FUNCTION HAS
DETERIORATED OVER THE YEARS.
AND HOW WOULD THAT.
WHAT WE THERE HELLO WATCHDOG
FUNCTION MIGHT OCCUR THERE WOULD
BE AT THE CHANCELLOR'S LEVEL
OBVIOUSLY? AND WHAT SOME.
OFFICER OFFICER WITHIN. THAT
BUILDING.
WOULD.
YEAH I THINK AND OTHER.
HISTORIC.
PROCESS HAS BEEN THAT THE STATE
HAS STATUTORY LEGIT LEGISLATIVE
GUIDELINES FOR THE USE OF SPACE.
FOUR WHAT'S ENTAILED TO HAVE
APPROVAL FOR NEW SPACE.
AND THAT THE SEGMENTS WOULD
RECOGNIZE IF THEY WERE GOING TO
SUBMIT A PROPOSAL THEY WOULD
HAVE TO ADHERE TO THOSE
GUIDELINES.
FINANCE WOULD REJECT LOTS OF
PROPOSALS THAT JUST SENATE MEET
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND THEN WE
MIGHT SUGGEST YEARS JACKSON
PROPOSALS THAT DONE THAT MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS AND YOU WOULD
GO AHEAD AND REJECT THEM ASK
THEM TO BE RESUBMITTED ONCE THEY
HAD BETTER DOCUMENTATION OR ASK
THE SEGMENTS OF RESUBMIT A. NEW
LIST PROJECTS TO THAT DID MEET
YOUR PRIORITIES.
ON THE LAST FEW YEARS WITH A
SORT OF APPROVAL OF PROJECTS HAS
BECOME MUCH MORE PRO FORMA.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARTUCCI THANK
YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO.
ASSN QUESTIONS RICK RELATE TO
FIGURE SEVEN.
SO ACCORDING TO FIGURE SEVEN
WHICH SHOWS THE.
PER P. PER STUDENT FUNDING.
FOR THE THREE SEGMENTS.
I IT IT IT SEEMS THAT.
THAT WHILE THE CSU AND THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE FUNDING. EL
IS.
PRETTY MUCH AT OR NEAR THE PEAK.
A OVER THE LAST SIX. MINUTES OF
THIRTY YEARS.
THE UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA PER
STUDENT FUNDING DRAMATICALLY
DROPPED AFTER NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT PER OR THEREABOUTS. AND.
.
IS AND HAS A LONG WAY TO GO TO.
GET BACK TO WHERE IT WAS ONCE
IN THE LATE NINETIES IS IS THAT
I ACCURATE TO.
INTERPRETATION OF YOU OF FIGURE
SEVEN I THINK IT IS YEAH OKAY
SO.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW.
Y..
THE A STATE PER STUDENT FUNDING
HAS DRAMATICALLY DROP. IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY RELATIVE
TO THE CAL STATE IN THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
AND WHAT ARE THE.
BIGGEST BARRIERS TOWARD
RESTORING THAT LOST UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA A PER STUDENT
FUNDING.
I THINK THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOU SEE AND ACTUALLY BECAUSE
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND THAT THE
COLLEGES ARE WITHIN NINETY EIGHT
AND THEIR FUNDING IS BEING
DRIVEN BY IT SORT OF FORMULAS
THAT HAVE BEEN GENERALLY GROWING
OVER TIME. IN EXCESS OF
INFLATION. AYE IS MORE DIFFICULT
TO PINPOINT THE DIFFERENCES IN
UC AND CSU DID YOU SEE STARTED A
PARTICULARLY HIGH LEVEL AND THEN
WHEN THE STATE HIT THE RECESSION
THAT PURPOSELY WANT TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS THE STATE. HAS MADE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO TRY TO BUILD
UP CSU FUNDING A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
IT'S JUST A PRIORITIZATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS HAD A FOR A
FEW YEARS.
HOW FOR EXAMPLE OUT AWHILE AGO
VCS USE BASED INCREASED WAS
LINKED TO UC'S BASING CHRIS EVEN
THOUGH AT THE TIME YOU SEE HOW
TO HIRE A BASE SO THAT WAS ONE
EFFORTS TO JUST? PRIORITIZE THE
ISSUE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
AND AND IT HAS BEEN GROWING.
MORE NOTABLY BUT.
IT IN RECENT YEARS BUT AGAIN AT.
IT LARGELY COMES I THINK TO JUST
PRIORITIES OF THE STATE AND HOW
IT'S DECIDED TO. ITEM. AND MAKE
THESE DECISIONS AT BOTH UC AND
CSU FEES WENT UP VERY STEEPLY
DURING THE RECESSION.
AT AND THE STATE BUDGET.
GENERAL FUND WENT DOWN FOR BOTH
SEGMENTS I THINK PART OF THIS IS
JUST COMING OUT OF THAT WITH THE
STATE'S PRIORITIES HAVE BEEN AND
EVEN DURING THE RECESSION WHAT
DISPARITIES.
BUTTON BUT AGAIN I MEAN LOOK AT
THIS GRAPH IT DOES SEEM TO BE
STRENGTH EATEN LEAD DIFFERENT
FROM. THE CSU INCOMING COLLEGE
IS A. THERE IS THERE ANYTHING TO
ACCOUNT.
LIKE OFTEN WE WE HEAR THAT THE.
THEY DID THE REASON WHY THE
UNIVERSE TO CALIFORNIA OF
FUNDING HAS DROPPED IS BECAUSE
OF THE RECESSION. BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE THE THE DROPS.
YOU KNOW NO PRECEDED AND EVEN
CONTINUE DURING THE DOT COM BOOM
BEFORE THE GREAT RISK RECESSION
OF A.
DIDN'T START AROUND OH SEVEN OO
EIGHT.
ANY ANY.
REASON FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST
SPECULATION.
BUT I MEAN I WAS HERE DURING
THE LATE NINETIES AND THERE WAS
A LOT OF EFFECTIVELY
DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES SINCE
THE STATE'S FISCAL SITUATION WAS
GOOD. AND IS LOOKS LIKE FROM THE
GRAPH THAT THE STATE AND I THINK
WE CAN SOME OF US REMEMBER THE
A.
STATE KINDS OF THINGS THE STATE
DEAD IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES THAT BENEFITTED YOU SEE
IT APPEARS THAT IT DID THAT SORT
OF DISPROPORTIONATELY TO CS YOU.
SEE YOU SEE THEN WAS AND TRAIN.
THE DOT COM BUST AT A HIGHER
LEVEL AND SO THAT'S WHEN YOU GET
TO THE DOT COM BUST YOU SEE THAT
SORT OF TEMPORARY LATE NINETIES
ADDITIONAL SPENDING SORT OF CUT
AS THE FIRST THING TO GO. NOW IS
THAT A SIGN THAT SOME OF THAT
FUNDING IT WAS
REALLY SORT OF ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT BECAUSE THE STATE TIMES
WERE SO GOOD I'M SURE YOU SEE IT
WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION
AND BELIEVE THAT THOSE ARE
REALLY CRUCIAL. AN EXTRA
AUGMENTATIONS DURING THAT TIME
BUT THAT PROBABLY EXPLAINS A
TOUCH OF THAT AGAIN THIS IS JUST
ALL ABOUT THE STATE'S PRIORITIES
OVER TIME.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA BUT BUT ON
THIS POINT I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
ISN'T JUST GENERAL FUND HERE
THIS IS COR FUNDS ARE STUDENT
FEES SO. WHEN THEY INCREASE
STUDENT FEES ARE NON STUDENT.
PARA STATE.
REVENUE THIS IS ALL PART OF THAT
SAME RIGHT AGENT BECAUSE GENERAL
FINANCIAL OCEAN FROM THE
UNIVERSITY'S VANTAGE POINT IS
FUNGIBLE THEY USE BOTH FUNDS
SOURCES TO RUN THEIR CORE
OPERATIONS WE LOOK. NOT ONLY FOR
YOU SEE AT STATE GENERAL FUND
AND RESIDENTS WHO WISH ON THAT
BECAUSE THEY USE SOME NON
RESIDENT TUITION SO CROSS
SUBSIDIZE THEIR CORE PROGRAM. WE
INCLUDE EVEN THAT.
OKAY.
MR MEDINA GETS REQUEST QUESTIONS
TO.
THE GOVERNOR'S PERMIT FINEST.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN TO ME HOW.
COULD EXPLAIN TO ME HOW. THE
GOVERNOR KNOWS THAT THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA.
WILL WORK.
AS IT PERTAINS TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SURE SO I. AM JUST STEPPING BACK
A LITTLE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
EXISTING AT FUNDING FORMULA AND
THE IT AND IT CONCERNS I'M. WITH
DEAFENING FORMULATING HIS BEEN
CONVERSATIONS.
.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAMINO
WORK FOR THE HAS BEEN LOOKING AT
THE EXISTING FUNDING FORMULA.
SO THERE ARE SEVERAL CONCERNS.
THAT IT'S BASED ON ENROLLMENT
AND IT MAKES A VERY CHALLENGING.
FOR.
COLLEGES I SPECIALLY GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC CHANGES WHEN ENROLLMENT
WHEN ECONOMIC TIMES ARE GOOD.
COLLEGES AT SUPPER WHEN THEY AT
CANNOT PAT ATTAIN THE A ROMANTIC
AND THEY'RE CHEATING GROWTH AND
AND AND OPPOSITE HAPPENS WHEN.
AT TIMES ARE ARE BAD SO I THINK
THERE IS A RECOGNITION THAT THE
FUNNY THE EXISTING FUNDING
FORMULA.
ISN'T WORKING.
I THINK WE LOOKED AT SEVERAL
MODELS WE KNOW THAT OVER THIRTY
STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED SOME
TYPE OF A OUTCOMES BASED
PERFORMANCE SPACE IN THEIR
FUNDING FORMULA AS A WAY TO AND
CENTS. UP HERE RURAL
INSTITUTIONAL AYE CHANGES AND
THAT'S THE ELLIOTT POINTED OUT I
HAD THE RESEARCH HAS INDICATED
THAT THIS HAS RESULT HEAD AND.
ABBY HE REALLY CHANGES IN THOSE
STATES THAT HAVE ADOPTED SOME
SORT OF OUTCOMES IN THEIR
FUNDING FORMULA.
IN THE FUNDING FORMULA ALSO
PROPOSES TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL A
FUNDING FOR DISTRICTS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAT THE DISTRICTS%
SERVE. AS WE KNOW IT THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THAT
AREA.
AB COULD BE AT HELPFUL IS SO I
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT TRAITS IS TRYING
TO ADDRESS.
VARIOUS CONCERNS AND THAT
BUILDS ON THE RESEARCH OF WHAT
OTHER STATES.
HAVE DONE.
I WOULD NOT THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CONVENED AT
SEVERAL WORKGROUPS THAT.
CHIEF BEEN PRETTY OPEN THAT WE
ARE.
OPEN TO CONSIDERING WHETHER
THESE ARE AT THE RIGHT FACTORS
THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING A LOT OF
OF FEEDBACK INCLUDING IS THERE A
BETTER WAY TO PLANNED.
AT. THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT WITH
OUTCOMES AND WE ARE IT CERTAINLY
TAKING THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
BUT WE REALLY THINK THAT BASED
ON THE RESEARCH.
AND BASED ON THE CONCERNS OF
THIS IS A WAY TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE CONCERNS.
AND I HAVE A SIMILAR QUESTION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S IDEA OF PROPOSAL.
TO FIND A ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
ONE TIME FOR ONLINE.
IF YOU COULD.
SHOW ME WHAT EVIDENCE WE HAVE
THAT THIS WOULD ALSO WORK AND
WHAT EVIDENCE. DOES THE GOVERNOR
HAVE IN PROPOSING THIS.
SHIRTS ALL ALL SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT.
MAY RESPOND TO SOME SORT OF THE
LA ELBOWS AND QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT WHAT ARE AT THE ROOT CAUSES
WHAT WE WHAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
SO WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION WORKING
ADULTS AT BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY FOUR WHO
DON'T HAVE A POST SECONDARY.
CREDENTIAL WE LOOKED AT THE
AVERAGE WAGES OF OF THIS
POPULATION AND WE WE KNOW THAT
AT THE AFTER AVERAGE ANNUAL
WAGES TWENTY THREE AT THE HOUSE
AND. WE KNOW THAT.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THIS
POPULATION IS CURRENTLY WORKING.
OUT AND WE KNOW THAT.
FORTY PERCENT ARE ARE THAT THE
NOT. SO I.
THE THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT
THERE A OUR INCOME.
UP DISPARITIES AND THAT IS THE
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT IS AN
AXIS SEEN.
THE EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND DEMOCRAT COURSES.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE ARE
WORKING THERE IS A NEED FOR
FLEXIBLE OPTIONS I AM GIVEN
THEIR FAMILIAL Y. WORK
OBLIGATIONS.
SO WITH SO WHY AREN'T OF THE
STUDENTS OR THE WORKING ADULTS
ACCESS SEEN EXISTING ONLINE
COURSE AT THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
WE KNOW THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF ONLINE AT THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES HAS BEEN BUILT AROUND
THE MORE TRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
OF FIRST TIME FRESHMEN.
WHO IS SEEKING A GREATER
TRANSFER TO A UNIVERSITY AND
WHERE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES?
WITH REGARDS TO I FACULTY LOAD
ACADEMIC CALENDARS.
AND THAT DON'T ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBLE ON DEMAND BURST OF
EDUCATION AND.
SO THIS IS A WAY TO PROVIDE A
TUONO ADD TO PROVIDE A FOCUSED
EFFORT TO.
REACHED UP POPULATION AND
PROVIDE MORE ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND LIKE. I WOULD JUST ADD THIS
IS ALSO A GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED WHEN
RECESSIONS OCCUR I THINK.
WE CERTAINLY SEE THAT THERE'S A
BENEFIT TO HELPING THESE
STUDENTS AND THESE ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA FURTHER THEIR.
INCOME PROSPERITY THEIR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT WILL HELP
SAFEGUARD AGAINST DOWNTURNS IN
THE ECONOMY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
SO I I I HEAR YOU SAYING THERE'S
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION. WORKING
ADULTS.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THOSE BEING
LATINA.
WHO ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS?
HIGHER EDUCATION ARE.
ABOUT FORTY EIGHT PERCENT OF OF
THAT TWO POINT FIVE ARE LATINO
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE TWO
POINT FIVE ARE WORKING WORKING
EIGHTY PERCENT WORKING FORTY
PERCENT LATINA.
BUT I DID NOT HEAR IN YOUR
RESPONSE.
ANY EVIDENCE
THAT THIS IS THE BEST WAY.
OR THIS IS THE WAY THAT WILL
WORKWITH THESE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION AND WHICH IS THE
QUESTION THAT.
I ASKED.
.
DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE BECAUSE
AS AN EDUCATOR. I'M SKEPTICAL.
AS AN EDUCATOR.
THIRTY SOME YEARS.
AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS THE
BEST WAY.
OF MAKING SURE THAT THAT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION STUDENTS.
FORTY PERCENT LATINO WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL.
IN MY OWN MIND I THINK.
YOU KNOW ARE THESE THE STUDENTS
WHO ARE GONNA HAVE THE MOST
ABILITY. TO DO ONLINE LEARNING.
I I KNOW I CAN THINK OF RIGHT
AWAY THE SAN JOSE STATE. A STUDY
THAT SHOWED THAT STUDENTS HAD A
HARD TIME.
BEING SUCCESSFUL WITH ONLINE
LEARNING HOW DO I KNOW.
THAT THIS IS BETTER THAN THE
PROGRAMS ALREADY EXISTING AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ALREADY
HAVE.
ONLINE LEARNING.
WHO AND WHAT EVIDENCE DOES THE
GOVERNOR HAVE THAT THIS IS
BETTER AND THAT THIS WILL WORK?
AUTHORED OFTEN AND SO SO WE KNOW
THAT THESE AT TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION.
ADULTS CURLY DON'T ACCESS.
I.
COURSES SO.
THAT WE THINK THAT THAT'S
EVIDENCE THAT THE TRADITIONAL.
STRUCTURE ISN'T.
WORKING FOR THAT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT AND THE DEMAND
FOR ONLINE IS GROWING WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. EYES AT STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA OTHER ACCESS SEEN
ONLINE PROGRAMS A PRIVATE EYE
INSTITUTIONS SO WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS A DEMAND WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS A SHIFT.
TOWARDS ONLINE TOWARDS FLEXIBLE
I'M OPTIONS.
FOR ADULTS WHO CAN'T ATTEND
YOUR TRADITIONAL.
CLASS
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
IDEAS OPPORTUNITIES FOR.
AT THIS POPULATION TO ADVANCE
IN THEIR EMPLOYMENT AND TO
PROMOTE WHAT'S.
ADDS THROUGH.
ISSUE CERTIFICATES THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED BY THE THE EMPLOYERS
WE REALLY THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
TO HELP.
THIS POPULATION ADVANCE IN
TERMS OF SUCCESS AN ONLINE WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN I'M
IMPROVEMENTS AND.
COURSE COMPLETIONS AN ONLINE.
THE COMEDIC COLLEGE.
AT A DATA SHOWS THAT THAT GAP
BETWEEN FACE TO FACE AN ONLINE
IS CLOSING IN WHO WE ALSO KNOW
THAT. THERE ARE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF INNOVATIONS IN AN ONLINE AND
WITH PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS.
BECOMING EASIER.
TO TO IDENTIFY THE SKILLS GAPS
AND ADDRESS THOSE EARLY ON AND
THEN I'M ONLINE SETTING SO SO WE
THINK THAT THIS IS A SOLUTION TO
REACH A POPULATION THAT.
CURRENTLY JUST AS AN ACCENT
THINGAND.
AT PROVIDING A FLEXIBLE OPTION.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TRY I WOULD
ALSO ADD THAT I THINK WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S RESEARCH OUT THERE.
THAT INDICATES THAT ADULT
LEARNERS.
PERFORM BEST IN A SELF DIRECTED
ENVIRONMENT I THINK THAT'S ALL A
LONG STANDING RESEARCH
PATTERNED.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT ARIZONA
STATE UNIVERSITY.
HAS ROUGHLY ELEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS IN THERE UP FACE TO
FACE CLASSROOM WE KNOW THAT
THEIR ROUGHLY TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS TAKING ONLINE
PROGRAMS THROUGH ASU ONLINE. AND
IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THOSE STUDENTS ARE ROUGHLY.
COMPLETING THE PROGRAMS AND
HAVING SUCCESS RATES THAT ARE
ALMOST IDENTICAL BETWEEN THE TWO
FORMATS.
I I WOULD SAY.
.
THAT I DO NOT SEE NOR DO I HEAR
A WHOLE LOT OF EVIDENCE TO
CONVINCE ME THAT THIS IS.
REALLY A PROGRAM THAT WILL WORK
AND IN THE WAY THAT IT'S
INTENDED TO WORK.
OUR I I HAVEN'T SEEN HER OR
HEARD THAT EVIDENCE
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD IT HERE
TODAY EITHER.
.
TO ME IT'S A A BIG PROGRAM
SHIFT.
IN THE WEIGH.
AND IT AND IT HAS ALL SORTS OF
QUESTIONS OF GOVERNANCE AND
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR. IS
TO SET THIS UP IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
HI AS A INDEPENDENT COLLEGE
WHO WOULD GOVERN THAT IS UNCLEAR
TO ME TO THEIR ISSUES OF
GOVERNANCE.
AND CONFLICTS OF INTEREST THAT
ARISES.
APART FROM THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAM.
THE A INVESTORS SURE OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS A
CERTAINLY A BIG SOUND.
I I SEE IT IS A SHIFT. IN POLICY
AND I WOULD I WOULD SAY AND I'M
ASKING OUR LEADERSHIP.
TO BRING THIS PROPOSAL WHERE CAN
BE BETTER DISCUSS AND THAT WOULD
BE IN THAT COMMITTEE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. I'M ASKING OUR
LEADERSHIP TO DO THAT TO BRING
THIS MEASURE TO HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AYE I THINK IT'S.
WORTH.
FLUSHING OUT.
AND ASKING THE QUESTIONS THAT I
THINK THAT LA SO OFFICE RAZORS.
AND QUESTIONS THAT I KNOW A LOT
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SO I I
WILL.
CONTINUE TO ASK.
LEADERSHIP TO DO THAT TO BRING
THIS FORWARD TO.
WHERE WE CAN DISCUSS IT MORE IN
THE STOCK COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION?
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA IS ALSO
A SHIFT.
.
BUT IF A YOU KNOW YOU FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THAT THAT'S GOING
TO WORK ALRIGHT WE'LL GIVE IT A
TRY. BUT CERTAINLY I THINK THE
ONLINE COLLEGE DESERVES A FAIR
HEARING. OF MERCANTE TALKED
ABOUT IN MORE DETAIL.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER AYE MEDINA
AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE YOU
GOT HERE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW.
HOT TOPICS IN THE BUDGET
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE FEW TOPICS
IN THE BUDGET AND ALL SORTS OF
MINIMAL BUDGET FOR HIGHER ED. I
THIS IS THE OVERVIEW WE'RE GOING
TO DIG INTO IT DEEP IN THE
POLICY I. THINK IN THE POLICY IN
THE BUDGET IMPLICATIONS IN THE
HEARING IN A FEW.
IN A FEW WEEKS BUT THERE IS
PRECEDENT I WILL REMIND US THAT
TOUGH YEARS AGO WHEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED. AT LCF HALF.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS YOUR YOUR
ALL YOUR FIRST YEAR HERE. IT WAS
A TWO YEAR PROCESS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR I THINK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE REJECTED THE
PROPOSAL DIRECTOR THE GOVERNOR
TO INTRODUCE A BILL IN POLICY
COMMITTEE THE GOVERNOR DID NOT
DO THAT.
IT IS ACTUALLY I TOOK A TIME OUT
FOR THE YEAR AND CAME BACK THE
NEXT YEAR IN THE BUDGET AGAIN
SO.
I WEEK WE HAVE ENTERTAINED THESE
ISSUES ON BIG IT ON BIG POLICY
MATTERS SO SOMETHING WE WILL.
YOU KNOW.
THAT PUT INTO CONSIDERATION AS
WE MOVE FORWARD SO. I THINK YOU
FOR THAT I OR WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE SEGMENTS IN A FEW
SECONDS AS WELL BY THE I I
WANTED TO JUST ASK ON THE
OVERALL.
A FUNDING FOR THE UC AND CSU AND
GRANTED IT WAS A LIGHT BUDGET
THIS I'M THIS IS JANUARY TEN.
A TON OF MONEY WENT TO.
THE RESERVE RAINY DAY FUND
WHICH IS GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
GOOD FOR US TO TO SET UP FOR.
YOU KNOW.
BUDGET PROBLEMS DOWN THE ROAD.
THEM THE MAJORITY MONEY WENT TO
PROP NINETY EIGHT WHICH WE ARE
HEARING IN COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AND K. TWELVE SO WAS A LOT
GENERAL FUND MONEY AND THE FIRST
PLACE BUT. I'M HAD THERE BEEN
MAYBE THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
INVESTMENTS IN.
UCC ISSUE HIGHER ED HEALTH
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL BY IS WHEN
I GO TO THE OVERALL PREMISE OF
THE OF THE THREE PERCENT
BECAUSE.
IT KIND OF.
IT'S IT'S BOTH WAYS HERE
BECAUSE WHAT ONE OF THE ISSUES
AS WE DON'T WANT TO INCREASE
STUDENT FEES NONE OF US WANT
THAT TO STUDENTS DON'T WANT THAT
THEM.
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
DON'T WANT THAT.
BUT THE SAME TIME THERE IS THIS.
BELIEF THAT THAT THAT THAT
GOVERN THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT
ARE SAYING HEY. THE PROMISES
THREE PERCENT AND WE'RE GOING
HERE IN A FEW MOMENTS THE
SEGMENTS ARE SAYING WELL. WITH
THREE PERCENT WAS OUT OF MONEY
TO. PAY THE BILLS THE BASICS PAY
FOR.
GOT COMPENSATION YOU KNOW THE.
RIGHTFULLY EARNED COMPENSATION
INCREASES.
NO MONEY TO PAY FOR STUDENTS.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WHICH IS WHAT
WE NEED TO YOU KNOW MAKE SURE WE
AND MARK GRADUATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THAT
ISSUE.
YOU SAYING NO ONE STUDENT FEE
INCREASES NO ADDITIONAL.
I MONEY ABOUT THREE PERCENT.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW THERE THERE
ARE A COUPLE THINGS THAT I
TIGHTLY I THINK FIRST AT THREE
PERCENT.
THAT IS ACTUALLY LARGER THAN
THE IMPLICIT PRICE THE PREDATOR
THAT WE SEE TODAY WHICH IS TWO
POINT FIVE ONE PERCENT.
SO I I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S A
HEALTHY INVESTMENT WITHIN THE.
THE CSU ON THE UC.
I THINK THE SECOND COMPONENT
THAT WE'VE YOU KNOW VOCALIZED.
HAS BEEN.
ENCOURAGING BOTH SEGMENTS TO
LOOK AT THEIR COST STRUCTURES.
AND LOOK AT WAYS TO REDUCE THEIR
COSTS INTERNALLY SO THAT WITH
THIS THREE PERCENT AUGMENTATION
AS WELL AS THEIR THE RESOURCES.
THEY ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR ALL
OF THEIR COSTS WITHOUT REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL TUITION INCREASES.
SO I AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF
THAT COULD BE AS STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER FROM THE CSU THROUGH THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THAT IN THEORY IS
OPENING UP CAPACITY TO EITHER
SERVE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS OR
CHIU UTILIZE THOSE RESOURCES TO
MEET. THE GOALS OF THE CSU.
YEAH I I MEAN WERE IN FULL
ACCORD WITH THAT ESPECIALLY THE
GRADUATES INITIATIVES WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING. LATER ON
ABOUT.
I FURTHER INCENTIVIZING STUDENTS
WHO GET A CAL GRANT TO GO FULL
TIME TRUTHFUL TIME THAT THE BELL
DEFINITION OF FULL TIME.
I WANT TO ASK YOU LA ELF YOU
COULD CARP RESPOND TO THAT AND.
YOU KNOW THAT DESIRES THAT DID
NOT INCREASE FEES BUT THEN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
A PLUGGING IN THREE PERCENT BY
THREE PERCENT IS GREATER THAN A
TRADITIONAL CALL IS TODAY
ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF.
PERCENT WHICH AS YOU KNOW AS YOU
NOTED THERE ARE. FIXED COSTS IN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION HEALTH
COSTS.
RETIREMENT COSTS WHAT BUT HAPPY
SO HOW DO WE RECONCILE THESE
THINGS.
YEAH AND BECAUSE THAT THEIR
EFFECTIVELY HAVING THE STATE
GENERAL FUND BEAR THAT.
AUGMENTATION FOR THE ENTIRE
COURT BUDGET ADEQUATE STE MORE
LIKE ONE AND A HALF SO DEPENDING
ON YOUR INFLATION INDICATOR IS.
ON THE CORNER FUND BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE ISN'T EQUATING TO
INFLATION HAVING SAID THAT WE'VE
NEVER ENCOURAGED YOU TO JUST
GIVE THEM AN INFLATION
ADJUSTMENT AND WALK AWAY. WE'VE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT INCREASES IF ANY DO YOU
WANT TO SUPPORT AT THE SEGMENTS
IS IT. FACULTY'S SALARIES ARE
NOT COMPETITIVE AND YOU WANT TO
MAKE THEM MORE COMPETITIVE
ANYONE INCREASE THEM THREE OR
FOUR OR FIVE PERCENT TO PERCENT
WHATEVER YOU FIND REASONABLE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO HAVE AS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WHAT KIND OF
INCREASES IN DOT SERVICE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SEE BECAUSE OF NEW
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUEST?
AND SO THIS IS JUST A MATTER OF
IS ESTABLISHING YOUR PRIORITIES
ARE WE TRYING TO DO ON THE
REPORT IS WALK THROUGH THINGS
LIKE COMPENSATION ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THESE ADDITIONAL EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC QUALITY OF
EACH OF THE STATEMENTS TO JUST
TRY TO GIVE YOU A FRAMEWORK FOR
WHETHER THOSE. WOULD BE THE
KINDS OF THINGS YOU WOULD WANT
TO SUPPORT.
WHEN IT COMES TO FEE INCREASES
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDS THIS.
I'D.
IDEA IS SUMMIT IS GOING TO BE
BEARING THE COST INCREASES GOING
TO BE THE GENERAL TAXPAYER IS
GOING TO BE THE STUDENT WHETHER
IT'S THREE PERCENT OR ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT. THERE'S A COST TO
BEAR SO WE'D JUST CONTINUALLY
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO THINK
ABOUT LET'S MAKE SURE THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL THINGS THAT YOU WANT
TO DO WHETHER THE STATE'S GOING
TO BEAR THE FULL COST OR WHETHER
THEY WOULD BE SHARED.
AND THIS IS. ECONOMIC EXPANSION
AND WAGES STILL ARE GOING ON BY
AND LARGE WHETHER THIS IS A TIME
WHERE YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
REASONABLE TO ASK FAMILIES TO
PAY.
SOME MODEST AMOUNT MORE IS AGAIN
WITHIN YOUR BAILIWICK TO DECIDE.
.
THAT WOULD JUST BE.
CONTEXT FOR THE THINGS YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER I'M SORRY THIS IS A
FINAL COMMENT AND I DIDN'T A
VERY SYSTEMATICALLY MENTIONED
THIS BUT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS THE NEXT FEW MONTHS IS
DECIDING YOUR PRIORITIES WHAT
KIND OF BUDGET YOU WANT TO
SUPPORT. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AREAS WHERE WE ARE GOING TO
RECOMMEND REJECTING WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PRESENTED TO YOU
INNOVATION AWARDS THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB A NEW
THING THAT HE CREATES.
PRIOR YEAR APPRENTICESHIP
REIMBURSEMENTS.
MAYBE REVISITING THE SIZE OR IF
YOU WANNA DO THIS ONLINE COLLEGE
AT ALL.
WE.
DON'T TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW YOU
WOULD REPURPOSE THOSE WE JUST
IDENTIFY IF YOU DON'T REJECT
THEM YOU'D HAVE MONEY TO DO YOUR
OWN PRIORITIES.
WE DO OFFER SOME SUGGESTIONS AND
THEN I'LL ASSESS WHAT YOU COULD
DO MORE FOR FINANCIAL AID IF YOU
FOR EXAMPLE WANTED TO PROVIDE
ALL FULL TIME FINANCIALLY NEEDY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE ARE NOT LIVING COSTS WITH
THE GRANT. THAT WOULD COST MORE
THAN THE GOVERNOR'S PRESENTED TO
YOU. I'M IF YOU WANTED TO
PROVIDE APPRENTICESHIPS MORE
FUNDING ON ONGOING BASIS THAT
WOULD COST MORE SO THIS IS ALL
WHAT YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IS
FIGURING OUT WHAT KIND OF BUDGET
YOU ONE OBVIOUSLY AS THE WEEKS
GONE ARE HAPPY TO TRY TO HELP
YOU DID.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA.
THANK YOU AND SO I YOU KNOW AS
THEY CAME IN AND IT WAS HEARING
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION.
AND SO I WANTED TO COME AND
JUST OVERALL AND I NEED TO THE
ASPECTS THAT WE WERE DISCUSSING
AND THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I THINK I WOULD ECHO. I YOU KNOW
MY COLLEAGUES AT COMMENTS IN
TERMS OF LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE.
HAVING SERVED ON TO KEEP YOUR
SCHOOL BOARD AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT ROLLOUT AND IMPLEMENTATION
IS A WHOLE OTHER THING NO MATTER
WHAT THE TREND IS DOING.
AND PARTICULARLY FOR EXACTLY
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE THAT WERE TRYING TO I'M
REACH AND A TIMER OVER THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS WE'VE STILL TALKED
ABOUT SOME COMMUNITIES NOT EVEN
HAVING.
FULL NEEDED ACCESS TO INTERNET.
ITS YOU KNOW I I THINK OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE OF THE TWO POINT
FIVE ARE IN THOSE EXACT SAME
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE THE
ISSUES. AND THAT THEY STILL
DON'T HAVE FULL ACCESS
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF ELEMENTS AND THAT I TO
HIM LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT INVESTMENT AT
THIS PARTICULAR TIME.
.
I THINK WE NEED CREATIVITY NAY
THINK THERE'S REASONS TO BE
CREATIVE AND TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO REACH A HARD TO
REACH POPULATION. AND BUT I ALSO
THINK THAT AND THERE ARE SOME
TOOLS IN PLACE AND SEVEN MET
INVESTMENTS IF I LOOKED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I LOOK AT
THE FUNDING HAS BEEN MULTIPLE
INVESTMENTS MADE TO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROGRAMS AND NOT ALL
ONLINE. THAT REACH THAT YOU KNOW
ARE TARGETED TO REACH SOME OF
OUR HARD TO REACH STUDENTS AND
AND SO I THINK OF YOU KNOW. HOW
DO WE WAY THAT OUT BUT I AM I DO
I DO I THINK THAT? THAT EVIDENCE
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR AT
LEAST ME AND TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND IF THIS IS THE RIGHT
INVESTMENT AT THIS PARTICULAR
MOMENT IN TIME. ON IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER YOU KNOW IN OTHER FORMS
OF LOOKING AT WHAT'S ALREADY IN
PLACE.
ANNIE DOING FURTHER EXPANSION
INVESTING THERE OR REALLY
STARTING A WHOLE NEW GRANDMA AND
BRAND.
ON THE FRONT.
RELATED TO THE UC FUNDING.
YOU KNOW I I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT THE STUDENT VOICES IS AND
NARRATIVE IS NOT LOST IN THIS
AND SO I THINK ABOUT THE FACT
WHAT YOU KNOW.
EVEN THERE IS MENTION ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S. THREE
PERCENT IS MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE.
BUT IT'S NOT THE FOUR PERCENT.
AND AND I ALSO THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HAS.
BECOME VERY REAL IN THE LIFE OF
STUDENTS AYE AND DADDY IS THAT
THAT THE LANDSCAPE AND HIGHER IT
IS CHANGING. AND AT A TIME WHERE
WE ARE ALSO THINKING ABOUT WHAT
IMPACTS.
AND CHANGES WE MAY SEE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH A
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAMS TITLE
NINE. THE PELL GRANT FIFTEEN
UNITS VERSUS TWELVE UNITS.
I THINK OF THE FACT THAT OUR
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT.
JUST THINKING ABOUT WHETHER
THIS IS ONE YEAR OF TUITION. AND
INCREASE AND MORE ABOUT HOW MUCH
IMPACT CAN BE TAKE IN THE COMING
YEAR AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
JUST HOW WE INCORPORATE THAT IT
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S THINKING IN
TERMS OF LIKE THERE MAY ACTUALLY
BE OTHER CUTS AND IF WE'RE
INCREASING TUITION. AND A TIME
WHERE WE MAY BE TELLING STUDENTS
THAT. YOU KNOW TWELVE HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED FOR TWELVE UNITS HAS
BEEN CONSIDER FULL TIME FOR
PURPOSES OF FINANCIAL AID BUT WE
MAKE UP THAT ON YOU TO FIFTEEN
IT'S GONNA MEAN THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO PAY MORE. IN TUITION
HAVE TO WORK MORE HOURS I MEAN
NOT BE ABLE TO WORK AS MANY
HOURS BECAUSE THEY NOW HAVE TO
TAKE.
THE THREE UNIT DIFFERENCE IN
QUARTER. YOU KNOW I IN SCHOOLS
THAT RUN ON A QUARTER SYSTEM AS
A WHOLE OTHER CLASS.
HOW HOW DOES THAT INCORPORATE
INTO ALL OF THIS AND HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE? AND THAT WE AT LEAST
CONSIDER A STOP GAP IN A YEAR
WHERE THEY MAY BE OTHER FEDERAL
IMPACTS.
SO YOU THINK IT'S DIFFICULT
FRONT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT'S
DIFFICULT AT BEST TO PROTECT.
WHAT THIS FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH AT ANY
GIVEN MOMENT AND I THINK?
YOU KNOW IT WE UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN CERTAINLY.
BUT IT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
SAY WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL OR WON'T DO AT THIS POINT.
I'M SURE WOULD BE PREMATURE FOR
THE STATE TO TAKE ACTION BASED
ON.
WHAT IT DOESN'T KNOW ABOUT WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD WITH IT IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT?
POSITION BUT WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE.
THAT WE NEED TO MONITOR IT.
WE MEAN TO KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ULTIMATELY MOVES FORWARD WITH
AND TAKE APPROPRIATE ACTION. AS
THE YOU KNOW THE DID IT THAT
SPECIFIC INFORMATION BECOMES
VERY CLEAR TO THE STATE. UP BUT
UNTIL THAT POINT IN TIME I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE
PREMATURE TO ASSUME WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL OR WILL.
WELL AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE ARE VERY SPECIFIC ON ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC IN TERMS OF THE DIRECTION
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY BE
GOING. AND I ALSO WANT TO AND.
YOU KNOW KNOWING OUR PROCESS
HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE THAT WE
HAVE THE MEANS TO CORRECT THAT
IF NEED BE AND SO I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT TO AS. THIS BUT YOU
KNOW BUDGET.
MOVES FORWARD AYE THAT IF THERE
IS THE HOW A TRIGGER WHAT IS
THAT TRIGGER GONNA LOOK LIKE TO
RE CORRECT ANYTHING THAT MAY
HAPPEN BECAUSE IN THE LIFE. OF A
STUDENT.
TO WAIT AN ENTIRE ACADEMIC YEAR.
YOU KNOW THE THE VERY GOAL OF
HELPING STUDENTS REACH TIME TO
DEGREE MAY BE IMPACTED AND BY
SAYING HEY THIS WAS OF THE
BUDGET WE REALLY CAN'T DEAL WITH
THIS UNTIL ANOTHER YEAR WHEN
SOME OF THESE CHANGES. AND CAN
BE REALLY.
YOU KNOW DETRIMENTAL TO THE THE
LIFE OF A STUDENT AND NOT JUST
IN TERMS OF GETTING INTO IT. A
YOU SEE BUT GRADUATING FROM A
YOU SEE AND ALSO BEING
SUCCESSFUL ON THIS IT YES SO SO.
I HOPE THAT THERE'S SOME THOUGHT
INTO WHAT WOULD TRIGGER.
A A REMEDY.
FOR STUDENTS IF SOME OF THIS
WERE TO HAPPEN AND IN LIGHT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN TWO
POINT FIVE TO THREE PERCENT TO
FIVE PERCENT TO FOUR PERCENT.
OKAY WITH THAT WE WANT TO
UPGRADE OF THIS TO MEDINA YET
THERE IS A SUPREME COURT JUDGE
AND I FORGET. HIS NAME BUT IT
WAS A SUPREME COURT JUDGE OF THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT AND
HE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT THE DEATH
PENALTY.
AND HE SAID.
BUT TALKING ABOUT THE DEATH
PENALTY DID HE WOULD NO LONGER.
I CONTEMPLATE DEALING AROUND THE
EDGES OF THE DEATH PENALTY HE
THREW IT OUT THE CITY'S NO LUCK
HE'S TIRED OF DEALING WITH IT.
AND THAT THERE WAS NO PLACE FOR.
I FEEL LIKE THAT JUDGE THAT YEAR
AFTER YEAR WE SIT HERE.
IN SACRAMENTO TO TALK ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND YEAR AFTER YEAR WE HEAR
FROM.
GOVERNOR.
WHY WE CAN'T DO BETTER FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION?
I HAVE.
DONE LISTENING TO WHY WE CAN'T
DO BETTER.
I AM DONE LISTENING IT IS UNFAIR
TO THE STUDENTS WHO SIT HERE
OVER GOING TO HEAR FROM.
LATER IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY IT IS
UNFAIR TO THE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT ARE IN THE
CAMPUSES AND THEY DON'T GET TO
COME UP HERE TO SACRAMENTO.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE BUSY TAKING
CLASSES THEY'RE BUILT THEIR BUSY
WITH TWO JOBS AND WE DON'T HEAR
FROM THEM.
BUT I HOPE WE HEAR FROM OF THIS
YEAR.
SO I'M DONE LISTENING TO WHY WE
CAN'T DO BETTER.
BUT.
LET ME ASK A QUESTION.
DID WE OR DID WE NOT HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WITH WITH UC THAT WE
WOULD THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD
NOT RAISE.
THAT WE WOULDN'T SEE TUITION
RAISES AND THAT WE WOULD GIVE UC
FOUR PERCENT. IN THE TIME OF HIS
TERM OF GOVERNOR SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO YOU SEE WE
WOULD NOT HAVE TO SEE. A TUITION
RAISES WASN'T THERE. WAS THAT
AGREEMENT IN PLACE OR NOT.
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND YOU
SEE.
HELLO JACK'S WALT FROM A
FINANCE.
I THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN. THE
GOVERNOR AND THE UC PRESIDENT.
PREDICATED THAT IN THE LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR THAT THE
UNIVERSITY COULD.
INCREASED TUITION.
YOU MIGHT WITH INFLATION.
HOWEVER.
I LAST YEAR'S TUITION INCREASE
OF BOTH THE UC. AND THE CSU WAS
GREATER THAN PREDICTED
INFLATION.
SO THE WHILE THERE WEREN'T
WHAT'S AGREEMENT.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH.
THE UC AND CSU.
TWO ONE WAY FORWARD AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
.
THE COMPONENTS OF THAT
AGREEMENT.
ADDRESSING THE COST STRUCTURE.
MAINTAINING.
AND. TO WHICH INCREASES IN LINE
WITH INFLATION AND OUT THE OTHER
SPIRIT OF THAT AGREEMENT ARE.
CONTINUE TO BE THE BASE FOR
POLICY SO TRIP TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS THE TUITION ROSE HIGHER THAN
THE RATE OF INFLATION. THAT'S
CORRECT.
AND THAT THEREFORE THE AGREEMENT
IS NO LONGER AN AGREEMENT. WELL
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT UP.
BUT. THE THE INFLATION THEIR
GRADE RATHER TUITION DAVID.
INCREASE FASTER THAN INFLATION
AND.
A CORRESPONDING MOVES MADE ARE
ALL PART.
WELL AYE I WILL ECHO WHAT A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE SAID. THE IN
SPEAKING ABOUT OUR GOVERNOR HE
SAID THE GOVERNOR GIVES US
SOMETHING.
THEN HE TAKES IT AWAY. AND THEN
WE WANT TO THANK HIM WHEN HE
GIVES IT BACK TO US WHAT HE'D
ALREADY PROMISED.
IT OUT TO ME A PROMISE IS A
PROMISE AND AND WE'VE MADE A
PROMISE TO CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A PLACE.
AND HIGHER EDUCATION THE CHART.
ON PAGE TWELVE FIGURE SEVEN
SHOWS THAT WE'VE NOT MADE
MAINTAIN THAT PROMISE
YEAH.
YEAH LET'S AND.
CAN WE GET TO THE SEGMENTS
MISTER O'DONNELL FORMER
QUESTION.
THE QUESTION YET MY MY QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH REGARD TO THE
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
YEAH I I WAS LED TO BELIEVE THAT
IT ISN'T AMY.
IT ISN'T SOMETHING IT'S ALWAYS
SEE COULD AGREE ON. BUT IT WAS
SEEK TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC.
SKILL GAPS CAN YOU SPEAK I IN I
DON'T THINK. IF THAT IS SUCH
THAT THAT IS A PROPOSAL YOU IT
HAS NOT BEEN MADE CLEAR I DON'T
KNOW IF OTHERS ON THE COMMITTEE
KNOWS BUT. I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT YET SAID THAT THE PROPOSAL
IS THAT THIS COMMITTEE COLLEGE
WILL FOCUS ON SHORT TERM.
CERTIFICATES CREDENTIAL IS NOT
THE TYPICAL I TRANSFER AT A
DEGREE THE EXPECTATION IS THAT
THESE WOULD BE STACKABLE ALSO OF
A STUDENT DOES WANT TO PURSUE. A
FOR.
DECREED THAT THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE COVER FOR THAT AT THAT
STUDENTS TO OTHER LOCAL
COMMITTEE COLLEGE BUT THEY DHEA
IS THAT THESE CREDENTIALS. AND
THE CERTIFICATES WOULD BE
CLOSELY LINKED TO A STUDENTS
APPOINTMENTS SO FOR INSTANCE IT
COULD BE ASHORE I MEAN A PROJECT
MANAGEMENT QUARTERS THE LAST TWO
TO THREE WEEKS. THAT IS
RECOGNIZED BY THE EMPLOYER AND
THAT WOULD ALLOW THAT EMPLOYEE
FOR INSTANCE TO PROMOTE TOOL AS
SUPERB VYTORIN POSITION SO THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF.
EYES CERTIFICATE SHORT TERM STE
CERTIFICATES.
IT'S NOT YOUR TRADITIONAL.
DEGREE AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILS ON WHAT
THOSE LOOK LIKE MOVING FORWARD
THROUGH THE SPRING PROCESS.
THE USER IS THERE ANY
CONTEMPLATION WHO TEACH THESE
CLASSES ARE THEY.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY ARE THEY IMMUNITY CITY
IN RUSSIA WHERE THESE PEOPLE.
YEAH.
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THIS
COLLEGE BUT RELY ON THE
EXPERTISE THE FACULTY OF THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES JUST LIKE ANY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AT THE COLLEGE
WOULD BE ABLE TO HIRE AT FACULTY
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF EXPERTISE.
IN THE EXISTING COLLEGES TO HER
WITH A WITH A DROP IN THE
EXISTING PULL CALIFORNIA.
THREE COLLEGE FACULTY OR WERE
THEY CREATE THEIR OWN UNIVERSITY
THESE PEOPLE COULD BE FAR FAR
AWAY.
IN THEORY IF SO CAN YOU DO HAVE
YOU CONTEMPLATED THAT IN YOUR
WHOLE.
I THINK GENERALLY IT'S IT'S
CONTEMPLATED IN THAT YES THE
COLLEGE COULD HIRE NEW FACULTY I
THINK THE EXPECTATION IS THAT
THOSE FACULTY. WOULD BE A
QUALIFIED AS ANY OTHER FACULTY
ARE WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
TWO IS I MEAN I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER MY QUESTION THAT'S WHY
I'M THEM AND I'M POKING AROUND
SO THAT WOULD THOSE FACULTY BE
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA MIGHT THEY
BE FAR FAR AWAY. WOULD THEY BE
FROM EXISTING FACULTY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A QUESTION THAT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER AT
SOME POINT IN THIS VENTURE
CERTAINLY DO YOU DO YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER TODAY.
SO I WOULD SAY. IT IS LIKELY
THAT YOU COULD HAVE THIS COLLEGE
HIRING SOME EXISTING FACULTY
MEMBERS. OR A COULD BE A HIRING
SOME ADJUNCT FACULTY THAT ARE
WORKING PART TIME AT SOME OF
THESE COLLEGES IT COULD BE
HIRING NEW FACULTY FOR THE
SYSTEM WITHIN. A YOU KNOW
QUALIFIED FACULTY THAT ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THERE ARE MANY OPTIONS
FOR HIRING FACULTY BUT MY
STATEMENT REALLY IS THAT IF THEY
WOULD HAVE TO MEET. THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS TO BE A FACULTY
MEMBER AYE IN A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND YOU CAN ASK THIS QUESTION
WOULD THEY HAVE TO BE LOCATED
PHYSICALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK GENERALLY I DON'T THINK
THAT THE TRAILER BILL SPEAKS TO
THAT SPECIFIC ASPECT BUT
GENERALLY YOU WOULD EXPECT THE
COLLEGE TO BE HIRING FROM WITHIN
THE STATE.
LET'S GET ON TO OUR NEXT TO. OUR
NEXT THAT PANEL WILL HAVE THE
THREE SEGMENTS COME UP AND
PROVIDE INSIGHT ON THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS. AS THEY
COME UP WE'RE GONNA CALL ROLE
WILL QUIT.
MR MCCARTY HERE.
CHAVEZ MISLI MON.
MR MEDINA HERE.
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
MISTER O'DONNELL HERE MISTER
VOEPEL GO.
OKAY.
WE'LL START WITH THE.
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA AND CSU
THEIR COMMUNICABLE GE'S.
HAVE A NEW FACE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SO PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
THANK YOU HONORABLE TERM MCCARTY
AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAY EVER
TATTENHAM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE SURGEON WILL BE HANDING OUT
A HANDOUT UMP THAT. TYPE PROVIDE
WILL HAVE PROVIDED TO YOU.
WITH SOME BACKUP DATA.
TO GIVE YOU AN OVERALL PICTURE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
THE OVERALL BUDGET OF THIRTY
FOUR AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS.
OF THIS APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD
ARE FROM OUR MEDICAL CENTERS UP
AND ANOTHER THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
ARE SELF SUPPORTING AUXILIARIES
UP AND FACULTY RESEARCH HARDCORE
FUNDS BUDGET. IS APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
AND THIS IS COMPOSED OF STATE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
STUDENT TUITION NON RESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION AND VARIOUS
OTHER STUDENT FEES AND A FEW
SMALLER. FUNDING SOURCES SUCH AS
PATENT REVENUE. MAKE UP THE THE
DIFFERENCE THAT I THINK THE
IMPORTANT TAKEAWAYS HERE ARE.
THAT STATE GENERAL FUNDS ARE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY PERCENT OF
OUR CORE INSTRUCTIONAL BUDGET.
ON SLIDE TREE THREE.
YOU WILL SEE HOW THE COR FUND
BUDGET FOR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS CHANGED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. AND ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT TAKEAWAYS HERE IS DOT
OUR STATE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
HAS FLUCTUATED. WITH THE.
THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
WE HAVE RECEIVED INCREASES AND
WE HAVE BEEN DECREASE AND WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL. TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE INCREASES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION. BUT WE DID ALSO
SUSTAIN APPROXIMATELY A BILLION
DOLLARS OF CUTS DURING THAT
TIME.
AND AT THIS TIME OUR STATE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT IS ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN
IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND.
THE DIFFERENCE FROM OUR FUNDING
SOURCES HAS BEEN MADE UP FROM
PRIMARILY STUDENT FEES AND
APPROXIMATELY A BILLION DOLLARS
IN NON RESIDENT REVENUE.
NON RESIDENT STUDENT TUITION
REVENUE.
ARE. AVAILABLE COR FUNDS PER
STUDENT WHEN ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION HAVE DROPPED BY.
APPROXIMATELY OF FOUR THOUSAND.
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER STUDENT SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
DURING THIS TIME.
.
WELL LET'S SEE.
AND THEN IF YOU MOVE ON THE
SLIDE FOR.
YOU WILL SEE THAT OUR
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT HAS
GROWN. BY OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED FD STUDENTS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE UNFORTUNATELY
I DIDN'T HAVE THE UNDERGRADUATE
FTE  BROKEN DOWN BY
RESIDENCY STATUS FROM PRIOR TO
TWO THOUSAND FIVE BECAUSE WE
MEASURED IT DIFFERENTLY. FOR
CONSISTENCY I WANTED TO PROVIDE
A SINGLE. SINGLE CHART.
.
AND.
IN OUR RESIDENT OF STUDENT
POPULATION THE UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY POPULATION HAS BEEN.
GROWING STEADILY AS YOU WILL SEE
ON THE CHART ON THE RIGHT THERE.
THE TOTAL UNDERGRADUATE FTE HAS
ACTUALLY GROWN BY EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SINCE
A TWO THOUSAND.
THIS IS WHAT IMPACTS THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE PER STUDENT.
AND LIKE I SAID ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS HAVE INCREASED BY
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR PERCENT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
AND YOU ARE I'M STUDENTS ARE
NOW ABOUT THIRTY FOUR PERCENT OF
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
TO SUPPORT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
THE UNIVERSITY NEEDS ADDITIONAL
FUNDS.
WE NEED TO WE NEED FUNDS FOR
INSTRUCTORS STUDENTS SERVICES
PERSONNEL. OF OUR OFFICES SUCH
AS FINANCIAL AID AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND BASIC BEHIND THE SEAS
SCENES FUNCTIONALITY LIKE
CUSTODIAL SERVICES AND LIBRARY
STAFF.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDS THE THREE
PERCENT GROWTH PROVIDED BY THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE THEY ARE ON THE
FORTY PERCENT OF OUR STATE. ODD
GENERAL FUND COMPONENT. ACTUALLY
REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY A ONE
POINT FOUR PERCENT GROWTH FOR
THE ENTIRE CORPS FUNDS BUDGET
FOR INSTRUCTION SODAS. AS A
WHOLE BELOW INFLATION.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWO
UNIVERSITY IS GOING TO BE
GROWING AGAIN WHEREIN THE
PROCESS OF ADMITTING NEW
STUDENTS AS WE SPEAK.
THE CURRENT PLAN IS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO GROW BY TWO
THOUSAND RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES
FOR NEXT YEAR.
AND ALSO FIVE HUNDRED GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
TOOK THESE
BUT INDIVIDUALS WILL NEED
INSTRUCTION AND.
STAFF TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
ON SLIDE FIVE.
UP YOU WILL AGAIN SEE OUR CORE
FUNDS PER STUDENT.
AND THIS IS TO ILLUSTRATE HOW
HOUR TOTAL CORE FUNDS VERSUS
AVAILABLE COR FUNDS PER STUDENT
ARE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THERE ARE CERTAIN
FUNCTIONS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PAYS FOR. OUT OF OUR
TOTAL CORE FUND BUDGET THESE
INCLUDE A RETIREMENT BENEFITS
FOR FACULTY AND STAFF.
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND DEBT
PAYMENTS AND FINANCIAL AID THOSE
COMPONENTS ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO
HIRE NEW FACULTY AND NEW STAFF.
AND THE GENERAL OBLIGATION IN
LEASE.
BOND PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING OVER THE LAST.
.
LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
ON SLIDE SIX ARMED YOU WILL SEE
HOW THE UNIVERSITY HAS STEADILY
INCREASED.
OF OUR STUDENT FACULTY RATIO.
OVER THE LAST.
BOB SEVERAL DECADES.
UGH THIS MEANS THAT STUDENTS WHO
ARE ENROLLING TODAY ARE
RECEIVING A LESS INDIVIDUALIZED
ATTENTION FROM FACULTY. AND ALSO
SITTING IN CLASSROOMS THAT ARE
MORE CROWDED. THAN PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS.
WHILE WE WOULD LIKE TO REDUCE
OUR STUDENT FACULTY RATIO
REDUCING THAT RATIO BY ONLY ONE
STUDENT PER FACULTY WITH TAKE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. SO THEY
ADDITIONAL FUNDS BEING PROVIDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE NOT
GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE.
ON THE STUDENT FACULTY RATIO AT
THIS TIME.
AND ON SLIDE SEVEN.
THIS IS THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET
ASK IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS OFF THIS
IT IS IN LIEU OF THE TUITION AND
STUDENT FEE INCREASE SO THIS
WOULD KEEP TUITION AND STUDENT
SERVICES BE. THE SAME AS IN
CURRENT YEAR FOR NEXT YEAR SO
THAT STUDENTS. DO NOT EXPERIENCE
AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON THEIR.
TUITION BILLS STOW WE DO TAKE
GOOD CARE OF OUR STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF FINANCIAL AID.
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS DO NOT PAY TUITION FEES
BECAUSE OF OUR FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGES CURRENTLY.
.
AND ALSO PROVIDING THE SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE SYSTEM
WOULD SAVE THE STATE SOME MONEY
ON THE CAL GRANTS BECAUSE.
A.
SO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ON.
RECEIVE FINANCIAL AID.
CALTRANS COVER A PORTION OF THAT
OF THOSE FEES FOR STUDENTS SO
IT'S APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF SAVINGS ON
THAT.
WE'RE REQUESTING TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
IMPACTS OF RECENT GROWTH ON THE
SYSTEM.
WE'VE RECEIVED FUNDING FOR
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS IN
THE LAST SEVERAL BUDGETS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE WAS
STRUCTURED AS AN ALL OR NOTHING.
UP FINE FUNDING FOR THOSE
STUDENTS ARE IN.
FOR THE UC SYSTEM WE OVER AND
ROLLED BY APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS CREATES A BURDEN ON THE
CAMPUSES BECAUSE CLASSROOMS ARE
OVERCROWDED AND THE FUNDING TO
HIRE NEW INSTRUCTORS IS NOT
THERE SO WE ARE REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE EDUCATION
AND STUDENT SERVICES.
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE RECESS
FOR THE POPULATION OF STUDENTS.
THAT IS ALREADY ON OUR CAMPUSES.
A IN ADDITION WE'RE REQUESTING
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE NEW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT WE WILL
BE TAKING ON FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THIS IS IN ADDITION TO
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT.
AS PART OF THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU SEE WAS
DIRECTED TO RE DIRECT FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT BUDGET
TO THE CAMPUSES FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
AND ALSO WE'RE REQUESTING ONE
TIME THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TO CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY NEXT CSU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS RYAN STORM OF THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET FOR THE SEIZE YOU SYSTEM.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
THIS BUDGET CYCLE AGAIN.
THE FIRST THING I WANTED TO DO
WAS START OFF WITH.
REAL A HIGH LEVEL AYE
CHARACTERIZATION OF SOMETHING IN
THAT IN THAT THE C. ISSUE AND
STATE LEADERS SHARE RELEASED
SAME FUNDING PRIORITIES.
THEY ARE IMPROVING OUR
GRADUATION RATES.
THEY'RE CREASING STUDENT ACCESS
AND THEY ARE FAIRLY COMPENSATING
OUR EMPLOYEES.
SORRY VISIT THESE PRIORITIES
THROUGHOUT MY COMMENTS.
SO THESE PER PARTIES HAVE BEEN A
CURRENTLY ARE IN CONTINUE TO BE
OUR SHARE PARTY'S.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK A LOOK
FIRST AT HOW THESE PARTIES HAVE
BEEN
PORTED IN THE RECENT PAST OF
SKIN BECOME A PAST PRESENT
FUTURE SORT OF PRESENTATION SO
IF YOU SEE THIS HAND OUT HERE.
THAT WE CAN WALK THROUGH REAL
QUICKLY.
I SO FUTURE TO PITCH TO LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU.
AND MANY THIS ISSUE SUCCESSES
SINCE THEIR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
BEGAN.
THESE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE REGULAR
INVESTMENT BY THIS BODY AS WELL
AS THE SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR
WE THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE INVESTMENTS OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS OR SO.
SO JUST READ QUICKLY AT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ENROLL A OVER
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND MORE FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS ARE
THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND HEAD COUNT.
A IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
FROM A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO ADDING.
TWO CAMPUSES THE SIZE ONE THE
SIZE OF C. ISSUE SEMBRA DE NO
THE OTHERS THE SIZE A SEE ISSUE
CHICO SO DURING THE RECOVERY
WE'VE BEEN REALLY GOING
GANGBUSTERS IN TERMS OF OUR
ENROLLMENT I THINK.
.
CAMPUSES HAVE ALSO ADDED A MANY
NEW COURSE SECTIONS
I TO THEIR COURSE OFFERINGS I
JUST ALONE BETWEENLAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR WE'RE REPORTING TO YOU
ABOUT THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL COURSE SECTIONS WHICH
IS GREAT FOR THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
ARE YOU ALSO HAVE MORE STUDENTS
PORTS LIKE ACADEMIC ADVISING AND
A WHOLE HOST OF MENTORING SORTS
OF PROGRAMS THAT REALLY HELP A
NUMBER STUDENTS THAT PERSIST IN
THEIR EDUCATION.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE A DENT
IN OUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IMPROVE INFRASTRUCTURE. UP BUT
THEY'RE STILL A A MOUNTAIN OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE STILL OUT
THERE HONOR CONNOR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES.
AND WE'VE CONSISTENTLY OVER
THIS PERIOD.
BEEN ABLE TO SETTLE MANY OF OUR
EMPLOYEE CONTRACTS
AND I THINK EVERYBODY IS HAPPY
FOR FROM THAT VANTAGE POINT.
SPECIALLY THAT THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR EMPLOYEES
AND BEEN ABLE TO YOU KNOW
FULFILL THE MISSION OF THE
UNIVERSITY AND NOT NOT BE
WRAPPED UP IN IN IN. IN
CHALLENGES OF
OF SALARIES IN THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS SO I THINK IT'S BEEN
REALLY GET THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO SETTLE OUT THOSE CONTRACTS.
WE'VE KEPT PACE ALSO WITH
INCREASING HEALTH CARE A PENSION
COSTS ANOTHER MANDATORY COST
INCREASES OVER THIS TIME.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
AND WILL FOCUS WILL BE ON THIS
ON THE NEXT FEW SLIDES OUT WE
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO START THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
WHICH IS REALLY AN EMPHASIS ON
ON THOSE TWO TO WATCH PERSISTING
GET DONE AND FOR TO YEARS THIS
TRANSFER STUDENTS THAN.
THERE WERE TRYING TO DO OUR BEST
TO ADD TO DELIVER THAT TO THEM.
SO WE TURN TO PAGE THREE.
TALKING A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT WE HAVE GOING FOR TODAY AND
ABOUT WHAT OUR BUDGET ASK WILL
BE.
.
SO PAGE THREE CONTAINS MORE
DETAIL BETTER GRADUATION
INITIATIVE.
IT HAS AN AMBITIOUS IT'S AN
AMBITIOUS PLAN THAT SETS
ACHIEVABLE TARGETS.
TO INCREASE GRADUATION RATES FOR
ALL STERN GROUPS AND ELIMINATE
ACHIEVEMENT IN OPPORTUNITY.
GAPS.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ARE SHARING
OUR STARTING POINT HERE.
THE THE FIRST LINE BEING ARE
THE FIRST DOT COLUMN BEING
TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AND OUR LONGER TERM GOAL ON THE
FAR RIGHT SIDE. THAT'S.
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
COLUMN AND THEN OUR PROGRESS TO
DATE JUSTIN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE FEEL THAT WE'VE DONE A PRETTY
GOOD JOB GETAN THIS THING GOING
WITH.
ESPECIALLY WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD BEEN ABLE TO
INVEST LIKE I DESCRIBED ALREADY.
SOURCE MADE POSSIBLE HIGHER MORE
ADVISERS.
MORE FACULTY.
CREATE NEW ECONOMIC SUPPORTS
FOR NEW CONTINUING STUDENTS.
AND UP ALL OF THIS WILL INCREASE
COMPLETION ULTIMATELY.
A PAGE FOR.
OF YOUR HANDOUT SERVES A COUPLE
OF PURPOSES.
YOU SEEN A VERSION OF THIS OVER
THE YEARS AND AND HOPEFULLY THIS
DOESN'T SURPRISE HOW WE HOW WE
LAY ASIDE EVERY YEAR BUT I THINK
IT'S ILLUSTRATIVE OF OF A NUMBER
OF THINGS.
A ONE OF THE PURPOSES TO BACK TO
IS TO TO IS TO DEPICT.
OUR ASSURE PARTIES TODAY AS
REFLECTED IN THE CS USE REQUEST
FOR AN ADDITIONAL FOR A BRITISH
OF FUNDING FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
SO THE RIGHT COLUMN HERE OF
INFORMATION IS THE TRUSTEES
REQUESTS INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND.
ONLY THE MOST ESSENTIAL ITEMS.
IN THE C. ISSUE.
WHICH OTHER GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FAIR COMPENSATION
INCREASES ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH ENROLLMENT GROWTH NONE
THE LESS.
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS THAT WE CONTINUE TO NEED
TO BE ON TOP OF. AND ALSO
MANDATORY COST INCREASES LIKE
HEALTH CARE AND PENTECOSTAL SORT
OF THINGS.
SO WEEK GREAT MOMENTUM IN ON
TRACK TO MAKE HISTORIC UP
PROGRESS ON DOUBLING OUR FOR
YOUR GRADUATION RATES THROUGH
THE GRAD INITIATIVE.
BUT WE WILL NEED ONGOING
CONSISTENT HAND STE FUNDING TO
REALIZE THOSE GOALS LAST YEAR'S.
INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT THE START
AND FINISH WE NEED TO INVEST
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TWO OR MORE
EVERY YEAR FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN RAKE MAKE GOOD PROGRESS
IN GRADUATION ASH.
ALSO AS THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS
MEET MINIMUM SEISHI RICK ELLIS
VERTICAL ELIGIBLE REQUIREMENTS
LIKE WE JUST HEARD EARLIER.
AND AS A AS MORE STUDENTS
COMPLETE THEIR ASSISTANT DEGREE
FOR TRANSFERS AT THE SEAT AT
THAT ME COLLEGES WE NEED
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
OFFER THEM A SEAT AT THE C.
ISSUE.
AND AFTER YEARS OF STAGNANT
WAGES.
DUE TO THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION AND THAT WAS FOR ABOUT
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF FOR
RECEIVING WELL WRITTEN WELL. I
DESERVED RACES.
AND ON AVERAGE THAT'S ABOUT
THREE PERCENT PER YEAR THAT'S
COMPARABLE TO THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN RECEIVED BY STATE
EMPLOYEES.
THE OTHER PURPOSE OF THIS PAGE
IS TO BEGIN ANSWERING THIS
COMMITTEE'S QUESTION WHICH IS
NAMELY WATER SEES SHE'S THOUGHTS
ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
NOW THAT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A
PROVIDES ABOUT A ONE POINT FOUR
PERCENT INCREASED WERE OPREME
BUDGET WHICH FALLS ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS SHORT OF I REQUEST THEY
SEE ON THE RIGHT SIDE THERE.
LIKE WE HAVE ALREADY DISCUSSED
EARLIER.
GET I THINK THE SAME IS TRUE
WITH SIT WITH YOU SEE TO A LARGE
EXTENT EACH UP OUR CORE
OPERATING FUNDS ARE FUNDED ABOUT
HALF BY TUITION AND HALF BY
GENERAL FUND.
SO WHEN IT'S WHEN IT'S SIDE
DESCRIBED AS A THREE PERCENT
INCREASE OR FOUR PERCENT
INCREASE YOU IMMEDIATELY HAVE A
OF A GENERAL FUND INCREASE YOU
HAVE TO IMMEDIATELY FIGURE OUT
WHAT DOES THAT. HOW DOES THAT
APPLY TO THE ENTIRETY OF THE
OPERATING BUDGET WILL IT WILL
ULTIMATELY MEANS IT'S ABOUT HALF
SO THAT'S WHY? YOU HEAR
DIFFERENT NUMBERS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FROM THE VANTAGE POINT OF
WHAT HOW DOES THAT GROW THE
ENTIRETY OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
BUDGET NOT JUST ONE PIECE OF
THAT REVENUE SOURCE.
I SO SO THERE'S ABOUT THERE'S A
GAP OF ABOUT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
I IF YOU SEE ON THE LEFT COLUMN
HERE IT SHOWS HOW FAR WE COULD
STRETCH THAT NINETY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WHEN MEASURED AGAINST
NIVERSITIES ENTIRE OPERATE
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
INCREASE PROVIDES LESS THAN HALF
THE RATE OF INFLATION.
AND IS SIXTY ONE MILLION SHORT
OF WHAT WE NEED SIMPLY TO COVER
OUR COMPENSATION INCREASES FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF.
AND ARE MANDATORY COST INCREASES
LIKE IT'S HEALTH CARE AND
PENSION COSTS.
AND YOU CAN SEE HERE ON THIS
SLIDE THE THE SIXTY ONE MILLION
IS DEPICTED IN THAT IN THAT RED
AREA OF THE OF THE DISPLAY.
SO WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR FOR
THIS ISSUE ME THAT'S I THINK
WE'VE.
SHOWN HERE PRETTY CLEARLY SO
CAMPUSES IF IF.
IF YOU GET TO THE END OF THE
PROCESS
AND HAVE A SITUATION WHERE.
THIS YEAR SHE RECEIVED ONLY
NINETY TWO MILLION DOLLARS WE
HAVE TWO CHOICES THAT WERE
REALLY ARE REALLY TROUBLING I
THINK IN A TIME WHEN WE HAVE A
LOT OF NEW REVENUE COMING TO THE
STATE. THERE'S A LOT OF NEED FOR
NEW INVESTMENT UNIVERSITIES
SO THE FIRST THING IS THE
CAMPUSES WILL OUR CAMPUS
PRESIDENTS
PACIFIC WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE
DIFFICULT. DECISIONS TO COVER
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS.
RESULTING IN POTENTIAL DECREASES
AND CAMPUS OPERATIONS INCLUDING
APP ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND
ECONOMIC SUPPORTS
WE DON'T WANT TO BE ABLE TO WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO GO THERE.
BUT THAT'S JUST THE STARK
REALITY THAT WE FACE IF IF
NOTHING CHANGES.
IN IN THE IN THE BUDGET
SITUATION.
ANOTHER THING THAT. IS IS IS
CHALLENGING FOR THE SEIZE YOU TO
CONSIDER IS THAT THE TRUSTEES
WILL HAVE TO CONSIDER WHETHER TO
AUTHORIZE IT TUITION INCREASE TO
MEET THOSE VERY BASIC FINANCIAL
NEEDS OF OUR CAMPUSES.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THIS THAT.
A POTENTIAL NEGATIVE BUDGET
SCENARIO TODAY WOULD NOT PASS
SET UP SEE ISSUE STUDENTS AND
THE STATE'S ECONOMY FOR. WHAT WE
WOULD HOPE TO BE A STELLAR?
A CHAIR.
A STELLAR OUR FUTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
WITH NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EARNING BACHELOR'S
DEGREES AT THE CSU EVERY YEAR.
IN A TIME WHEN THE STATE IS A
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR A SURPLUS.
A WE BELIEVE THAT NO OTHER
INVESTMENT HAS THE SAME
POTENTIAL TO POSITIVELY IMPACT
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE.
SO PAGE FIVE.
REALLY I THINK SUMS IT UP.
OTHERS SEE SUMA STATE SHARED
THESE COMMON PARTIES TODAY.
AND THAT WILL SHAPE TOMORROW I
MEAN CONSISTENT VESTMENT
INCOMPLETION THROUGH THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE CONSISTENT
INVESTMENT IN ACCESS THROUGH THE
ROMAN INCREASES AND CONSISTENT
INVESTMENT IN MOMENTUM. THROUGH
REGULAR COMPENSATION INCREASES
IN AND ALL THOSE OTHER
NECESSITIES THAT I ALREADY
DESCRIBED.
THOSE THREE PARTIES WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SOME
GOOD PROGRESS AND WE HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION TO
CONTINUE THE MOMENTUM THAT WE'VE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED HERE.
AND WE TO SEIZE YOU CAN ONLY
ACCOMPLISH THESE PARTIES WITH
YOUR FINANCIAL PARTNERSHIP.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FULL
FUNDING OF THE C. ISSUES BUDGET
REQUEST BY INVESTING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
NOT FINANCE TODAY YOU'RE NOT
FINANCE ANYMORE YOU THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT YOU'RE SITTING IN
YOUR OLD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TIME OVER THERE I'VE GOTTEN TOO
USED TO IT HUMM WELL THANK YOU.
CHEN MCCARTY MEMBERS I'M
CHRISTIAN US MANY OF ICE
CHANCELLOR FOR. FINANCE IN
FACILITIES PLANNING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO I WILL BE SPEAKING FROM THE
LAST SET OF OF SLIDES THAT THE
SERGEANT HANDED OUT. AND
FINANCES PROVIDED YOU WITH
DETAILS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS FOR THE COLLEGES.
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S FRAMEWORK IN A BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PROPOSALS BEFORE THAT I WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME SHORT CONTEXT
ABOUT THE COLLEGES IN OUR
SYSTEMS PROCESS IN DEVELOPING
OUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET QUEST.
SO BEGIN ON SLIDE TO.
WHICH SHOWS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING OVER AN EIGHT YEAR
PERIOD BEGINNING WITH ELEVEN
TWELVE AS REFLECTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE TOP LINE SHOWS TOTAL FUNDS
INCLUDING STATE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS LOCAL PROPERTY
TAXES AND STUDENT FEE REVENUES
AND THE BOTTOM LINE SHOWS
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATIONS
ONLY.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
STUDY GROWTH FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION THIRTY
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
GROWTH IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE OVER
THAT PERIOD.
FOR CONTEXT MAJORITY OF THAT
STATE GENERAL FUND IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF TOTAL FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED FROM THE STATE TO THE
COLLEGES BASED ON THE GENERAL
APPORTIONMENT.
A FORMULA THAT DISTRIBUTES FUNDS
TO COLLEGES PRIMARILY BASED ON
THEIR ENROLLMENT USING A PER
STUDENT RATE AS FINANCE
DISTRACT.
OTHER FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
THROUGH CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS FOR
SPECIFIED PURPOSES THESE INCLUDE
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY FOR STUDENTS
SERVICES AND WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE THREE SHOWS
THAT NUMBER OF FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
THE COLLEGE'S.
FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS STUDENTS
ARE ONE MEASURE THAT WE USE A TO
CONSIDER ACCESS TO THE SYSTEM.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE WHILE THE
SYSTEM IS EXPERIENCE GROWTH IN
ENROLLMENT IN SOME YEARS THIS
MEASURE OF WORKLOAD IS MORE
VOLATILE THAN CHANGES IN FUNDING
HAVE BEEN.
AS I MENTIONED AFTER YES IS THE
PRINCIPAL MEASURE USED IN THE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS THROUGH THE
GENERAL PORTION IT SO WELL
FUNDING HAS GROWN STEADILY STATE
WIDE MANY DISTRICTS SPACE MORE
VOLATILE FUNDING PICTURE.
SLIDE FOUR COMBINES THESE TWO
PREVIOUS PICTURES
PER STUDENT FUNDING IS THE
LOWEST OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COMPARED TO THE OTHER SEGMENTS
ARE SHOWN IN THE LA ILL REPORT.
AND THESE DIFFERENCES HAVE LONG
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED IN STATE
POLICY AND THEY'RE A MAJOR
FEATURE OF THE MASTER PLAN.
AS YOU CONSIDER OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THOUGH WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CHALLENGING LOGIC
THE STATE IS USED AS EXPLICIT
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHICH SERVE STUDENTS WHOSE
CHARACTERISTICS SUGGESTS THAT
THEY NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
SUCCEED IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. GENERAL GENERALLY
RECEIVE THE LEAST AND FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT.
ON PAGE FIVE WE SHOW THE VISION
FOR SUCH A SUCCESS
HISTORICALLY ACCESS HAS BEEN A
PRINCIPAL GOAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE MASTER PLAN SPECIFIED THAT
ALL STUDENTS WHO COULD BENEFIT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE AND FROM THAT
LENDS ENROLLMENT HAS BEEN THE
PRINCIPAL MEASURE USED TO ASSESS
WHETHER COLLEGES ARE MEETING THE
STATE SCHOOLS.
MORE RECENTLY THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SYSTEM'S
BOARD OF GOVERNORS HAVE ALL
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO MAKE OTHER
GOALS. INCLUDING STUDENT SUCCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED BY THE
SYSTEM.
KEY FOCUS.
THIS SLIDE SHOWS THE GOALS
INCLUDED IN THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS WHICH WAS ADOPTED BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS LAST YEAR.
THE VISION INCLUDE SIX SCHOOLS
WHICH THE BOARD IN THE
CHANCELLOR EXPECT BE ACHIEVED BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THESE GOALS HELPED TO BRING
CALIFORNIA CLOSER TO ITS
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT NEEDS
WHICH YOU DISCUSSED YOUR
PREVIOUS HEARING.
AS YOU'RE WEARING THEM MOVING ON
THE SIDE SIX HISTORICALLY THE
STATE THE SYSTEM IN INSTITUTIONS
UNDERTOOK VARIOUS EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS USING
MANY DIFFERENT STRATEGIES.
LAST YEAR THE CHANCE OR PROPOSED
IN THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
UNIFYING THOSE EFFORTS THROUGH A
FRAMEWORK CALLED GUIDED
PATHWAYS.
AND THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET INCLUDED A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
BE SPENT OVER MULTI YEAR PERIOD.
TO MOVE COLLEGES TOWARD THAT
FRAMEWORK.
IN SHORT GUIDED PATHWAYS IS A
RESPONSE TO THE CAFETERIA STYLE
APPROACH TO ORGANIZING A COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. AND WHICH STUDENTS
ARE OFFERED MANY CHOICES WITH
LIMITED DIRECTION.
INSTEAD GUIDED PATHWAYS PROVIDES
ALL STUDENTS WITH THE SET OF
CLEAR COURSE TAKING PATTERNS AND
INTEGRATE SERVICES ALONG THE
WAY.
ON SLIDE SEVEN YOU'LL SEE A
BREAK DOWN OF FOR SPECIFIC WAYS
IN WHICH WE IMAGINE THE COLLEGE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
FIRST THROUGH GUIDED PATHWAYS
YOU WOULD CREATE CURRICULUM WITH
THE LINK TO EMPLOYMENT IN FUTURE
EDUCATION. SECOND YOU WOULD
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO HELP STUDENTS
CHOOSE AND ENTER PATHWAYS.
THIRD YOU WOULD HELP STUDENTS
STAY ON THE PATH AND FOURTH YOU
DO IT WITH AN EYE TOWARDS.
LEARNING CONSISTENT WITH
INTENTIONAL OUTCOMES.
SO IN THAT CONTEXT I COME TO OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS REQUEST FOR
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
THAT'S SHOWN ON SLIDES EIGHT AND
NINE.
THE INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS THE
REQUESTS ARE LISTED ON EACH
LINE.
AND IN GENERAL WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS REQUEST
IT FOCUSES ON GROWTH IN THE
GENERAL PORTION MEANT. PROPOSES
A NEW ONLINE COLLEGE CONSISTENT
WITH THE DISCUSSIONS ARE CALLED
OUR SYSTEM HAD LAST YEAR ROUND
ONLINE EDUCATION.
THE PROPOSES REFORMS TO
FINANCIAL ADDRESSES COORDINATION
OF
SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AND
RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
SYSTEM OFFICE.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE AREA
WHERE WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT IS WITH REGARD TO SPECIFIC
SUPPORT FOR FACULTY NOTABLY THE
BOARD'S REQUESTS FOR SPECIFIC
ALLOCATIONS FOR FULL TIME
FACULTY HIRING AND PART TIME
FACULTY OF SUPPORT.
WE THINK THAT KIND OF SPENDING
IS NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS.
IN TOTAL THE REQUEST INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING WITH AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME. WITH THE RECOGNITION THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SHOULD BE SIZED WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
THIS.
BEES TO SLIDE SHOW OUR
OPERATING BUDGET REQUEST IN
ADDITION AS WE MENTIONED AT THE
LAST HEARING THERE FIFTEEN
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT OUR
BOARD IS A. A SUBMITTED TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR CONSIDERATION OF
THOSE TEN WERE UNFUNDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AND THOSE
RAIN A PRIORITY FOR OUR BOARD.
AND SO FINALLY THE OF THE LAST
FEW SLIDES SLIDES TEN AND ELEVEN
GO OVER.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE PRESENTED
EARLIER? VIEWS OF THE CHIU MADE
SURE BUDGET PRIORITIES AND I
WANT TO SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IS FINANCE DESCRIBED.
.
NO THESE ARE ALSO PRIORITIES FOR
THE CHANCELLOR.
THE FIRST.
IS THE ONLINE COLLEGE COVERED
ON THIS FIRST SLIDE THE SECOND
IS THE FUNDING FORMULA COVERED
ON THAT SECOND SIDE.
AND ARE YOU GOT THE HEART OFFICE
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
FRAMEWORK BECAUSE THE PROPOSAL'S
RESPOND TO PROBLEM STATEMENTS
WITH WHICH WE CONCUR.
THE CHALLENGES THAT FACE
STRANDED WORKERS AND THE NEED TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES
PARTICULARLY FOR HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS INCLUDING
BY ALIGNING FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
WITH OUR GOALS.
WE BELIEVE THE FRAMEWORK CAN BE
IMPROVED IN THE COMING MONTHS.
AS FINANCE MET MENTIONED WE'VE
ENGAGED IN STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
IS ON BOTH AND WE ALSO WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
ADMINISTRATION TO TO MAKE THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS.
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ESTHER MEDINA.
THIS AFTERNOON AFTER THE GERMAN
OF THE ASSEMBLY I HAD THE HONOR
OF HOSTING. FIFTEEN DIFFERENT.
GRADUATE STUDENTS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM YOU SEE CSU AND
THE PRIVATE COLLEGES.
.
YOU SEE IS ASKING FOR A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING FOR FIVE
HUNDRED MORE GRADUATE STUDENTS
SO FROM UC WHY IS THAT.
IMPORTANT.
OF GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US FOR
TWO PURPOSES OF THEY. SERVE AS
RESEARCHERS TO ASSIST OUR
FACULTY TO HELP PROVIDE.
THE WORKFORCE TO.
ALLOW THE FACULTY DO CONDUCT ALL
THE RESEARCH AND GAIN ALL THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE SEEKING.
AND ALSO AS GRADUATE STUDENTS
STRUCTURES FOR UNDERGRADUATE SO
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IN ANOTHER
TWO THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES WE
NEED A WAY TO GIVE THEM
INDIVIDUALIZED ATTENTION.
THROUGH DISCUSSION SECTIONS WE
NEED AN ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTORS
OF THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
REPRESENTS THE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
PER STUDENT MARGINAL COST BUT
IT.
FOR FOR EACH GRADUATE STUDENT
THAT'S HOW WE DERIVE DOT NUMBER.
OKAY I I'VE A FEW QUESTIONS AND
I GUESS I'LL START WITH THAT WAS
THE ISSUE. AYE AYE AYE
CERTAINLY.
AND NEVER GOT RESPECT
UNDERSTAND THIS SIMPLE
MATHEMATICS OF THIS TABLE. UP
BUT BUT I WILL SAY THAT.
THAT THE TOP PRIORITY WHEN WE GO
IN. AND OUR COMMUNITIES GO TO
THE PARK A GROCERY STORE IS
ACCESS.
RIGHT GRAND WE MAY RUN INTO A
FACULTY MEMBER IN THAT CONTACT
THAT FUND. PAY FOR THE
COMPENSATION BUT THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE CONCERNED THAT
WE TURN AWAY THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA KIDS EVERY YEAR AT
THE CSU SYSTEM SO. IT'S SOMEWHAT
HARD TO SWALLOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PRIORITIES ACCESS.
IS THAT THE BOTTOM OF THE LIST
RATS TOP BUT IT'S.
LAST THING OF IMPORTANCE FROM.
FROM THE CS YOU I JUST WANNA
KNOW THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
THING OF IMPORTANCE.
THAT WE AS REPRESENTATIVES HERE
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS OUT
SO I WANT TO POINT THAT OUT WELL
IF YOU IF I COULD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER UP.
THAT THAT LIST IS NOT
NECESSARILY A RANK ORDER I AM
WELL AWARE THAT I I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE IT CLEAR IN THE PAST
YEARS WE'VE WORKED WITH YOU IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT TRYING
TO BALANCE ALL OF THOSE. VERY
BASIC NEEDS OF THE UNIVERSITY
AND I THINK WE'VE TRIED TO
SPREAD THESE FUNDS. AS WELL AS
WE COULD AND I THINK.
BASICALLY VICE BY JUST BY
WALKING THROUGH MY PRESENTATION
EARLIER DEMONSTRATE THAT WE HAVE
YEAH INCREASED ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY BY THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND.
OVER THIRTY ONE THOUSAND FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT SO.
IT'S A PRIORITY OF OURS AS WELL
FOR SURE I THINK A CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE THAT'S SO UNIQUE
THIS YEAR. IS THAT.
THAT WITH THE WITH THE YEAR
OVER YEAR DROP IN PROPOSED
FUNDING FROM THE GOVERNOR.
LAST YEAR HE PROPOSED ABORIGINE
IN JANUARY HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE C. ISSUE AND THIS YEAR
IT'S NINETY TWO IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT DROP I THINK IT'S
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. SO
WHAT THAT DOES IS THAT REALLY
THAT EATS INTO WAR HOW DO YOU
EAT. NOW WE'RE EATING INTO THE
POINT OF.
HOW TO COVER THOSE BASIC COSTS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE?
LOCK DOWN IN TERMS OF CONTRACTS
OR AND COST THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
INCURRING FROM RATE INCREASES BY
CALPERS FOR PENSIONS OR FOR
HEALTH CARE. SO THAT'S WERE
REALLY NOT REALIZING THIS POINT
THIS IS REALLY A CHALLENGE.
I THINK ULTIMATELY IT'S IT'S
IT'S GOING TO BE BY THE END OF
THE BUT IN THE PROCESS HERE.
WE WE HOPE THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO TO SPREAD MORE OF THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
STATE TO ALL THESE OTHER. IN A
AREAS INCLUDING ENROLLMENT.
GRADUATION A SHIP AND
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THIS PET THIS
JUNCTURE IT'S IT'S REALLY A DIRE
SITUATION THAT RAN. OFFERED FOR
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR OKAY
AND THEN A FOLLOW UP BURKE
PERSEUS YOU. I DID YOU WANTTO
MAYBE ADDRESS THAT THE ARRANGE
WE HAD LAST YEAR FOR. FOR AN
UNDERGRADUATE. ADMISSIONS IN THE
POLICY THAT YOU KNOW.
JUNIOR STUDENTS ENFORCEMENT GET
GOT TURNED AWAY BUT WE WE ARE
NOW GOING TO. GIVE ALL OF YOUR
STUDENTS AT LEAST THAT GUARANTEE
OF A SPOT AND ONE. I CAMPUS AND
SO HOW IS THAT GOING TO WORK
OUT.
WELL I THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE
STILL IN THE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT.
IF.
YOUR STAFF FOR OTHERS HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING.
OUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES HAS HAD
NUMBER OF OF THAT HEARING SIR
ACTUALLY I. ITEMS THAT THEY'VE
DISCUSSED.
ON A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS ON ONE
THING THAT I THINK IS
CHALLENGING ROM RIGHT NOW IS IS
THAT WE HAVE THREE THINGS IN
PLAY AT MINIMUM. ONE YOU HAVE
THE ELIGIBILITY STUDY ARE
BASICALLY SAYING THAT WE ARE.
CARPOOL IS FORTY ONE PERCENT
RIGHT SO WERE WERE GRAPPLING
WITH THAT PARTICULAR ITEM.
I WERE ALSO GRAPPLING WITH THE
NOTION OF.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF POLICY
STATEMENTS THAT COME THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR WANTED
US TO TO DEVELOP ONE OF THOSE
BEING TO READ DIRECTOR CAMPUSES
THAT MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL PASSED
THE THE OTHER THING IS TO.
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ACCESS FOR
LOCAL STUDENTS AT THEIR LOCAL
CAMPUS.
IN ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT
THERE'S THE NOTION THAT.
.
WITH TIGHT BUDGETS IT'LL BE
TOUGH TO.
KEEP KEEP IT WRONG THAT WHERE IT
IS.
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT A
STANDING BODY THAT'S ALWAYS
WORKING ON THIS IS CALLED THE
MISSION ADVISORY COUNCIL.
IT'S A CROSS SECTION OF THE
UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY THEY ARE
VIGOROUSLY MEETING DEBATING ARE
DISCUSSING HOW TO BLEND ALL OF
THESE.
ISSUES INTO ONE COHESIVE POLICY
THAT WILL WORK BEST FOR THE C.
ISSUE.
THAT'S A LOT OF BACKGROUND
BASICALLY SAY IT'S STILL TO BE
DETERMINED. A A SEVEN MEMBER
MCCARTY.
WE HAVE.
LIKELY AN ACTION ITEM IN MARCH
AND SO BY THAT POINT I THINK THE
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE THE COUNCIL
OF HAD.
NETWORK UNDER ITS UNDER ITS
BELT. WHERE THEY CAN NAM PUT
TOGETHER OUT OF A PROPOSAL I
THINK THAT WILL BENEFIT?
TODD
STATE AND OUR STUDENTS A LITTLE
BIT BETTER THAN OUR CURRENT.
A LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN OUR
CURRENT SITUATION WE'RE IN.
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND AND I WILL NOT TO
JUST FOR THE UC AND CSU I THINK
IN YEARS PAST TO WE WE HAVE. A
FOUGHT FOR INCREASES ABOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I WORK IN IT
NO REASON WE WHEN CAN YOU DO SO.
THIS YEAR AS WELL WITH BUT
STILL THINK THE GOVERNOR IT IS
CORRECT THAT WE WON AT.
LOOK ABOUT WAYS WE CAN TIGHTEN
THE BELT BUT AS FAR AS THE
GRADUATION RATES AND WOULD YOU
SEE AS OUR AUDITOR POINTED OUT
AND WE TALKED LAST TO RETHINK
THEIR SON. EFFICIENCIES IN IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THERE'S YOU KNOW UPWARDS OF
THREE QUARTERS OF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN.
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
EARMARKED FOR THIRTY YEARS SON
SOME ARE GREAT SOME LOOK GOOD ON
PAPER BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE A TOUGH CHOICE.
IN THE BUDGET CLIMATE WHAT'S OUR
HIGHEST AND BEST USE OF THAT
SCARES DOLLAR MAYBE.
AND ROLLING AYE MORE CALIFORNIA
KIDS IS A CHOICE WE WANNA FOCUS
ON SO THAT'S A CONTINUING.
CONTINUED ISSUE I I I DO WANT TO
ASK YOU ONE POINT.
.
ABOUT THE.
YOU THE CHARTS YOU HAVE THERE ON
THE.
THAT THIS STUDENT TO FACULTY
RATIO YOU SAID THAT BY GOING
DOWN. OF ONE FOUR POINTS.
AS FAR AS I'M TO BETTER.
FACULTY TO STUDENT RATIO WOULD
COST
I THINK TO WONDERING EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO FROM
TWENTY ONE TO ONE AND. YOU KNOW
WE AYE AYE WE'D RATHER HAVE YOU
KNOW SERVE TWENTY THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIA KIDS BUT THEN YOU
WOULD ARGUE THAT STUDENTS ARE
SERVE BETTER HAVING A BETTER
STUDENT TO FACULTY. RATIO BUT AS
THE NUMBER HAS GONE UP YOUR
GRADUATION RATE.
HAS SUCCESS RATE HAS GONE DOWN
SO HOW HOW DO YOU.
RECONCILE US TWO POINT SO YOU
THE IN OTHER WORDS IT WORK YOUR
CUP WITH WHERE THANK WE LIVE PER
LAMENTING THAT WE HAVE. A MORE
STUDENTS.
IN A CLASS.
PER FACULTY IN THE LAST DECADE
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR EARLIER
CHARTS THE UNIT THE GRADUATION
SUCCESS RATE FOR THOSE STUDENTS
HAS GOTTEN BETTER.
BUT HAD HAD YOU ANSWER THAT.
WE WE DO THINK THAT STUDENTS
WOULD BE BETTER SERVED IN
SETTINGS WHERE THEY HAVE MORE
ACCESS TO A FACULTY MEMBER IN
SUCH SETTINGS. UNDERGRADUATES
CAN HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESEARCH OR DISCUSSION THAT THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE IF THEY'RE IN A
LECTURE HALL WITH. THREE OR FIVE
HUNDRED OTHER STUDENTS
SYSTEM WIDE WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE FOR OVERALL QUALITY LONG
TERM. TO AT LEAST KEEP THE
STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIO OF
FLAT.
WE HAVE MADE GRADE.
GREAT STRIDES IN INCREASING.
STUDENT SUCCESS AT UC
GRADUATION RATES AMONG OUR
UNDERGRADUATES ARE UP.
MUCH OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
OUGHT TO INCREASES IN STUDENT
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE ON OUR
CAMPUSES. SO THERE ARE
SPECIALIZED TUTORING THERE'S.
NEW A WE HAVE STARTED STUDENTS
CENTERS ON CAMPUSES WHERE
STUDENTS CAN COME IN GET PURER.
GUIDANCE AND MENTORING.
THAT ALSO HELPED THEM DURING
THEIR DURING THEIR TIMES IN
SCHOOL BUT WE THINK IT'S A.
GREAT GOAL FOR THE SYSTEM TO
HAVE TO FIGHT TO WIN. TO REDUCE
OUR STUDENT FACULTY RATIO BUT WE
REALIZE IT'S PROBABLY NOT
REALISTIC FOR THIS COMING YEAR
YEAH I KNOW LOGICALLY IT MAKES
SENSE.
BEING IN A CLASS WITH THAT THAT.
PROFESSOR AND THIRTY STUDENTS
BETTER THAN BEING A CLASS WITH
THE. IN THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
BUT AS THE ALEJO POINTED OUT IN
THE SAME TIME WHEN THE RATIO
INCREASED THE YEAR GRADUATION
RATES FOR A FOUR YEAR SWEAT
FROM.
A FORTY FIVE PERCENT TO SIXTY
FIVE SO.
MAYBE THE STUDENTS ARE MORE
THESE MONIES ARE MORE RESILIENT
AND PERSISTENT THAN THAT. THAN
THAT PRIOR GENERATIONS WE DO
HAVE THE BEST STUDENTS THERE WE
GO.
OKAY SO WITH THAT LET'S GET TO
THE STUDENTS.
AS FAR AS PUBLIC COMMENT AND
HOPE I'M SORRY MISTER MARTZ IT
YES THANK YOU.
.
START WITH TO THE STUDENTS YOU
CAN.
WE LEARN MORE.
ALONE HERE.
.
THERE'S.
RIVER TENANT YES TODD YOU KNOW
CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE LA ROSA
HIGHER EDUCATION ANNOUNCES. I
HAVE LOOKED AT IT I HAVEN'T
STUDIED EVERY PORTION OF IT IN
DETAIL BUT I WILL DO MY BEST TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I WANTED TO
ASK YOU THE SAME QUESTION ASKED
LA O. IF YOU CAN TURN TO. PAGE
TWELVE.
WRITTEN VIGOR SEVEN.
I I THINK THIS IS A.
A SOFTBALL THAT I'M TALKING TO
YOU BUT I.
I I SEE THIS DRAMATIC DROP.
IN THE PER PUPIL FUNDING.
FROM AROUND TWO THOUSAND.
AND AND AND THAT.
YEAH YOU SEE WE ARE FAR FROM
RECOVERING FROM THE PEAK IN PER
PUPIL FUNDING.
YES.
A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
ADDED EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND NEW
STUDENT ASSISTANCE TWO THOUSAND
OKAY THAT IS SO DRAMATIC ODD
NUMBER OF MORE STUDENTS THAT
YOU'RE DIVIDING THOSE RESOURCES
IT'S GOOD CLEAN. UP ALSO OUR
STATE GENERAL FUND IS NOW ONLY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS MORE IN
ACTUAL DOLLARS WHEN IT WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND SO YOU'RE TAKING
THOSE RESOURCES AND DIVIDING
THEM BETWEEN MORE STUDENTS WHAT
THIS DOES. IS IT SHIFTS THE
BURDEN OF THE INCREASED COST IN
EDUCATION ON TO STUDENT FEES.
SO COMING SO WE DO HAVE FEWER
FUNDS TO EDUCATE OUR EACH
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT BY.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THIS
CHART DOES NOT SUBTRACT IT
DOESN'T SURPRISE THE FACT THAT
WE HAD OF MANDATORY RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE BROUGHT
BACK GONE. IN TWENTY TEN.
YOU SEE HAD TAKEN QUITE A LONG
BREAK IN YOU SEE RETIREMENT
PROGRAM FROM CHARGING A. ITSELF
OURSELVES FOR. THE.
RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF WE HAVE
PROMISED OUR EMPLOYEES THOSE
WERE RESTARTED AND ARE NOW AT
FOURTEEN PERCENT OF PAYROLL. SO
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT THAT
CANNOT GO TO HIRING NEW
EMPLOYEES OKAY.
AND THEN ANOTHER THING THAT'S
NOT BEING SUBTRACTED HERE IS TO
FINANCIAL AID ALLOCATION OF
THAT.
THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDES OUT OF
ITS OWN FUNDS TO OUR STUDENTS.
ALRIGHT
THANK YOU THAT GIVES ME A WEB.
DEEPER APPRECIATION OF.
OF AT THIS CHART I I JUST
WANTED TO UP.
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WHAT YOU SAID
EARLIER THAT.
AND MY DISTRICT ALSO.
THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN I HERE
IS ACCESS AND THAT WE JUST HAD A
HEARING.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
HOSTED ABOUT THE NEED FOR.
YOU KNOW A LOT MORE CAUSE
AGREES A LOT MORE COLLEGE
EDUCATED GRADUATES TO MEET THE
WORKFORCE DEMANDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A WHILE I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
EFFORTS TO. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ACHIEVING EFFICIENCIES
AND AND AND AND TO.
SAVE COSTS IS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE I ALSO.
SURE.
MR MEDINA IS FRUSTRATION THAT
THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN PLAYING AROUND WITH THE.
YOU KNOW.
THREE PERCENT HERE FOUR PERCENT
HOW THEIR.
WOULD I I I THINK THAT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WE NEED TO BE
EDUCATING A LOT MORE. A COLLEGE
GRADUATES.
IN AND THAT THE WAY TO DO THAT
IS BY INCREASING
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITMENTS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY YOUR
TESTIMONY AND WE'LL SEE YOU BACK
IN OUR.
FOLLOW UP HEARINGS WITH THAT.
WE WILL PROCEED WITH THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT
YOU COULD LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THE ROOM.
HOME COURT ADVANTAGE BY CS YOU.
YEAH.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO ASK
EVERYBODY TO KEEP THEIR COMMENTS
TWO TO ONE MINUTE.
ONE MINUTE COMMENTS PLEASE THANK
YOU ALRIGHT I'LL TRY IT
AFTERNOON AT YOUR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET SUB TO A
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S JENNIFER
EGAN I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE REPRESENT THE OVER TO TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PROFESSORS
LECTURES LIBRARIANS COUNSELORS
AND COACHES. WHO TEACH AND
MENTOR STUDENTS IN THE CSU
SYSTEM?
THE COMMITTEE RECENTLY HOSTED A
HEARING ON THE DEGREE GAP DURING
WHICH THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA STATED
THAT CALIFORNIA IS ON PACE TO BE
OVER ONE MILLION COLLEGE
GRADUATE SHORT.
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BY TWENTY
THIRTY.
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL OF
MORE DEGREES WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON.
EQUITY ACCESS AND ECONOMICS
FIRST OFF EQUITY.
SEE AFFAIRS REPORT EQUITY
INTERRUPTED SHOWS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM EDUCATES A FAR MORE
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY TODAY THAN
IT DID THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND
THAT AS THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
OF COLOR HIS INCREASED PUBLIC
FUNDING FOR THE CSU HAS
DECREASED.
NEARLY THREE QUARTERS A OF OUR
STUDENTS IDENTIFY AS STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
FUNDING FOR THE CSU IS NOT ONLY
A MATTER OF CREATING CLASS
MOBILITY BUT IT FOSTERS RACIAL
JUSTICE AS WELL AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
COIN. FAILING TO SUFFICIENTLY
FUND THE CSU IS TO ACTIVELY
WORSEN ALREADYEXISTING RACIAL
DISPARITIES.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS ACCESS AND
WE KNOW FOR WE KNOW THAT THE CSU
TURNED AWAY THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS THIS PAST
YEAR DUE TO FUNDING. AND
ACCORDING TO THE CSU ZONE OWN
NUMBERS TWENTY TO THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS EACH YEAR OVER
THE LAST SIX.
A AND.
A.
PERHAPS IN CONTRAST.
.
DOES TO THE UC NINETY FOUR
PERCENT OF CSU STUDENTS ARE FROM
CALIFORNIA. SO WE BELIEVE
REASONABLY SO THAT THIS TREND
WILL ONLY GET WORSE WITHOUT A
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET AUGMENTATION.
THESE ARE LIFE CHANCES MISSED BY
REAL YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE
PROMISED A SEAT AT A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY.
THIS IS ALSO CERTAINLY A CRISIS
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
ECONOMIC WELL BEING.
AT SO AS YOU ARE AWARE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED UNDER FUNDING
THIS THIS YES YOU WITH NINETY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS THE CSU IS YOU HEARD
REQUESTED TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLIONDOLLARS AND MY
ORGANIZATION CFA IS
RECOMMENDING.
OF FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS SO IN SHORT.
YOU MIGHT WONDER WHY THE
DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE IT IS YOU
DOUBLE TIME.
ALRIGHT SO GREAT APPETITE
THE CURRENT.
.
BUT IF IF THE STATE REALLY WANTS
TO PREPARE FOR THE NEXT DOWNTURN
IT SHOULD DO SO BY INVESTING IN
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
WORKERS FEEL OUR ECONOMY PEOPLE
WITH FOR YEARS DEGREES ARE
PARTICULARLY VALUABLE TO ARE
PARTICULARLY VALUABLE AND
DEGREES HELP LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY. IF YOU AGREE THAT
BUDGET IT THAT BUDGETS ARE MORAL
DOCUMENTS AS I THINK THAT YOU
DO.
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD AGREE THAT FUNDING THE
DREAMS OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND FAMILIES
JUST THIS PAST YEAR ACCOUNTING.
OF FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO EARN A
DEGREE IS MONEY WE'RE SPENDING
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN GREENER
PRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
JENNIFER IAN THAT THE CSU
FUNDING REQUEST IS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS SHORT. IN A PARTICULAR
CONCERN TO ME IS WHAT HAPPENS TO
NOT ONLY A THROUGH G. ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WATER TURNED AWAY BUT
ALSO COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AS THE PP I SEE NOTED ARM WE
NEED A RADICAL INTERVENTION IN A
SENATOR WERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIRCHI SAID WE NEED A RADICAL
INTERVENTION. INTO.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING
SYSTEM.
AND IN THE CSU WERE EXPECTED TO
TAKE AN ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
TRANSFER STUDENTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. IF WE
ARE GOING TO ACHIEVE THAT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DEGREE FOR
YOUR DEGREE SHORT FALL.
PROTECTED BY THE PP I SEE. AND
WITHOUT ADEQUATE FUNDING WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES NOT
ONLY ABOUT THE INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT ALSO THE
INVESTMENT IN THE RECEIVING
INSTITUTIONS. OTHERWISE THE
TRANSFER INITIATIVES THE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHETHER IT
WORKS OR NOT OWNED THE
GUARANTEED GUIDED PATHWAYS WILL
BE FOR NAUGHT BECAUSE STUDENTS
WILL HAVE A GUARANTEED SEAT. TO
ABSOLUTELY NO WHERE WE NEED TO
GUARANTEED GENERATIONS OF
STUDENTS ON A FUTURE FOR THE
FUTURE DRIVERS OF THE STATE
ECONOMY. IT'S SHORT SIGHTED AND
AS ARE JENNIFER ALLUDED TO IT'S
AWFUL ALSO RACIALLY UNJUST
I'M AT THE VERY MOMENT THAT THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION IS FIGHTING
AGAINST POLICIES THAT ARE COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WE DON'T LIKE THAT ARE RACIST.
NATIVIST OF AND ARE HURTING OUR
STUDENTS WERE HURTING THOSE VERY
SAME STUDENTS BY NOT INVESTING
IN THE CSU AND OFFERING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE THE FOUR
YEAR DEGREES THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
I'M CECIL CANTON.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT HE'S.
JERRY MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
.
WE ARE WELL ONE MAIN COLLEGE
GRADUATES SHORT.
COMMITTED DEMANDS OF OUR OF OUR
STATE HAS STATE'S ECONOMY.
THIS IS AN ISSUE IN LARGE PART
DUE TO. NOT CHEST GRADUATION.
BUT ALSO TO ACCESS
WHO THE STUDENTS.
IN OUR WHITE PAPER.
HARD TO SEE IF A WHITE PAPER
ECKLEY INTERRUPTED.
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
A FAR MORE DIVERSE.
A STUDENT BODY THAT WE HAVE
THIRTY YEARS AGO.
IN FACT IN THE PAPER WE SAY
THAT.
AS THE STUDENT BODY GOT DARKEN.
THE FUNDING GOT LIGHTER.
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE GOT
TO DEAL WITH.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE TURNED AWAY
LAST YEAR FROM THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS FROM THE CSU.
I AM WE BEEN TURNING AWAY SIX TO
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS EVERY
YEAR FOR THE LAST SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS.
THE.
.
MANY WHO WERE TURNED AWAY.
WERE UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT FACT
THAT THESE ARE FOLKS WHO NEED
CHANCES.
TO GET INTO.
ODD THE ECONOMY FAITH THEY
DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
EDUCATED.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED UNDER
FUNDING THE CSU WITH A NINETY
TWO MILLION A BALLOT OUT A
AMOUNT.
WHILE THAT WHILE THE CSU BRICK
REQUESTED TWENTY SIXTY THREE
MILLION AND OUR ORGANIZATION AS
IT WAS AS WAS MENTIONED. RIP ARE
RECOMMENDED FOR TO TWENTY TWO
MILLION.
IF THE STATE REALLY WANTS TO
PREPARE.
FOR THE NEXT DOWNTURN.
IT SHOULD DO SO BY INVESTING IN
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND IT SHOULD DO THAT BY ALSO
IDENTIFYING A LONG TERM
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE.
THAT CAN BE USED FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IF WE DON'T DO THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING AS AS A MR MEDINA
HAS SAID.
WITH THE THREE AND FOUR PERCENT.
AND NOT REALLY ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS MORE
THANKED US AND I AM A STUDENT
FROM A SACRAMENTO STATE. OF I'M
AN ETHNIC STUDIES IN ASIAN
AMERICAN AND.
WOMAN'S MAJOR AND I AM HERE TO
WITH THIS YEAR A AND STUDENTS
FOR QUALITY EDUCATION.
HERE TO PROVIDE A STUDENT
NARRATIVE AND.
OUT TO START THAT I STARTED
THIS SEMESTER WITH A THREE JOB.
DO YOU JOBS ON BUT I HAD TO DROP
ONE JOB BECAUSE I WAS FORCED TO
TAKE EIGHTEEN UNITS.
I HAD FULL TIME FIFTEEN UNITS
AND I WAS FORCED TO TAKE
EIGHTEEN UNITS BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW WITH THAT.
YOU HAVE TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS.
.
DOES FORCED TO THIS IS LIKE
SOMETHING LIKE ME AS A STUDENT.
AND THOUGH I RECOGNIZE THAT I
HAVE PRIVILEGED I'M HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CSU BECAUSE
I'M AN IMMIGRANT AND I'LL I WAS.
IN A PLACE WHERE I HAD I DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
BUT KNOWING THAT THE PRIVILEGE
THAT I HAVE IS TAKEN AWAY JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE UNDER FUNDED A
SOMETHING RIDICULOUS.
.
SO YOU KNOW I WANT TO FORMALLY
ASK YOU TO STAND WITH ME I'M
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS PEOPLE.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND STUDENTS
ALL OVER IT THE CALIFORNIA JUST
LIKE ME OR.
ARE WORKING HARD AND WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO STUDY WE DON'T HAVE
BECAUSE WE WAKE UP OR GO TO
SCHOOL.
WE GO TO SLEEP WE EAT WE GO TO
WORK AND THAT'S LIKE EVERY
SINGLE DAY. ON I'M HERE.
JUST MISS MY CLASS
HOME BECAUSE I WANT TO TESTIFY
ON SO THAT'S IT THANK YOU GOOD
E
GOLDFISH A MUFFIN AND A SMOG BAG
OF CHIPS THAT'S ALL THAT HAD E.
TODAY WHEN AM A THOUGHT AND I'M
A STUDENT AT SAC STATE. AND YOU
KNOW GROWING UP.
IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO ALL HAVE
WONDERFUL EVER WANTED WAS TO BE
A SACRAMENTO STATE WARNING BUT
NOW THAT I'M HERE I COULD BARELY
AFFORD IT I COME FROM A
HOUSEHOLD THE SIX WHERE I
HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. APPEARS TO
HAVE A RETIREMENT FUND IS
NOTHING SAVE FOR THE FUTURE ALL
THE MONEY WE HAVE GHOST OF FOOD
AND BILLS FOOD AND BILLS FOOD
AND BILLS.
AND LIKE OTHER CSU STUDENTS I
STRUGGLE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
FACTS AND FIGURES WE ARE FLESH
AND BONE AND WHEN WE ARE UNDER
FUNDED WE HURT WE HUNGER WE
STRUGGLE AND LIKE YOU MISTER
MEDINA I AM TIRED OF HIM WHAT HE
CAN'T DO BETTER.
AND.
YOU KNOW CSU EDUCATION MEANS
THAT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
TAKE CARE MY FAMILY OF MY
PARENTS IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME TO GO BACK TO SOUTH
SACRAMENTO IS A TEACHER. WHERE
YOU KNOW KIDS THAT LOOK LIKE ME
ARE SEVENTY PERCENT OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES BUT ONLY FORTY
PERCENT OF COLLEGE ATTENDEES WE
CAN DO BETTER? AND BY NOT
FUNDING THE CSU YOU KNOW TAKEN
AWAY JEAN TO TAKEN WHERE FUTURE
SO PLEASE FIND US FUND THE DREAM
WE CAN DO BETTER WE DESERVE TO
DO BETTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
CHAIR TRUTH HAVE ON THE CAL
STATES IN ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT ALL CSU STUDENTS ON WE
WERE VERY DISAPPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST AND
ARE ASKING YOU ALL TO SUPPORT.
THE CS USEFUL.
A FULL BUDGET REQUEST AT AT
MINIMUM.
STUDENTS ARE FACING THE SECOND
YEAR OF A TUITION INCREASE AND
THEY'RE EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AND I WANTED TO
REFERENCE REALLY QUICK WHAT THE
LA L. I'M HAD IN THEIR.
IN THEIR PRESENTATION THE
PURPOSE.
THE FUNDING PER AT THE NUMBERS
AND SAY THAT WHILE.
BUT THEY ASSERT THAT IT'S
REMAINED STEADY SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TUITION HAS
NEARLY TRIPLED IN THAT TIME SO
WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS ARE TAKING
ON A LARGER BURDEN OF FUNDING
THE INSTITUTION. WERE ASKING
THAT YOU ALL SUPPORT THIS ISSUES
BUDGET REQUEST THIS YEAR AND
ALSO ADDRESS THIS LONG TERM
TREND OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST SIXTY YEARS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M JAKE RENDER I'M WITH YOU
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AT LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR REMARKS
THAT I REALLY NEEDED A WAKE UP
CALL FROM THE.
EXISTING CONVERSATION AROUND
FUNDING AT OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY JOINS
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IN OUR
OTHER.
COMMENTERS HERE.
CALLING FOR THE NEED FOR
EXPANDED ACCESS TO THE YOU SEE
IN THE SEE IF YOU LAST YEAR WE
PUBLISHED A REPORT CARD ON HOW
IS CALIFORNIA DOING TO CLOSE THE
DEGREES GAP THAT WAS CITED.
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD TO GIVE OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON F. GRADE
AND THAT'S DRIVEN IN LARGE PART
BY THE LACKING CAPACITY AT OUR
FOUR YEAR ON INSTITUTIONS OF
OUR.
OF PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE STUDENT FOCUSED FUNDING
FORMULA PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
MEANS OF INCORPORATING EQUITY.
AND STUDENT SUCCESS CONCERNS
INTO THE CURRENT WAY THAT WE
PORTION FUNDING FOR OUR COLLEGES
SO THAT WE CAN BOTH GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
STUDENTS THAT NEED IT. AS WELL
AS MAKE SURE THAT STUDENT
SUCCESS IS KEPT AT
FOR OF EVERY A CONVERSATION WE
HAVE AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT
DISTRICT LEVELS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLODIMERA KHAMENEI
REPRESENTING THE LOS RIOS CALLS
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION TEACHERS
AND THE FACT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES. SO THE
TRUCK WILL BE ABOUT ME COLLEGES
SO MANY THINGS I TALK ABOUT A
LIMIT MY COMMENTS IN JUST A
COUPLE OF THINGS ONE. IS THAT IN
TERMS OF THIS NEW FUNDING
FORMULA
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE CD
YOU HAVE A DISCUSSION CONCERNING
THIS ISSUE WITH THE CEOS CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICERS. I BELIEVE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING GROUPS
ACADEMIC SENATE AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN COMMITTEE
COLLEGES TO TALK ABOUT THIS NEW
FUNDING FORMULA. AND THEN BROWN
SIMULATIONS THAT TEST HOW THIS
NEW FUNDING FORMULA WOULD AFFECT
THE BUDGET OF CAMINO COLLEGES
BEFORE CAME TO A BUDGET BILL.
NOT IN THIS CASE.
NOW THEY'RE HAVING A TASK FORCE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THEY CAN
FIT THIS OF THIS FUNDING FORMULA
WITH JUST THE CEOS.
OKAY NO CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICERS
NO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING GROUPS
NO ACADEMIC SENATE NO OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WERE ALL SHUT OUT
THE PROCESS. THAT'S NOT THE WAY
THAT I THINK THAT YOU DO THIS
TYPE OF KEY BUDGETING ITEM.
SOMETHING WITHIN A THREE MONTH
PERIOD AND YOU'RE GONNA GET
SOMETHING THAT RISK GOING TO
REALLY TRULY WORK THE WAY YOU
INTENDED TO. I DON'T THINK THIS
IS THE WAY THAT IT SHOULD BE
DONE.
THE OTHER THING WOULD BE I IN
TERMS OF I THINK MR MEDINA YOU
WOULD UNDERSTAND THIS WHEN YOU
OPEN UP A CALLS PORTS WHERE
THERE'S. OR ON GRANT.
YOU HAVE NO CONTROL WITH AN OPEN
ACCESS OPEN ENROLLMENT SYSTEM OF
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE THOSE
COURSES.
SO WHEN YOU OPEN UP THIS ONLINE
COLLEGE
CLASS
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT THE ONLY
STUDENTS THERE ARE GOING TO ROLL
IN THERE. ARE COME FROM THAT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION STUDENTS
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THOSE
CLASSES THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE THAT'S
A DREAM. THIS IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN
SO THIS IS NOT VERY WELL THOUGHT
OUT ADULT BECAUSE ESPECIALLY
WITH IT'S AN ONLINE CLASS. THAT
EXACERBATES THE PROBLEMIT
DOESN'T MAKE IT ANY BETTER.
FOR THOSE TARGETED POPULATIONS
TO POPULATIONS
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY JUST
THEM CHO SHORT. THIS THIS IS A
COLLEGE THAT WILL NOT BE
ACCREDITED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
FIGURE THEY'RE GONNA BE TAKING
THESE CLASSES THEY'LL NEVER
TRANSFER. TO ANOTHER ALCHEMY
COLLEGES ARTISTS YES YOU YOU SEE
BECAUSE I'M NOT ACCREDITED
INSTITUTION DETAIL TAKE FORTY
EIGHT YEARS TO GET
ACCREDITATION.
FROM THEIR CREDIT MISSION.
RIGHT NOW SO I YOU KNOW THIS IS
A SERIOUS PROBLEM THEY THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD CONSIDER. ON
TERMS OF THIS SEPARATE NEW
ONLINE COLLEGE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS HARSHA SURVEY SURE
AND I AM A SECOND YEAR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY.
WITH ME TODAY ARE ABOUT TWENTY
STUDENTS FROM THE UNIVERSITAT
TODAY THEY'RE GONNA TELL YOU
THEIR OWN STORIES BECAUSE AS YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AMMONIA NOTED SO ELOQUENTLY WE
NEED A CENTER STUDENT VOICES IN
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE ARE
BEING LEFT OUT.
SO TODAY YOU WILL HEAR ABOUT HOW
DECADES OF STATE DISINVESTMENT
INCLUDING DISINVESTMENT THAT WAS
CAUSED BY POLITICAL DISPUTES
BETWEEN THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND THE GOVERNOR. HOW
THAT DISINVESTMENT HAS DEEPLY
IMPACTED STUDENTS NEGATIVELY ON
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES?
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT HOW ON MY
CAMPUS ONE HALF OF OUR STUDENTS
FACE.
FOOD INSECURITY AND A QUARTER
AND ONE FIFTH FACE HOUSING
INSECURITY AT SOME POINT IN
THEIR CAREER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY. AND YOU
WILL HEAR ABOUT ON MY CAMPUS HOW
BECAUSE OUR FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES SO POORLY FUNDED AND SO
POORLY STAFFED MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS DON'T GET THEIR
FINANCIAL AID PAYMENTS ON TIME
AND ARE CONSEQUENTLY DROPPED
FROM THEIR COURSES. AND OR
EVICTED FROM THEIR APARTMENTS.
AND THESE ARE DEEPLY PERSONAL
STORY SO I ASK THAT WHEN YOU
HEAR THEM YOU DON'T GO ON YOUR
PHONES THAT YOU PAY THE STUDENTS
THERE. THE DETENTION THAT THEY
DESERVE BECAUSE ALL THE MISSED
THEIR CLASSES TO BE HERE AND
THAT WAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME EMOTIONAL LABOR ON THEIR
PART.
O. WITH THAT I'M GOING TO LEAVE
US THE REST OF MY PEERS AND I
SINCERELY HOPE THAT YOU TAKE OUR
TESTIMONY AND ACCOUNT AND THAT
WHEN THE BUDGET PROCESS UNFOLDS
THAT YOU ADVOCATE FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
WE A STUDENTS AS ORGANIZERS AND
AS VOTERS WILL BE LOOKING TO YOU
WE WILL BE WATCHING YOU AND WE
PLAN ON HOLDING YOU ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE ALL OF YOU TALK A GOOD
GAME BUT COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY.
BUT IT IS TIME FOR YOUR ACTIONS
TO MATCH YOUR RHETORIC
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRIEVING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
THAT NASH IRE I'M A FIRST YEAR
FROM UC SANTA CRUZ.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE'VE BEEN
TOLD I'M A STUDENTS ASPIRING TO
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION WITH IN
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE BEST COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. AND SO THE
ACCOLADES THE RESEARCH
ACHIEVEMENTS
MAY ALL SEEM TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENT BUT ARE. A DISTRACTION
THE FACE OF THE REALITY IN THE
THROUGH TRUTH OF THE SITUATION
AND SOME GOING TO BE VERY HONEST
I'M SEVERAL FOLKS HERE BODY
CONVEYED. THE SENTIMENTS.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS AS PART OF THE AYE
DELEGATION FROM THE YOU SEE.
ATTENDING A YOU SEE AND FOR
THAT MATTER ANY PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM IN CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE IS NOT
AFFORDABLE ON AS A FRESHMAN I AM
SUPER SUFFERING IN OTHER
STUDENTS IS SUFFERING FROM. THE
COST OF OVER NORMAN A DIRECT
RESULT OF WHAT WAS MANDATED BY
THE STATE LAST YEAR ON UC SANTA
CRUZ IS NEAR IN HOSPITAL BECAUSE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
EDUCATE.
EACH ADDITIONAL STUDENT MANDATED
TO BE ENROLLED BY THE UC ON IS
NONEXISTENT SKIPPING MEALS
SKIPPING CLASSES ARE ALL
COMMONALITY FOR MYSELF AND MY
PEERS. OVERCROWDED BUSES OVER
CROWDED DINING AREAS CLASS IS
THE INABILITY TO EVEN REGISTER
FOR CLASSES PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE OUR MAJORS THAT ARE
IMPACTED. ALL A COMMON A
COMMONALITY FOR UC SANTA CRUZ
AND ARE YOU SEE INSTITUTIONS YOU
SEE WHY. I'M IN SO I'M ASKING
YOU ALL AS OUR LEGISLATORS AYE
TO FUND US.
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN DENIED FOR
YEARS AND IT'S NOT A PASS FOR
Y'ALL TO DIRECT US TO YOU CALL
FOR THE REGION'S BECAUSE WE ARE
ASKING YOU AND WILL HOLD YOU
RESPONSIBLE AS. WAS ECHOED BY
MAY PIER BEFORE.
YOU'RE ALL HERE AND YOU'VE YOU
KNOW TALKED A GOOD GAME ABOUT
FUNDING US BUT LIKE MY PEERS
SAID BEFORE IT IS TIME FOR YOU
ALL TO TAKE ACTION AND ACTUALLY
ACT ON THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT. IN THIS
THREE HOUR COMMITTEE SESSION
THANK YOU.
JOE MCCARTY IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROGER ROBINSON I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING THE FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AT UC BERKELEY
IS EXTERNAL AFFAIRS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THEIR STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION. ACTIONABLE LECTURE
THE STARTS AT FIVE PM TODAY BUT
I DECIDED TO BE A BETTER USE OF
MY TIME TO COMEADDRESS YOU
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT UNLESS I
SHOW UP EARLY. I LITERALLY WON'T
HAVE A SCENE LIKE THIS ON THE
AISLE ON THE FLOOR.
OVERCROWDED CLASSROOMS ARE JUST
ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF UNDER
FUNDED MANDATES FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH ACROSS THE SYSTEM BUT A
FAR MORE SERIOUS AND DIRE ONE IS
A SHORTAGE OF AVAILABLE HOUSING.
BERKELEY IS THE UC CAMPUS IT
CURRENTLY HOUSES THE SMALLEST
CHAIR OF ITS STUDENTS OUR
CAMPUSES MOST RECENT HOUSING
SURVEY INDICATES A TEN PERCENT
OF UC BERKELEY STUDENTS WILL
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AT SOME
POINT DURING THEIR TIME AT
BERKELEY. WE DON'T HAVE THE
PHYSICAL ROOM OR THE FUNDS TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING AND GETS THE
STATE CONTINUES TO ASK FOR MORE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FROM US.
YOU SEE WAS BUILT ON PRINCIPLES
OF ACCESS AFFORDABILITY AND
QUALITY BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK
BEYOND JUST ACCESS
UNFUNDED ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS
DECIMATING THE QUALITY OR
EDUCATION AND THE AFFORDABILITY
OF COSTS OF ATTENDANCE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR THE UC HAS
ANSWERED THESE FUNDING NEEDS BY
INCREASING TUITION BUT THIS IS
GONE ON FOR FAR TOO LONG AS THE
REGION'S REALIZED AT THEIR LAST
MEETING. THIS YEAR THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT ARE
COMING TO YOU TO DEMAND MORE FOR
THE UC.
BUDGETS ARE STATEMENT OF VALUES
STATE TRULY VALUES THAT YOU SEE
IN HIGHER EDUCATION IT WILL
GRANT US THE FULL FOUR PERCENT
INCREASE IN FUNDING THAT WE ARE
EXPECTING.
STATE TRULY VALUE SO YOU SEE IT
WILL ENSURE THERE IS FUNDING
GRANTED FAR RECENT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE COSTS NEITHER OF
WHICH IS ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. BUT
A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE I'M
TELLING FAMILY FIGURE
UNDERGRADUATES TODAY UC IRVINE
I'M HERE TODAY TAKING TIME WHEN
I COULD BE STUDYING FOR MY
MIDTERMS OUT THAT SHE WRITING A
PAPER ON THE FLIGHT ON THE WAY
CARE.
AND I'M HERE NOT ONLY TO
REPRESENT MYSELF BUT ALSO TO
EACH THOUSAND OF MY FELLOW AND
EATERS AT IRVINE.
I'M HERE TO ASK BY LEGISLATORS
PEOPLE THAT WE AS VOTERS AND
STUDENTS.
TO PUT THAT WE PUT OUR TRUST IN
YOU TO REPRESENT US AND TO
INVEST IN HIGHER EDUCATION NOT
ONLY FOR OURSELVES BUT FOR THE
FUTURE. GENERATIONS COME YOU SEE
IS CURRENTLY AT FULL CAPACITY OF
CURRENT FUNDING BARELY ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE RESOURCES FORCE
CURRENT STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I MEAN. LIKE THE SAID
LIKE I SEE MY FELLOW CLASSMATES
SITTING ON THE FLOOR OF A
LECTURE HALLS THEY'RE SLEEPING
IN THE LIBRARIES THERE.
SUBSIDING THEMSELVES ARE JUST
COFFEE AND CHIPS ALONE AND I NOT
ONLY SEEN I'M EXPERIENCING THAT
WE'RE ALL EXPERIENCING THIS ARM.
AND ALSO THE COST OF EDUCATION
IS NOT JUST TUITION LOANS ALSO
ACROSS THE PDIF HAVING TO LIVE
AS A PERSON HAVING TO PAY FOR
ALL THE THINGS HAVING TO GO
THROUGH. FOOD INSECURITY HOUSING
INSECURITY ALL THE STUFF AND
ALSO THE FACT THAT I'M A PROUD
CHILD OF AN OF IMMIGRANTS MY
PARENTS CAME HERE IN ORDER TO
GIVE MYSELF BETTER.
OPPORTUNITIES AND GET MY YOUNGER
SIBLINGS BUT OPPORTUNITIES AS
WELL BUT THE THING IS. HOW CAN
WE AFFORD TO THAT WHEN THE STATE
IS UNWILLING TO INVEST IN OUR
EDUCATION THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON WHEN HE WAS THERE
REALLY THINK HE DOES. I AM A
JUNIOR AT UC IRVINE AS WELL.
AND.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA SOUND LIKE
A BROKEN RECORD I DON'T EVEN OWN
AGREED THAT IS THE SAME THING
THAT ALL OF MY PEERS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONING IS WHAT WE'RE ALL
EXPERIENCING. ALL OF MY FRIENDS
ARE DEALING WITH THAT IT'S
EXHAUSTING IT'S EMOTIONALLY
DRAINING IT'S MENTALLY DRAINING
WAS SUPPOSE TO BE FOCUSING ON
EDUCATING OURSELVES. AND WE
CAN'T BECAUSE ALREADY THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN BE AFFECTS
QUARTER. OUR HOUSING WE HAVE TO
PLAN A YEAR IN ADVANCE ARE WE
GONNA BE ABLE TO AFFORD
EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT TO DO IN
ORDER TO GRADUATE ON TIME. AND
THEN BE ABLE TO GET A JOB
AFTERWARDS IT'S EXHAUSTING.
OUR UNIVERSITY ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCE A LOT OF ISSUES.
PRIOR TO THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. DUE TO
STUDENTS ARE BEING THREATENED TO
BE RESCINDED.
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS TOTAL
ACTUALLY.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR STUDENT
EFFORTS THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY BUT THEN
WE SUFFERED OF THE STUDENT BODY.
ALL OF OUR RESOURCES ARE.
LIKE IT'S RIDICULOUS OUR BUSES
ARE OVERCROWDED WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH BUSES I VERY. OF HOUSING
IS A BIG ISSUE ESPECIALLY IN
IRVINE ORANGE COUNTY IS VERY
EXPENSIVE OUR DORMS ARE NOT
ADEQUATE.
EVERYTHING IS JUST A MASS OF
MASS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY AND WE'RE EXHAUSTED
WE'RE TIRED OF ASKING FOR THIS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. I'VE SEEN
COUSINS OVER THE PAST DECADE
DEAL WITH THE THEME ISSUES OF
THE UC AND YOU WOULD THINK THAT
IT WOULD OF GOTTEN BETTER BY NOW
AND.
I HOPE THAT YOU TAKE ARE
STRUGGLING TO HEAR.
CONSIDERATIONS
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS SARAB CHINA SECOND
YEAR AT UC BERKELEY.
THE UC WAS FOUNDED ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF ACCESSIBILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY BUT IN REALITY THE
YOU SEE EXHIBITS NEITHER. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE STUDENTS HAVE
BECOME THE PRIMARY FINANCIAL
STAKE HOLDERS OF THE UC AND THE
REGIONS ARE STILL CONSIDERING
RAISING OUR TUITION BECAUSE THE
STATE BUDGET DID NOT COVER
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS OR
FUNDING FOR INCREASED
ENROLLMENT.
YOU SHOULD BE GETTING A COPY OF
STUDENT TESTIMONY IS TESTAMENT
O. SHORTLY SHOULD BE COMING
AROUND RIGHT NOW. THERE YOU'LL
FIND STE.
STORIES FROM PEOPLE LIKE HONEY
WHO OR ANY HOUSEWORK OVER TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK TO SUPPORT HERSELF
OR FROM PEOPLE LIKE JAY WHO IS
ALREADY OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS DEEP IN STUDENT LOANS.
THEY HAVE MANY PEERS IN THE SAME
BOAT AND THEIR SITUATION WILL BE
WORSE IF TUITION INCREASES AND
LET ME CLARIFY THAT TUITION IS
NOT GOING TO RAISE BECAUSE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE BLOAT IT'S GONNA
RAISE BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE'S.
STUDENTS OR TO CONTRIBUTE MORE
TO CAR FUNDS IN THE STATE DOES
SO I HAVE A HARD TIME CALLING
BERKELEY THE NUMBER ONE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY IN THE WORLD WHAT IS
NOT REALLY FUNDED BY THE STATE.
WE'VE OUR STATE FUNDING WE NEED
IT NOW AND WE NEED IT FOR THE
LONG TERM SO WE'LL BE WATCHING
WILL BE SKIPPING CLASS TO BE
HERE. AND WILL BE VISITING YOUR
OFFICES AND BE MAKING SURE THAT
YOU ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
THAT YOUR ACTIONS MATCH YOUR
RHETORIC WE URGE YOU TO FUND THE
UC AND ONCE AGAIN A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
GREAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS KILEY
MURDOCH AND I'M A SECOND YEAR AT
UC BERKELEY EMERGE GOING FROM
TORRANCE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERTZ OFF MARZI
SHE'S DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA IS ARGUABLY THE BEST
STAY IN THE U. S. BUT WE
CURRENTLY RANKED FIFTIETH IN
EDUCATION. IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM WE NEED TO INVEST IN
IT THE UC REGENTS RECENTLY
PROPOSED INCREASING OUR TUITION
IN ORDER TO FUND THE YOU SEE.
HOWEVER TUITION INCREASES MAKE
HIGHER EDUCATION LESS ACCESSIBLE
AND WE TOLD THE REGENTS THAT
WHEN WE WENT TO THEIR LAST
MEETING.
YOU SEE PRESIDENT NEPAL TANA
AGREED TO PUSH OFF TUITION
INCREASES AND WORK WITH US TO
LOBBY FOR INCREASED FUNDING SO
HERE WE ARE. IN BERKELEY I
CURRENTLY LIVE IN TO DOUBLE THAT
IS MEANT TO BE A SINGLE AND I
PAY EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH IN RENT. ON TOP OF TUITION
AND FEES AND RENTS I HAVE TO PAY
FOR TEXTBOOKS AND GROCERIES AND
TRANSIT COSTS.
TO KEEP THE UC SYSTEM ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE WE NEED THE STATE
TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE UC
SYSTEM WE WILL BE WATCHING OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS TO SEE IF
YOUR ACTIONS SUPPORT HERE.
RHETORIC OF SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SYNDICATES DE ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DISTRIBUTED OUR BUDGET LETTER
OUTLINING OUR CONCERNS BUT VERY
BRIEFLY ON THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE BELIEVE A MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY TO TARGET. A THAT
POPULATION WOULD BE TO REJECT
THE PROPOSED FUNDS TO INS
INSTEAD INCREASE THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE.
WE'VE ALSO PROPOSE ALTERNATIVE
METRICS ON THE FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH MOVES AWAY FROM
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING WHICH
WE FEEL WHAT EXASPERATED
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
AND FOR CLOSE OPPORTUNITY ON
STUDENTS WHO ARE DEEMED HIGH
RISK.
FINALLY AND LIKE TO ECHO
CHRISTIANS EARLIER COMMENTS IN
ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR FULL AND
PART TIME FACULTY AND STUDENT
SIR STUDENT SERVICES. THESE
COMPONENTS ARE CRITICAL TO THE
COMMUNICATIVE AS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KELLY
OPERATE I'M A STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY I'M HERE EVEN THOUGH I
WAS UP UNTIL FOUR THIRTY LAST
NIGHT READING MATERNA THING AND
HAVE A CLASS AT THREE.
.
I'M ALSO A DELEGATE AT THE CP
AND WILL BE VOTING HAS WEAKENED.
I THINK ITS FIRST WELL FRANKLY
OFFENSIVE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HAVE
ESSENTIALLY THE ONLINE
ACCREDITATION PROGRAM. WHEN WE
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE A MILLION
A COLLEGE GRADUATE SHORT VERY
SHORTLY.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO REALLY TALK
ABOUT TODAY'S.
HOW FAILURE FROM THE UC
EXACERBATE OUR HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA?
SO AT UC BERKELEY.
WE ARE.
WE CAN BARELY AFFORD AND BARELY
HAVE ROOM TO HOW THE FIRST.
A LITTLE ON THE OTHER STUDENTS
OF METAL EDGE OF.
AND THAT NOT ONLY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPACTFUL OF STUDENTS AND I KNOW
STUDENTS WHO GOT INTO UC'S HAVE
GOOD GRADES.
THEY COULD AFFORD THE TUITION
BUT COULDN'T FOR THE RENT AND
THAT'S A SHAME A DAMN SHAME.
BUT IT ALSO HAS A SEVERE IMPACT
ON THE CITY'S BUT HOST OR UC'S
AND A FEW ISSUES.
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT.
WHEN STUDENTS CAN'T GET HOUSING
ON CAMPUS THEY'RE FORCED INTO
THESE COMMUNITIES WHICH ALREADY
HAVE MASSIVE MASSIVELY.
YOU KNOW BERKELEY IT'S PART OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKET IN THE WORLD.
AND WHEN STUDENTS ARE FORCED
INTO THOSE HOUSING MARKETS.
IT RAISES RENTS FOR EVERYBODY.
AND I KNOW THIS LEGISLATURE TOOK
A VERY BRAVE STEP LAST A
SESSION.
INCLUDING FORD VERY UP IN FRONT
OF HOUSING PACKAGE.
GOING FORWARD THAT PASSED TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FIRST.
IT MUST OTHERWISE WE WILL NOT
SELL OR HAVING.
I'M I AM YOUNGER THEY LOOK MY
BEARD IS
YOU KNOW DEFINITELY LITTLE THE
MAN BUT I WILL BE AT MANY
CONVENTIONS IN THE FUTURE. AT
THE CP AND I WERE MEMBER WHO
WILL STAND WITH STUDENTS IN WHO
DID NOT AND WHO ARE ON THEIR
PHONES WHILE THEY TALKED.
AND I WILL BE VOTING.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND THANK YOU FOR
RAISING FUNDING FOR THAT YOU GET
AT THEM.
HELLO MUCH LIKE KEVIN MCCARTY
I'LL BE LOOKING AT MY PHONE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRETY OF THIS.
I'M A CURRENT SECOND YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE AT UC SAN DIEGO
AND I'M ALSO HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATES JENSEN
EASY SAN DIEGO AND THE EASIEST
IN ASSOCIATION.
SO I'M MY OWN CAMPUS STUDENTS
STRUGGLE SO MUCH WITH BASIC
CAMPUS FOOD PANTRY BASIC NEEDS
CENTER AND HAVE TO HOST ON
CAMPUS CALL FRESH CLINICS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN
EAT.
ONLY A FEW DECADES AGO
CALIFORNIA LED THE NATION IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
RESISTANCE TO OUR FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IT IS IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER. THAT FUNDING HIGHER
EDUCATION CREATES ACCENTS
TWO UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF.
SINCE OF COLOR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN THE
ECONOMY TANKED THE STATE
DIVESTED FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
AND AS A RESULT YOU SEE TUITION
DOUBLED.
IN JANUARY WE WENT TO THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS AND THEY
DELAYED TUITION HIKE THAT WOULD
FURTHER BURGER INSTANCE LIKE
MYSELF.
NOW IT'S ON YOU TO FUND THE UC.
WE WERE ABLE TO CIRCULATE A
STATEWIDE PETITION AND GET
THOUSANDS OF SIGNATURES FROM YOU
SEE STAKEHOLDERS YOU SEE
STUDENTS AND ALUMNI.
THANK YOU AS ELECTIONS LOOM WE
WILL BE HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT I THINK NAY AGAIN THAT
THEY'RE RUDE COMMENTS FROM THE
CROWD AREN'T PART VERY
APPRECIATIVE ARE ASKING
EVERYBODY FOR. SIXTY SECONDS OR
LESS I HAD SOME OF THE STATE
WOULD ORGANIZATIONS YOU A LITTLE
MORE TIME THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ROOM TO A CERTAIN DEGREE OF TIME
ALREADY LOSING. THE MAJORITY OF
OUR MEMBERS SO IT'S PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL KEEP IT TO SIXTY
SECONDS OR LESS SHIRT YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MAX LUBIN I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I'M
ONE OF MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH RISE CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE FIGHTING TO BRING FREE
COLLEGE BACK TO OUR STATE.
YOU'VE HEARD FROM COUNTLESS
STUDENTS ABOUT HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS SO MY QUESTION FOR
YOU IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IT'S ABOUT. WHY WE'RE
SPENDING FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ON
A RAINY DAY FUND THAT STUDENTS
CAN AFFORD?
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SPENDING
BILLIONS MORE ON ROADS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INSTEAD OF
ADDRESSING STUDENTS NEEDS.
QUESTION IS WHY CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST PAID PRISON GUARDS
IN THE NATION INSTEAD OF
INVESTING IN STUDENTS WHO WILL
PAY MUCH LONGER DIVIDENDS TO OUR
STATE.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU TO
SOLVE THESE ISSUES IF
ADMINISTRATIVE BLOAT IS THE
PROBLEM YOU CAN LEGISLATE YOUR
WAY OUT OF THAT PROBLEM WE CAN
SOLVE IT TOGETHER. BUT DON'T
SHORT CHANGE STUDENTS BECAUSE OF
POLITICS BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE UC CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THIS
MUCH I MEAN I'M A CURRENT.
SENIOR UC BERKELEY I AM.
I'M CURRENTLY HOMELESS ALSO
BEEN HOMELESS FOR YEAR AND I'M
NOT HERE TALK ON THIS THAT'S
PLOY BY MOSTLY TO TALK ABOUT. OF
FOR COMMITTEE IN THE GOVERNOR
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SOMETHING
HOT POTATO BECAUSE WHEN BLAMING
THE OTHER ONE YOU KNOW MAKING
MONEY FROM HERE AND THERE. WE
GET IT RIGHT WHEN I GET MONEY
FROM THERE BUT.
I DO ASSURE YOU THAT IF IF WE
WERE TO SAY WE'LL GIVE YOU A
FIVE PERCENT RAISE. YOU WOULD
FIND THAT MONEY SOMEWAY SOMEHOW
IN THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND THAT'S WHY I'M AND I'M
ASKING YOU ALL. S. I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ALSO TOO YOU KNOW. TO
TAKE IN CONSIDERATION THE
MASSIVE TAX CUTS HAVE BEEN HAVE
BEEN GIVEN TO PRIVATE SECTOR THE
MASSIVE TAX CUTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN
TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO DO NOT. WHO
ARE NOT IN THERE AND IN OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SO I WANT YOU
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
IMPORTANCE OF HOUSING THE POINTS
OF EDUCATION AND A POINT OF
PRIDE THESE FUNDS FOR ON? CSU
EXCUSE YOU THINK WHEN COLLEGES
AND STUFF LIKE UP HERE I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DANA
ALPER I'M A JUNIOR AT UC
BERKELEY I'M AYE SERVICE IN OUR
A IN THE UC BERKELEY DORMS AND
AS SUCH GET A FIRST HAND OUTLOOK
ON THE CONSISTENT ISSUES THAT
ARE INCOMING STUDENTS FACE. ON
ONE OF THOSE IS VERY PROBLEM
IT'S FOOD INSECURITY ON THE MEAL
PLANS FAR CURRENT FRESHMAN
INCOMING STUDENTS SUPPORT AB TWO
MEALS A DAY ONE ON THE WEEKEND.
I CANNOT TELL YOU THE NUMBER OF
TIMES THE MY RESIDENTS HAVE COME
FOR TO ME. TELLING ME ABOUT HOW
THE SKIP MEALS ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
FACING FOOD INSECURITY AND HOW
IT'S AFFECTING THEIR EDUCATION.
WE HAVE POLICIES HERE AT UC
BERKELEY THAT'S DROPS TUNES FROM
THEIR CLASSES IF THEY HAVEN'T
PAID A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF THEIR
TUITION ON TIME. AND YET OUR
FINANCIAL AID OFTEN ISN'T
DISPERSED UNTIL THE END OF THE
SEMESTER.
THAT PAIRED WITH RISING TUITION
COSTS FORCES STUDENTS TO FOCUS
ON THEIR FINANCIAL INSTABILITY
OVER THEIR EDUCATION.
I MYSELF WORKED TWO JOBS ON
CAMPUS AND MY PARENTS RECENTLY
CAME PORTS ME TALKING ABOUT
THEIR WORK SITUATION AND NOW I
WILL HAVE TO LOOK FOR A THIRD
JOB ON CAMPUS BY THE END OF THE
SEMESTER. REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO BE ABLE TO BALANCE THAT WITH
A FULL COURSE LOAD AND WE'LL TRY
TO GET RELEVANT. EXTRA
CURRICULAR AND JOB OPPORTUNITIES
BUT I'M GONNA HAVE TO MAKE IT
WORK IN ORDER TO GET AN
EDUCATION WITH AN ARGUES THE
SYSTEM. WE HAVE TO THINK BACK TO
WHAT WAS THE UC FOUNDED UPON IT
WAS FOUNDED UPON ACCESSIBILITY
AFFORDABILITY AND INVESTMENT IN
THE FUTURE. RISING TUITION COSTS
AND DECREASE STATE FUNDING DO
NOT REFLECT ANY OF THOSE VALUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI I'M A VALUES VANESSA PARADIS
I'M A SECOND YEAR YOU SEE VERY
BERKELEY STUDYING ECONOMICS.
I'M TO START AGAIN FROM A TITLE
ON HIGH SCHOOL.
.
FROM THE LOWEST FUNDED BUT
LARGEST.
VERY HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE STATE O. USD A PRODUCT OF
THAT.
.
IN MY HIGH SCHOOLERS
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN STUDENTS.
ATTENDING YOU SEE FROM MY
GRADUATING CLASS
SO FULLER YOU CAN DO THE MATH BY
THE WAY THAT'S FOUR PERCENT.
SO ENSURING A YOU SEE AS ALONE
CONSISTENT I SEE MY PEERS AND I.
AM HAVING TO CHOOSE WHETHER WE
SHOULD PAY BILLS ARE BOOKS
MISSING CLASSES WHETHER.
JUSTICE.
JUST GIVE.
DOES THIS GET CLASSES.
JUST SO MAKE SURE TO PAY THE
RENT TO STRETCH EVERY DOLLAR TO
THE NEXT DAY THAT'S WHAT IT'S
BECOME TO PICK UP. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT SURVIVAL HAS COME TO
BECOME A SCHOLAR YES FOSTERING
DIVERSITY WILL COME WITH A PRICE
YOU WANT TO FIX THIS SO OFTEN
ASKING IS NOT TO. CONSIDER THE
STATISTICS ON MAKING DECISIONS
BUT START LISTENING TO HER
STORIES.
EVERY DOLLAR YOU PUT IN OUR
SCHOOLS THAT ARE MEANT TO
BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES LIKE MY
PEERS OF ALL SAD. USE OUR LIVES
TO START BEING ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE STATISTICS THAT BECAUSE THE
STORIES THAT MAKE UP OUR LIVES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS NEAR MCCLINTIC AND
THE JUNIOR TRANSFER UC BERKELEY
AND A FORMER STUDENT AT DE ANZA
COMMUNICABLE ITCH. HAVING
EXPERIENCED MULTIPLE FACETS OF
THE HIGHER ED SYSTEM COMMITTEE
COLLEGE AND NOW YOU SEE
BERKELEY.
I CAN SAY THAT THE RECURRING
THEME THAT SADDENS ME MOST IS
SEEING FELLOW PEERS HAVE TO
WORRY SO MUCH ABOUT FOOD HOUSING
FINANCIAL SECURITY WHEN THEY
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON BEING A
STUDENT.
THE LABOR THAT GOES INTO THE
POPE FOCUSING ON BEING A STUDENT
IS TOO SEVERE TO HAVE TO ALSO
WORRY ABOUT MAJOR BUDGETING.
AS A STUDENT MYSELF BUDGETING
COMING FROM A SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLD IN WHICH RECENTLY MY
FAMILY CONTRIBUTIONS HAVE
SICKNESS SIGNIFICANTLY DROPPED.
I AM UNABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
ADEQUATE FINANCIAL AID WHILE
ALSO HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
FINANCIAL SECURITY.
ANY PLANS INVOLVING A POSSIBLE
TUITION INCREASE AYE A THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THREATENS
THE SECURITY MYSELF AND MANY
OTHER STUDENTS.
LAST LAST MONTH MYSELF AND MANY
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM RISK BEING
DROPPED FROM OUR CLASSES BECAUSE
WAS WENT WITHIN THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS OF SCHOOL. TO GO TO THE UC
REGENTS MEETING.
THOUGHT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
MYSELF AND OTHERS.
AND WE SUCCEEDED IN GETTING
THAT DELAYED INCREASE BUT THEIR
ULTIMATE PLANS ARE DEPENDENT ON
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS ROOM AND
ONWARD.
THE BALL IS IN YOUR COURT NOW
AND WE HOPE YOU STAND WITH
STUDENTS OF THE STATE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STRUCK US
ALL WHEN I AM A JUNIOR TRANSFER
FROM.
UC BERKELEY I TRANSFERRED FROM
CHIEF HE COMMUTE COLLEGE.
COMING FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUND WE ARE OFTEN TOLD
THAT FAST FOOD WILL COVER MOST
OF OUR EXPENSES. ARE WHAT THE
DID NOT PREPARE ME FOR IS THE
FACT THAT MANY STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF WHEN I END UP HOMELESS
AND HUNGRY AT ONE POINT OR
ANOTHER DURING THE TRANSITION.
TO THE UC SYSTEM FOR ME THAT
CAME RIGHT AT THE START A UC
BERKELEY INSTEAD OF BEING
EXCITED FOR ONE OF THE MOST BEST
OPT BIRD BEST UNIVERSITIES IN
THE WORLD. I WAS TOO CONCERNED
WITH TRYING TO FIND A PLACE TO
SLEEP AT NIGHT.
THIS WOULD OFTEN BE ON FRIENDS
COUCHES OR AT THE SCHOOL
LIBRARY.
SCRAMBLING TO FIND A PLACE I
ENDED UP SIGNING THE LEASE FOR A
FIVE BEDROOM APARTMENT THAT
COSTS OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THAT'S FOR ELEVEN MONTHS.
.
I OFTEN HAVE TO RELY ON FOOD
PANTRY TO EAT BUT THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING I FACE ALONE. OVER
FORTY EIGHT PERCENT OF YOU SEE
STUDENTS A REPORT FACING OF FOOD
INSECURITY SO WHEN I SPEAK OF
THE DIRE NEED OF PROPERLY
FUNDING THE UC SYSTEM I SPEAK
NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF. BUT FOR
MOST OF THE YOU SEE POPULATION.
.
WE ARE WATCHING WE'RE VOTING SO
PLEASE. FROM THE UC SYSTEM THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S AUDIOPHILE I'M A
THIRD YEAR TRANSFER SHOULD I UC
BERKELEY YOU SEE WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN I WAS RAPED KNOWS OF A
SINGLE PARENT BY THAT TIME AS
WELL SO. BECAUSE OF THAT I HAD
ABSOLUTELY LIKE HOW DO YOU EVEN
START SCHOOL WITH THAT IN MIND A
BOOK RIGHT NOW MY FINANCIAL AID
HAS NOT EVEN DISPERSED OR OFTEN
TOLD THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
FINANCIALLY FOR BEING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS BUT I'VE BEEN SEEN A
DIME. I'VE HAD TO TAKE OVER
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ALREADY
TO PAY FOR MY FOOD AND AND RAN
EVERYTHING.
ON TOP OF THAT I WAS HOMELESS
FOR THE FIRST WEEK OF SCHOOL I
DON'T GET TO GO HOME AND SEE MY
SON INSTEAD I SEE HIM EVERY
SIXTY FOUR TO SIX MONTHS BECAUSE
I CAN'T AFFORD HAVE YOU LIVED.
HERE WITH ME ON TOP OF THAT AS A
TRANSFER STUDENT THURMOND
INSURANCE FOR STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT EVEN BOTHER TO APPLY TO THE
UC SYSTEM. THIS GIG LAST YEAR
WAS THE GOD LARGEST GRADUATING
ENTRANCE CLASS OF SEVENTY NOVI
COLLEGE GET ONLY A HANDFUL APPLY
TO THE UC SYSTEM WHY BECAUSE
WE'RE SCARED OF THE STUDENT
DOCTOR. GONNA COME WITH IT WHEN
I GOT MY. UC BERKELEY ACCEPTANCE
LETTER I WAS ONLY OUT FOR THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE AT THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND HOW OUR STUDENTS
OPPOSED TO CONTINUE TO. EVEN TRY
TO APPLY OR EVEN CONSIDER THE UC
SYSTEM ONE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FACED WITH.
AND ON TOP OF THAT THERE'S A
WORK STUDY PROGRAM THAT ITSELF
LIMIT STUDENTS TO FIFTEEN HOURS
A WEEK WHEN THAT IT'S UNDERSTOOD
THAT THOSE FIFTEEN HOURS ARE
MORE THAN ENOUGH. TO MAKE AN
IMPACT ON TUNIC ACADEMIC STUFF A
SUCCESS WELL THERE'S PLENTY OF
US THAT ARE WORKING THIRTY HOURS
A WEEK JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH FOOD. THAT WE CAN
PAY FOR A RIGHT OUR BOOKS AND
SCHOOL AND YET WE STILL HAVE TO
COME HERE SKIPPER CLASSES IN THE
MIDDLE OF MID TERM WEEK TO TELL
YOU GUYS DO THE RIGHT THING AND
TO FUND THE UC SYSTEM. THANK
YOU.
HELLO.
AND THEN THERE WERE FOUR.
THINK YOU MISSED MEDINA FOR
STANDING WITH US EARLIER TODAY
BLAMES BONTA SOIL MEANS TO
BERKELEY UNDERGRADUATE AYE
ARMED.
NOW SO HE WITH YOU SEE ESSAY.
HONESTLY I CAME HERE WITH HIGH
ALL WOULD LISTEN TO US BUT NOW
I'M NOT TOO SURE WHETHER. I YOU
MEAN TAKING OUR STORES INTO
CONSIDERATION.
I AM WORKING TWENTY HOURS A WEEK
SO I CAN COVER RENT THAT'S NOT
COVERED BY DR PASS A PACKAGE.
SOME REAL WILL SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT YOUR FAULT BUT RATHER THAT
OUR UNIVERSITIES YEAH AS. MY
COLLEAGUE ISMAIL MENTIONED IS
THE GAME HOT POTATO.
SPRING THE BLAME ON THE REGION'S
THEM TO REACH A POINT BLAME ON
YOU ALL.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO MOVING
FORWARD YOM YOU MENTIONED ON
THIS MCCARTY THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD SUPPORT
INCREASES AND BUDGET? BY YOU CAN
KEEP PUSHING YOU KEEP PUSHING I
WOULD THINK THAT THE
CONSIDERATION WILL LOOK AT YOUR
ACTIONS MOVING FORWARD. ON. MY
SISTER DO NOT WANT TO APPLY TO
ALL UC SYSTEM BECAUSE HE SAW THE
COST I'M.
I WOULD I WAS COSTLY TELLING HER
TO APPLY BUT. IN THE END SHE SAW
THAT THERE WAS THERE WAS GONNA
BE A DIFFICULTY ARTIFACTS OF OUR
IN OUR FAMILY.
AND IT PAINS ME THAT SHE WILL BE
ABLE TO GET AN EDUCATION FOR THE
UC SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TYLER
JACOBSON A THIRD YEAR STUDENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY.
LAST FRIDAY I SPENT THREE HOURS
WITH A FEW OF THE OTHER STUDENTS
WHO ARE PRESENT HERE TODAY AND
THE CENTER OF CAMPUS. URGING
STUDENTS TO CONTACT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING IN SUPPORT OF MORE
FUNDING FOR THE UC.
WE MAY CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALL THEIR NAMES
HERE.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE BEEN ON CAMPUS URGING JUST
URGING STUDENTS TO MAKE CALLS.
IN THAT WAY BUT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT ON FRIDAY CALLING ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING THE
RESPONSE FROM STUDENTS WAS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE STUDENT WE
TALK TO HAVE A STORY JUST LIKE
THE ONES WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
SO FAR PRESENCE HERE DOESN'T
SIGNAL TO YOU JUST HOW CLOSELY
WERE PAYING ATTENTION I HOPE
THAT KNOWING ABOUT THE CALLS WE
MADE LAST WEEK IN THE CALLS THAT
ARE COMING LATER THIS WEEK. AND
IN THE WEEKS TO COME DO.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELA
CRITERIAS NAM CURRENT AGING
ACCOUNTS PERSON AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
AND LIKE MANY OF MY PEERS I AM
HERE TO DEMAND GREATER FUNDING
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AS A FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND AUTHOR
OF TWO FARMWORKERS FROM CENTRAL
VALLEY COMING TO COLLEGE HAS
BEEN A DREAM COME TRUE. HOWEVER
PAYING FOR COLLEGE HAS BEEN A
NIGHTMARE.
WHEN YOU OPEN HIGHER EDUCATION
YOU MAKE IT HARDER FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR LIKE
NEED TO AFFORD STUFF LIKE BOOKS
RENT AND FOOD AND ACTION SHOWS
THAT YOU NOT CARE ABOUT US.
YOU KNOW YOU ALWAYS SUBSTANCE
LIKE ME THAT YOU CARE ABOUT US
AND THAT STUDENTS ARE THE FUTURE
LEADERS OF TOMORROW SOCIETY BUT
THEN YOU DON'T ALLOCATE ENOUGH
FUNDS.
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WHICH
ULTIMATELY MAKES IT HARDER FOR
US TO BE THE FUTURE LEADERS THAT
YOU SAY YOU WANT US TO BE SUNSET
OF TELLING US SHOW US PLEASE ONE
HIGHER EDUCATION ESTIMATES LIKE
NEED IF OUR EXISTENCE. IN THE
WORDS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
KEEP YOUR PROMISE THAT YOU GAVE
STUDENTS LIKE ME THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS A LOT OF HELP WHEN
I'M A SENIOR UC BERKELEY I WANT
TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
BURDEN OF TUITION PAID PLACED ON
STUDENTS.
AND.
I I'D ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS THE
IDEA THAT THROUGH THAT AND A
TUITION INCREASE DOES NOT AFFECT
LOW INCOME STUDENTS BECAUSE.
BEING UNDOCUMENTED IN BEING LOW
INCOME I HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THAT WHEN I WAS
APPLYING TO UC'S MY PARENTS TRY
TO STOP ME FROM APPLYING TO
COLLEGE IN GENERAL BECAUSE WE
CAN AFFORD IT RECEIVED LOANS ARE
FEDERAL FUNDING. SO I WANT TO
CAN YOU COLLEGE INSTEAD AND
THANKFULLY THROUGH THE RESOURCES
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE I WAS
ABLE TO FIND MY WAY HERE. BUT
THAT DIDN'T STOP THERE I HAVE.
I HAVE I STILL STRUGGLE WITH
PAYING FOR HOUSING AND FOOD I
HAVE LIVED IN A ONE BEDROOM WITH
FOUR PEOPLE AND ONE PERSON IN
THE LIVING ROOM. AND I STILL
STRUGGLE WITH FOOD ALL THE TIME
AND I GO TO THE FREE UP PANTRY
AREA ON CAMPUS BUT WE'RE ONLY
WATCH GET FIVE ITEMS TWICE A
MONTH SO THAT'S REALLY NOT
ENOUGH AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT. IT'S YOUR TIME TO ME TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS AND WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M CALLED HAS GONE
FROM SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
I'M THIRTY ONE YEARS OLD AND A
FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT. WHO
COULD HAVE FINISHED A COLLEGE IN
A MORE TIMELY MANNER BUT I HAD A
FEW ECONOMIC BEERS GET THERE AND
WHEN I SAY FEW I MEAN A LOTS?
I STARTED CHICO STATE WHEN I WAS
EIGHTEEN WORKED THREE JOBS WHILE
TAKING A FULL LOAD SCHOOL AND IT
DIDN'T TAKE LONG THAT IT WAS A
RECIPE FOR FAILURE WHEN I HAD TO
DROP OUT BECAUSE I COULD MAKE
THE BILL'S.
I WORKED A FEW YEARS FINALLY
GETTING A JOB WITH A STABLE WAGE
AT TWENTY SIX I WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
A FEW YEARS LATER AYE SIR GO TO
SAC STATE. AT ANY TIME I COULD
HAVE GIVEN A INTO TEMPTATION AND
AND CHEAPEST OPTION BUT I KEPT
GOING. NOW I WORK FORTY HOURS A
WEEK AND I AM TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT
DEBT.
SO I ASK YOU TO FROM THE
COLLEGES ACCORDINGLY SO THAT
STUDENTS WHO ARE MORE BEERS THAN
I HAD CAN ALSO HAVE A CHANCE AT
AFFORDABLE EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS A DAY YOU
FOR TAKING TIME LISTEN TO ALL OF
OUR COMMENTS.
MINE IS A BLOW TO THEM WHEN I
KNOW I COME FROM SAC STATE.
BUT I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF TO
SPEAK FROM MY COMMUNITY DOWN IN
BAKERSFIELD I COME FROM A LOW
INCOME HIGH SCHOOL.
AND.
.
MYSELF AND MANY OTHER STUDENTS.
HAVE A HARD TIME WE WERE ALWAYS
TOLD THAT IF WE'VE DO WE WORK
HARD THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE.
OUR DREAMS
AND.
MANY OF MY FRIENDS WERE NOT ABLE
TO MAKE IT OUT OF BIGGEST WILL
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN IF THEY
CANNOT AFFORD A CEASE YOU
EDUCATION OR YOU SEE EDUCATION.
.
SAW HOPE THEY.
Y. PRIESTHOOD YOU HAS TAKEN THE
TIME LISTEN TO US AND I HOPE
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER
TO.
FINER RESOLUTION FOR THESE
OBSTACLES BIG. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE BACK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE WERE DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET CONTINUED THE FUNDS
FOUGHT BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AND
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDS THAT
WERE EARMARKED FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION.
WE BELIEVE THERE INITIATIVE
CLEARLY STATED THAT THE UC
SHOULD BE ADMINISTRATOR OF THESE
FUNDS AND THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED STATEWIDE FOR.
EXPANDING.
RESIDENCIES AND PRIMARY CARE
AND FAMILY.
SORRY.
EMERGENCY MEDICINE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE GENERAL FUND
THAT WAS SWAPPED OUT RESTORED TO
UC'S BUDGET AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBER MISTER CHAIR TO
MAD REPRESENT THE.
THE CALTRAIN CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN KALRA BURSAE FISSIONS
WE CONCUR WITH THIS BOX COMMENTS
FOR THEM THE CALVARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION BEFORE US WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT LAST
YEAR.
I MEAN YOUR ACTIONS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING MORE DETAILS
IN FUTURE HEARINGS AROUND THE
PROPERTY SIXTEEN MAY SWAP.
MISTER CHAIR BARBARA GLAZER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION I TOO AM
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
RESTORING FUNDS TO YOU SEE PRIME
THE PROP FIFTY SIX WHAT'S. ON
THE INTENT OF THE INITIATIVE WAS
TO GROW THE NUMBER OF RESIDENTS.
TRAINED AND EDUCATED IN THE
STATE SO THAT WE'LL HAVE MORE
POSITIONS AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
STOP THIS ON FROM OCCURRING FOR
THE SECOND YEAR IN A ROW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
MAYOR MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO ECHOING TH PART
OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR AYE AND.
YOUR CONTINUED ACTION TO TRY TO
RESTORE THE CUTS TO THE UC
SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROP FIFTY SIX GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION EDUCATION FUNDS. GO TO
ALL OF THE ENTITIES THAT WERE
OPEN TO GET THEM INCLUDING MY
EIGHT HOSPITALS THAT PROVIDE
OVER FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY SLOTS IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M SURE COULD GET
US AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UC STERN ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT STUDENTS
TIME OUT OF THEIR DAY TODAY TO
PART OF THIS DIALOGUE. AND TO
SHARE THEIR STORIES WITH YOU AND
I NEED YOU TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ARE THESE ARE UNIQUE STORY
IS A TO THOSE WHO HAVE SPOKEN
WHO ARE IN THIS ROOM BUT THESE
OUR SHARED EXPERIENCES. AMONG
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE FUNDS
AREN'T ADEQUATELY FUNDS THE YOU
SEE BECAUSE A BIRD AND SHOULD
NOT BE PLACED ON THE BACKS OF
STUDENTS. STUDENTS ARE TIRED
STUDENTS ARE ALERT AND WE ARE
HERE TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE.
BUT THE QC RECEIVES FUNDING FROM
THE STATE AND WE ARE COUNTING ON
YOU AUTUMN BEST THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE AND THAT STARTS BY
INVESTING IN OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO ALL MY NAME IS TAREQ FUNNY
ON STAFF WITH THE GOVERNMENT
WITH THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
HERE YOU'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
OF OUR YOU SEE STUDENTS TODAY
ABOUT THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
FURTHER STATE INVESTMENT TO THE
UC. AS YOU ALL KNOW THE STATE
SHARE OF YOU SEE SOON FUNDING
HAS PLUMMETED FROM OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO ABOUT HALF THAT COSTS
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN MEANWHILE
TUITION AND FEES ARE DRASTICALLY
INCREASE. WHICH PLACES GREATER
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON OUR STUDENTS
SO WE'RE ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
TAKE IN THE STORIES THAT YOU'VE
BEEN HEARING TODAY AND JOIN US
IN ADEQUATELY FUNDING AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS NEEDED TO FUND
THE UC'S CRITICAL NEEDS AND
AVERT YET ANOTHER TWITCH AN
INCREASE THIS. YEAR THANK YOU.
BURGER GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH COMMUNICABLE IT'S DISTRICT
AND.
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO.
NOTE THAT DUE TO THE RECENT.
INCREASES IN THE ECONOMY AND
HIGH SCHOOL ENROLLMENT DECLINING
AS WELL AS COMMUNICATIVE ROMAN
DECLINING.
WE JUST KNOW THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR.
INCREASE RESTORATION FUNDING
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS AT THE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LEVEL SO
THAT WAKES ME COLLEGES CAN CAN.
PACK CAN CONTINUE TO.
ENROLL THE SAME NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IF NOT MORE THANK YOU.
BRIAN NOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED THE TO GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON MY COLLEGE IN THE
FUNDING FORMULA.
THE CURRENT.
ONLINE EDUCATION THE SHOULD
HAVE ALREADY DIES WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WE WANT YOU
TO EXPAND ON THAT PROGRAM.
FOR IS THE FUNDING FORMULAS
CONCERNED WE ARE VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSED ANY TYPE OF.
OUTCOMES OR PERFORMANCE SPACE A
MECHANISM ATTACHED TO IT THANK
YOU.
BUT FUTURE NICHOLAS CHVEZ ON
BEHALF OF SADDAM ON COLLEGE WE
PRESENT THE FOCUS ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT BASED
PERSON FOCUS FUNDING FROM WHEN
THE BUDGET. REQUEST SLIGHTLY
MORE AT FOCUS ON THE BASS GRANT
PROPONENT OF THE FORMULA.
AB BOTH CREDIT AND NONCREDIT F.
T. E. S. REIMBURSEMENT RATES AS
A BE REYES CLOSER TO THE CURRENT
LAW. RECOGNIZING THE CURRENT
COST REQUIRED TO RUN QUALITY
TRANSFER AND WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION TAKE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR EVENING.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE.
TWO PARTICULAR ITEMS ON IT WEEK
IN REGARD TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE.
.
THAT PERFORMANCE BASED METRIC
WHAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER ON ONE OF THE AND PANEL
MEMBERS TODAY MENTION STUDENT
SUCCESS METRICS AND ACCESS TO
FACULTY.
ENCOURAGES STUDENT SUCCESS SO WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT CHANGING SOME OF THE
pSOME OF THOSE FUNDING FORMULAS
AND ALSO AND CHOOSE TO
THROUGHOUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
NUMBER OF COMPLEXITIES THAT
WE'RE NOW REALIZING WITHIN THE
K. TWELVE TIED. ON THE LC FF.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ASK
THE QUESTION.
IS THE CURRENT UP POSE WILL
GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
ASSUME THE INCREASE COSTIKYAN
COLLEGE DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO
BE FACING IN THE FUTURE IS THAT
GOING TO BE. NOT JUST MINIMAL
ADEQUATE AND IS THAT GOING TO
ENABLE COMMUNICATE USED TO BE
TRULY SUCCESSFUL YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD A NUMBER OF ISSUES
REGARDING ONLINE.
BUT WHAT I WOULD KNOW IS HOW WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FINDING THE
BEST WAY TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S LAID OUT.
BUT WE'RE VERY CONCERNED WITH
SOME CONFLICTS OF INTEREST WHEN
IT COMES TO PROP NINETY EIGHT.
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE CONSTITUTIONAL CONFLICTS
WITH A STRUCTURED PROPOSAL FOR
HOW THAT SYSTEMS INITIALLY SET
UP WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS
IMPERATIVE MEETING COMFORT IS
NOT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH. DISCUSSIONS UNLESS WE
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LEVER ORGAN TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL FACULTY
ARE GOING TO BE PROPERLY
REPRESENTED. THE ONLINE PROPOSAL
ITSELF IS HEAVILY DEPENDENT UPON
PART TIME TOO MANY COLLEGE
FACULTY AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY PART TIME
COMMITTEE COLLEGE FACULTY DO NOT
ALWAYS HAVE ACCESS TO OFFICE
HOURS. AND SO IF YOU'RE GONNA
RELY PREDOMINANTLY ON A PART
TIME POPULATION ARE YOU CAN
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY MAY NEED EVEN
MORE SUPPORT FROM THE FACULTY.
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE OUR
ACCESS TO THE FACULTY THAT
THEY'RE SERVING WILL BE SHARING
MANY OF THESE COMMENTS BUT
WANTED TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE SOME
STRUCTURAL CONCERNS THAT NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT.
HI I SPOKE ALREADY BUDGETS ONE
TWO MESSAGE RELAY A MESSAGE ON
MY FRIEND WHO'S A DOCUMENT
KILEY.
WHO'S CURRENTLY OCCUPYING THE
SAFETY OFF.
MOVE FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
DISCUSSION REVOLVING AROUND
TALKING IMMIGRANTS AS WELL NOT
JUST TALK RECIPIENTS LINDA
CHRISTIANS AS A WHOLE.
VISIT AS A CHARACTER.
THEN I RECEIVE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID THERE WAS A LOAN
PROGRAM INTRODUCED ABOUT WE
SHOULD DO BETTER THAN OFFERING
LOANS BECAUSE NOT ALL STUDENTS
WITH WITHOUT DOCTOR CAN AFFORD
TO HIRE. JOBS AFTER COLLEGE SO
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING I HOPE YA
CONSIDER. ODD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT YOUR
TESTIMONY FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
THAT WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
THE MEETING.
I